Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Bist du in einer Schutzhebe?
Nein.
Warum nicht? Du hast doch jetzt gelesen, wie wichtig es ist, in einer Schutz-Ehe zu sein.
Wäre ich ein guter Ehemann.
Wartest du noch drauf, unter die Fittiche genommen zu werden? Vielleicht bist du der Schützling in der Schutz-Ehe. Was ist eine Schutz-Ehe?
Eine Schutz-Ehe ist eine Ehe, die man eingehen kann mit einer Person, die einen Aufenthaltsstatus hat, der eher prekär ist, sprich, die könnte abgeschoben werden diese Person. Nun könnte man sich einfach sagen, warum nicht heiraten? Denn dann ist diese Person plötzlich geschützt, kann also dann nicht mehr nachts rausgeklingelt werden und abgeführt und in ein Flugzeug gesetzt werden. Es gibt tatsächlich Leute, die diese Schutz-Ehen eingehen. Das ist natürlich auch gar nicht so ohne. Man muss meistens dann noch mal vor Gericht auch beweisen, dass das eine richtige Ehe ist. Also Ehe ist ja nicht einfach nur, ich gebe jetzt mal so eine Unterschrift und von fortan sind wir verheiratet. Dann würden die nachfragen und sagen, ja, also, wie, sie wohnen in Koblenz und der andere in Frankfurt. Herr Schulz, wie ist denn das, wer macht dann die Wäsche bei ihnen? Also die fragen ja tatsächlich intime Fragen und wollen wissen, ob wirklich eine Ehe gelebt wird. Oder ob es sich um irgendein... Ob man Bett und Tisch teilt, so hieß es dann im Gesetz. Das ist ein Arrangement, denn theoretisch könnte man ja auch andere Schutz-Ehen bilden. Also man könnte ja jetzt auch dazu übergehen, Witwen, die über 80 sind, zu heiraten, um von denen noch eine Rente oder steuerfrei erben zu können. Also diese Modelle sollen ja so ein bisschen ausgeschossen werden. Aber eine Schutz-Ehe ist natürlich möglich, ist ja auch wahrscheinlich, wenn man sich informiert, dann machbar einzugehen. Ist aber wirklich ein sehr großer Schritt, denn man muss natürlich auch sehr viel Vertrauen mit hineingeben. Denn eine Ehe bedeutet ja auch ganz viele Verpflichtungen, die man mit eingeht. Also es ist nicht einfach so eine stille Patenschaft irgendwo in einem fernen Land. Aber man sieht hier schon, eigentlich ist hier sofort das Individuum auch angesprochen. Also was könnte ich tun? Und das ist ja eine Frage, die sich wie ein Leitmotiv durch das gesamte Buch von Arne Semsrott zieht.
Aber der muss noch kurz bei den Schutzehen bleiben.
Ich will das nur sagen, die Machtübernahme bedeutet ja, die Macht kann jederzeit von jemand anderem übernommen werden. Und was tut man, damit das nicht geschieht? Wie kann man Machtübernahmen verhindern? Oder wie kann man selbst die Macht übernehmen, damit andere es nicht tun?
Also diese Schutzehe kommt am Ende. Wenn wir dann im Verlauf durchkommen, erst gegen Ende, dann kommen wir dahin. Aber mir ist dann aufgefallen, dass es mir an dem Punkt zu wenig diskutiert wurde, was zu diskutieren ist. Denn die Ehe kennen wir ja als das hohe heilige Familienbündnis, das in Deutschland besondere Privilegien, nicht nur steuerlich, sondern auch so informationstechnisch usw. genießt. Und die wird ja durchaus eingegangen. Und sei es nur, weil Männer sich vor Einsamkeit schützen wollen, deswegen irgendwo nach Asien fahren, sich da eine Frau aussuchen, ihr sagen hier, komm doch mit mir nach Deutschland, wenn wir heiraten, ist sofort alles geregelt. Und das steht ja in einer Liste sozusagen mit anderen derartiger Beziehungen, wie zum Beispiel die Bedarfsgemeinschaft, die dir ja einfach übergestellt wird vom Sozialgesetzbuch. Sofern du im Haushalt mit jemandem lebst, der bedürftig ist, dann musst du sofort für ihn einspringen. Also der Staat hat sich selber Schutz-Ehen eingerichtet, Schutz-Ehen in Anführungszeichen, um sich vor zu hohen Kosten zu schützen. Da werden nämlich einfach Menschen in Beschlag genommen. Es gibt relativ nahe der Schutz-Ehe, wie Semsrott das vorstellt, die Bürgschaft für Zugezogene. Was ja bedeutet, 2015 zum Beispiel kann hier jemand die Bürgschaft für jemanden übernehmen, was dann bedeutet, man ist fünf Jahre dieser Person ausgeliefert, wirtschaftlich. Also wenn mit der irgendwas passiert, muss man selber gratis stehen. Man ist im Grunde so eine Haftpflichtschutzversicherung für diese Person, weshalb zivilgesellschaftliches Engagement relativ zügig ausgebremst wurde, einfach weil die Anforderung für die Bürgschaft da zu hoch ist. Oder die Vaterschaft. Das wird jetzt gerade diskutiert in Deutschland, weil bislang war es einfach so, man meldet Vaterschaften an. Und wir wissen ja, die soziale Vaterschaft ist viel wichtiger als die biologische. Alle Welt, alle Nachbarn, alle Freunde und Familie können wissen, die hat ihr Kind mit dem und dem bekommen, aber irgendwer anders erkennt die Vaterschaft an. Oder sie ist in ihr, dann ist es sowieso automatisch der Ehemann. Das wird jetzt auch so ein bisschen diskutiert, aber nicht um da Gerechtigkeit reinzuholen, sondern auch um den Staat wieder davor zu schützen, dass hier irgendwelche Kinder Schutz genießen, nur weil irgendein Vater gegen Geld eine Vaterschaft anerkennt. Also das Prinzip der Schutz-Ehe hätte man ganz krass diskutieren können, indem man dem Staat vorwirft, du hast dich doch selber schon in die Lage gebracht, Schutz-Ehen mit anderen Begriffen, wie ich es dir jetzt vorgestellt habe, zu formulieren, um dich zu schützen vor dem Ansprüchen deines Bürgers. Wer also dieses Buch liest, kann ganz unvermittelt am Ende auf diese Schutz-Ehe stoßen und sich denken, ne, das geht aber ein bisschen zu weit jetzt. Ich soll jetzt jemanden heiraten, um irgendwie Schutz einzugehen? Während der Staat seinerseits, da finde ich, ein bisschen über dich streng geschlägt. Also gerade bei Bedarfsgemeinschaften, dass da einfach gesagt wird, sie leben doch da zusammen, sie sind in einer Schutz-Ehe. Wir sind geschützt vor ihnen. Also in deren Sicht hat dieses Buch einige Überraschungen, die dann auch unausformuliert bleiben. Und dann startet eben, ich habe es ja im Vorgespräch schon gesagt, das ist ja wirklich crazy, aber im Wortlaut schon ganz eindrücklich, in diesem Buch werden immer wieder Szenarien durchgespielt, die die Konsequenzen einer rechtsextremistischen Machtübernahme behandeln. Diese stellen keine Tatsachenbehauptung dar, sondern skizzieren als Meinung und stilistisches Mittel einen möglichen Verlauf der Zukunft. Was ja im Grunde ausformuliert dieser Spruch ist. Pornografie, keine Ahnung, wie man das definiert, aber wenn ich sehe, erkenne ich es. Rechtsradikalismus, ich kann jetzt nicht so ganz genau sagen, was ich damit meine, aber wenn ich es fühle, ist es das. Und er sagt halt auch, wir wollen uns mal reinfühlen in dieses politische Problem. Und das finde ich sehr wirkmächtig und sehr mutig, das am Anfang sozusagen.
Und er sagt weiter, es sagt sehr viel über unsere Gegenwart aus, dass wir beim Lesen oft nicht sagen können, ob es sich hier um die Realität oder ein Szenario handelt. Dieser Effekt würde verloren gehen, wäre jede dieser Stellen markiert. Grundsätzlich gilt, überall, wo Quellen angegeben sind, wird auf reale Ereignisse verwiesen. Und das kann man dann natürlich im Anhang nachvollziehen. Aber es ist wirklich erstaunlich, wenn man es liest, dass man sich an vieles plötzlich wiedererinnert, was ja schon eingeführt wurde. Also wo mit anderen Worten rechtsextreme Politik gemacht wird, ohne dass die AfD die Macht übernommen hat. Und damit zeigt er also auch einen allgemeinen Rechtsruck. Also ich glaube, man redet von dem Rechtsruck immer und blickt auf Umfragen, blickt auf Parwahlen. Aber man muss wirklich diesen Rechtsruck nochmal ganz klar als etwas sehen, was durch die Gesellschaft durchsickert, was alles dann prägt, wo also an kleinen Stellschrauben ständig etwas verändert wird. Und damit rückt es nach rechts. Es ist nicht so ein einziger Ruck, sondern es sind ganz viele Bewegungen, die dorthin führen. Und ich finde, es ist wirklich eine große Leistung dieses Buches. Und ich glaube, damit unterscheidet es sich auch von 99,9 Prozent aller anderen Bücher, die jetzt sagen, wir leben die Demokratie und haken uns unter. Dass dieses Buch genau weiß, wie die Gesellschaft funktioniert, welche Institutionen wichtig sind, welche Apparate es gibt und welche Macht eine AfD-Downdote haben könnte. Es wird ja nicht einfach so getan, ja und dann wird der Führerkult installiert und dann ist wieder Nationalsozialismus. Aber dass er einfach zeigt, wie verändert sich das vor Gericht, wie verändert sich das Downdote, da geht das alles durch. Also vorab schon mal dieses Lob, dass ich es wirklich großartig finde, wie gut sich hier jemand auskennt. Und er ist ja jemand, der als Journalist tätig ist und der mit fragt den Staat ja schon dafür gesorgt hat, mit seinem Team, dass 150-mal staatliche Stellen verklagt wurden. Also er weiß genau, wo die Macht sitzt, wo die blinden Flecke sind. Und das jetzt hier durchzuarbeiten, ist wirklich hervorragend.
Und nicht nur klagt er häufig gegen den Staat, sondern er lässt sich auch immer mal strategisch verklagen, zuletzt vor Bundespräsidenten und so. Also da findet einiges statt. Ich will zu Beginn noch mal kurz auf das Stilmittel, also man kann jetzt so ein paar Namen finden, irgendwie so emotionale Antizipation oder so. Also dass man da so rangeht. An einem Beispiel mal zeigen. Er schreibt, es ist Sonntag, 18.03. Wahlnacht. In Erfurt, Dresden und Berlin, das ist für uns die kommenden Landtagswahlen. Sachsen, Thüringen, Brandenburg wählen. Und in Berlin führt das zur Aufruhr. Knallen die Sektkorken, die AfD hat bei den Wahlen so viele Stimmen wie noch nie geholt. 31 Prozent, stärkste Kraft. Die Fernsehkameras fangen in den Parteizentralen von SPD und Grünen geschockte Blicke ein, aber wirklich überrascht ist niemand. Wir werden nicht davon überrascht sein, wenn das dann so passiert, weil diese 31 Prozent werden antizipiert, je nachdem, was Sarah Wagenknecht da noch bewegt und wie auch immer. Im Verlauf dieses Textes, wo dann behandelt wird, Journalisten laden dann natürlich die Wahlgewinner ein, natürlich steht die AfD ganz normal mit am Tisch der Elefantenrunden, wie auch immer, fallen dann so Sätze wie, ja die CDU konnte ja dann gar nicht anders als Koalition eingehen, weil staatspolitische Verantwortung. Und das ist für uns natürlich, also es war ein richtiger Trigger, weil dieses staatspolitische Verantwortung, wir wissen noch, wie sich die SPD gewehrt hat dagegen, mit der CDU in eine große Koalition zu gehen. Und am Ende kam der Bundespräsident und hat gesagt, ihr müsst staatspolitische Verantwortung. Und wenn er jetzt antizipiert, dass es zu einem Szenario kommt, in dem in Thüringen dann geplant und auf Dauer ein Ministerpräsident von entweder der AfD oder von AfDs Gnaden gewählt wird, wird uns das erklärt werden mit staatspolitischer Verantwortung. Also hier antizipiert das Buch einfach, was kommen wird, mit Sätzen, die schon waren. Denn im Verlauf dieser Wahlnachts-Szenerie schreibt er auch, auf der Bühne wird gesagt, wir holen unser Land zurück. Ja, das wurde auf der Bühne schon mal gesagt. Das ist die 2017er Wahl, Gauland und so weiter. Also in der Ansicht haben wir es hier mit einem Buch zu tun, dass wir erst mal lesen können, weil der Autor sich hier wirklich auskennt und uns nicht eine Sonntagsrede oder irgendetwas oder so Michel-Friedmann-Style schon ganz nah dran an den ursächlichen und elementaren des Menschen, aber nicht auf Tagesaktueller Höhe. Die Flughöhe hier in diesem Buch stimmt einfach ganz genau.
Ja, und diese Pragmatik ist auch gut, um zu erkennen, ja Macht ist eine pragmatische Sache. Das ist nicht irgendetwas, was einfach so vom Himmel kommt, sondern um Macht muss man kämpfen. Wir haben eben Adam Toos gehört im Teaser, wie er vom Bulldozer spricht. Und er buchstabiert ja dieses Szenario noch weiter aus. Da heißt es, als die Hochrechnungen bestätigen, dass eine Regierung ohne Beteiligung der AfD kaum möglich sein wird, weil einige Parteien an der 5-%-Hürde scheitern und die CDU nicht mit der Linkspartei zusammenarbeiten will, werden in der ARD die Parteivorsitzenden interviewt. Der CDU-Vorsitzende, der noch während des Wahlkampfes ausgeschlossen hatte, mit der AfD zu koalieren, spricht jetzt die Möglichkeit, an eine AfD-Minderheitsregierung zu tolerieren. Das Wichtigste sei, so der Vorsitzende, das Land vor dem Chaos zu bewahren. Er betont die staatspolitische Verantwortung der Union. Kennen wir all diese Reden. Weiter heißt es dann, als die ARD-Moderatorin dem AfD-Vorsitzenden in der Elefantenrohende kritische Fragen zu seinen frauenfeindlichen Aussagen im Wahlkampf stellt, ergießt sich in den sozialen Medien eine Flut aus Hass und Hetze über sie. So dürfte man nicht mit einem Wahlsieger sprechen, kommentiert ein Kolumnist der Welt in einem hastig geschriebenen Online-Text, der auf x-vielfach geteilt wird. Immerhin sei die AfD demokratisch gewählt. Und das war das, was ich eben so angesprochen habe, dieser ganze Diskurs über die Verhinderung oder gewollte Verhinderung des AfD-Parteitags. Es ist ja einfach, dass man jetzt von dem konservativen Lager sehr oft hört, ja, das ist ja eine demokratische Partei, also könnt ihr jetzt nicht die Demokratie verhindern. Also seid ihr doch die, die auf der Straße protestiert, die eigentlichen Feinde der Demokratie. Und da sagt Semsrott, nee, es gibt einen fundamentalen oder einen kategorialen Unterschied. Der AfD wird alles dafür tun, ihren Bulldozer rauszuholen und alles platz zu machen, was man unter einem liberaldemokratischen Staat versteht.
Genau. Bulldozer gegen Wünschenswert wäre ein Bulldozer, ist so der Grundtenor. Und er weist eben darauf hin, die AfD kann nicht zaubern. Wer jetzt will, dass sie entzaubert werden, nee, die sind ja in einer völlig falschen Kategorie. Der Rechtsextremismus ist keine unaufhaltsames Ereignis wie eine Lawine. Und er wird ja tatsächlich häufig so behandelt. Im amerikanischen Fernsehen nicht mehr so sehr, was die GOP angeht, aber im deutschen Fernsehen ist ja der AfD-Wähler die dunkle Masse. Unansprechbar, unadressierbar. Und er geht ja ganz konkret darauf ein, nee, die AfD holt sich dann den Matenstein, um so einen Verein für die deutsche Sprache zu gründen. Und der Kommentar an der Wahlnacht, an den sich alle dranhängen bei Twitter, kommt aus der Welt. Also, da wird das einfach expliziert, statt hier irgendwie so, oh ja, und dann ist plötzlich der Rechtsextremismus da. Nein, der Rechtsextremismus ist eine von Menschen angetriebene Gefahr. Und er kann auch jederzeit von Menschen gestoppt werden. Man muss es halt nur organisieren. Statt das so als Naturereignis, ja, jetzt ist Hitze, sagen wir mal, so können wir nichts machen. Jetzt ist Hitze, jetzt ist AfD. Wir sind dem ausgeliefert. Für sein Buch hat er vor allem seine eigenen Erfahrungen mit Frag den Staat genommen und 70 Gespräche geführt und du hast ja eben schon gesagt, er braucht ja auch immer mal wieder diese juristischen oder sagen wir mal so, fragt der Stab alleine, ist ja schon eine juristische Einrichtung. Also da liegt Expertise vor und die sind nun mal gezwungen, damit sehr viele Menschen zu reden. Also aus diesen Gesprächen münden dann einfach hier diese Szenarien. Wir können ja mal aus dem Inhaltsverzeichnis, ich habe es mal direkt rauskopiert, Schritte 1 bis 10 sind in Überschriftenform gar nicht so aussagekräftig. Der erste vielleicht AfD an der Macht, dann wird erstmal das Personal ausgewechselt, dann wird Personal angewiesen, dann wird der Geldhahn auf oder zugedreht, je nachdem in welche Richtung. Dann allerdings Schritt 4, Skandal nach Skandal, Gesetze ändern, weitere Vernetzung, Grenzen austesten, Wiederwahl, größere Projekte und dranbleiben. Also ich würde sagen, wir können hier schon rauslesen, Bulldozer. Also dieses, wie fährt Adam Two's Bulldozer mit falschen Vorzeichen einmal durch die Institutionslandschaft?
Ja, und de facto ist ja Arne Semsrott jemand, der genau weiß, wie dieser Bulldozer ständig gebraucht wird von den anderen. Und er macht ja jetzt eigentlich was ganz Simples. Er sagt, die AfD könnte sich orientieren, zum Beispiel an der CDU, die hat da den Bulldozer rausgeholt. Oder die FDP ist darauf aus, das Personal da und dort zu wechseln. Also er weiß ja sehr viel. Er sagt zum Beispiel, dass es ja die politischen Beamten gibt. Davon gibt es aber dann gar nicht viele. Er sagt, ausgetauscht werden von der AfD deswegen zunächst die sogenannten politischen Beamten. Die anderen kann man nicht so leicht loswerden. Also diejenigen, die eine Regierung ohne Probleme ersetzen darf. In Ministerien zählen dazu die Leitungsebene, sowie Staatssekretäre und Abteilungsleiter. In einer großen Behörde wie dem Bundesinnenministerium geht es dabei zunächst um lediglich rund 20 von 1.700 Stellen, die allerdings besonders wichtig sind. Je nach Ebene sind teilweise auch die Leitungen der nachgeordneten Behörden wie Bundes- und Landesämter für verfassungsschutzpolitische Beamte im Bund. Und unter anderem die Botschafter und der Generalbundesanwalt in Hessen seit 2021 zudem der Chef des Landeskriminalamts. Also wenn man dann mal in die Sache tiefer reingeht, merkt man schon, okay, also man kann doch auch, wenn man nur 20 Leute austauscht, offenbar sehr, sehr viel bewegen.
Ja, über die Stimmungsmache holt er uns ja dann auch wieder empirisch ab. Also auf die Behördenleitung hat man sofort Zugriff, Verordnungen kann man erlassen. Wenn man es im Ministerium besetzt, hat man Polizeigeheimdienste und Asylbehörden. Das ist sozusagen Zukunftsmusik. Und dann werden wir wieder eingefangen. Wir erinnern uns ja, wenn nur die Lage dann entsprechend ist, hat man plötzlich ein BAMF-Skandal, bei dem wir nachhinein wissen, da war nichts dran. Trotzdem wurde da eine Behörde in der Leitung ausgewechselt. Damals noch von Seehofer als Innenminister. Und das muss man sich jetzt vorstellen, flankiert mit ein rechter Blog, schreibt so einen Skandal hoch über irgendeine Ausländerbehörde, in dem Fall dann die Bremer. Der Minister erteilt einen Einbürgerungsstopp. Der ist zwar rechtswidrig, aber Klagen kosten Zeit. Und am Ende hat die Verwaltung immer den längeren Atem. Weil sobald ein Gericht kommt und sagt, dürft ihr so nicht machen, sagen die, ach so, anders. Dann formulieren wir den halt anders. Also das kennt man ja wieder von Trump. Dass da einfach drei Versuche hintereinander gemacht werden, bis dann irgendwie so ein Muslim-Einwanderungsstopp da einfach gilt. Und unter der Schirmherrschaft, das ist dann die Landschaftspflege, unter der Schirmherrschaft von Harald Martenstein soll ein neues staatlich gefördetes Institut für die deutsche Sprache geschaffen werden. Und wir haben ja gerade eine Diskussion über diesen Verein deutscher Sprache, der da völlig durchdreht. Also das ist so eine Verquickung aus Antizipationen politischer Realität mit schon erlebter und gelebter politischer Realität, die einem wirklich ein bisschen gruseln lässt.
Ja, ein weiteres Beispiel.
Gerade weil er sich traut, diese ganzen Namen dann auch zu nennen. Das nennt ja einfach Harald Martenstein.
Das ist genau richtig. Was ich auch so gut finde, ist, dass er schon so eine Stimmung hier abgreift, die da ist. Wir alle wissen, dass es ständig solche Artikel gab in Zeitungen oder auch in Talkshows, wo so Äußerungen gemacht wurden. Ja, dieser ganze Gestank aus den Shisha-Bars und das ist alles so merkwürdig. Naja, und wir wissen, es gibt schon mal so eine grundsätzliche Stimmung in einem großen Teil der Bevölkerung, dass Shisha-Bars irgendwie nicht so toll sind. Also wir wollen die Kneipen haben, aber bitte keine Shisha-Bars.
Deutschland aber normal.
Jaja, und dann schreibt er hier, wie geht ein AfD-Politiker vor, der Innenminister wird? Nein, im Bundesland weiß er beispielsweise die Polizei an, Kontrollen in Bezug auf bestimmte Delikte auszuweiten, die im Zusammenhang mit Drogenkriminalität stehen. Auch Bagatelldelikte sollen konsequenter verfolgt werden als bisher. Offiziell erklärtes Ziel ist es, die Kriminalitätsrate zu senken. Dafür sei es wichtig, entschieden aufzutreten. Die Polizisten sollen Razzien und Kontrollen in Shisha-Bars und Döner-Embissen weiter verstärken. Unter dem Vorwand, Clan-Kriminalität zu bekämpfen, sollen sie auch in bestimmten Regionen Kontrollen verstärkt von Personen auf der Straße durchführen, die einer Clan-Struktur zugehörig sein könnten. Und hinter den Kulissen heißt es, mit ausreichend Druck könnten mehr Menschen zu einer freiwilligen Ausreise aus Deutschland gedrängt werden. Also das heißt, man kann mit dem Gesetz, das jetzt da ist, also man muss da nicht groß was ändern, sondern man kann durch Anweisungen dafür sorgen, dass sich ein Fokus irgendwo hin verschiebt, zum Beispiel auf Shisha-Bars. Und dann findet dort eine strukturelle Diskriminierung statt, die sogar so weit führen kann, dass Leute freiwillig die Ausreise erwägen. Also da zeigt man sehr gut, wie dann eine rechte Politik stattfinden kann, ohne dass gleich das ganze Grundgesetz über Bord geworfen werden muss. Also ich fand das so ein bisschen fahl, dass sich dann doch von Richard David Precht im Mazi-Hilscher-Podcast, wo er dann überlegte oder auch bei Tilo sagte er das. Ich glaube, bei Tilo war es dann besonders, wie es dann sein könnte, wie würde denn das Szenario aussehen, wenn die AfD Ministerpräsidenten stellt. Ja, de facto können die dann noch nicht am ganz großen Rad drehen. Aber man sieht dann doch so schrittweise, was alles möglich ist. Also wie sehr man vielen Menschen in Deutschland das Leben zur Hölle machen kann, ohne dass man ein Grundgesetz ändert oder so.
Ja und er nennt nach den politischen Verwaltungsapparaten die Justiz. Der größte Feind im System der Gewalten ist für die AfD die Justiz. Man kann dann über Richter, Wahlausschüsse, Einfluss auf die Besetzung von Gerichtspräsidenten erlangen. Das sind zwar alles langwierige und zähe Prozesse, aber im Konflikt Staat gegen Justiz, die einen da immer wieder beschränkt in seinen politischen Handeln, hat die Verwaltung meist den längeren Atem. Und dann kommt er das erste Mal auf zivilgesellschaftlichen Widerstand und erinnert uns, damals vor 100 Jahren, 1920er Jahre, die Eiserne Front, ein Bündnis aus SPD-nahen Organisationen wie dem reichsbraunen Schwarz-Rot-Gold, dem Arbeiter-Turn- und Sportbund und dem Allgemeinen Deutschen Gewerkschaftsbund hatte sich 1931 gegründet und wollte gegen solcher Arten vorgehen, scheiterte letztlich an den vergrößteten Strukturen der SPD. Steht da nicht einfach. Und das soll uns natürlich einfach, die Geschichte wiederholt sich hier. Vergrößtete Strukturen der SPD, ja, also da sind halt viele junge Leute schon drin, aber es ist halt trotzdem eine vergrößtete Struktur. Und als Zweites nennt er dann aktuell, dass derzeit in zahlreichen staatlich finanzierten Demokratie-Initiativen hektische Betriebsamkeit herrscht. Denn hier muss man natürlich schon antizipieren, dass irgendwann irgendwo die AfD regierungsbeteiligt ist. Ja, also ein sehr gelungener Historienbogenschlag.
Das ist ja sowieso das, was man sich im Amt klaren sein muss, wenn man jetzt irgendetwas macht. Dann muss man sich immer fragen, ist das, was man gerade eingeführt hat, auch unter einer AfD klug, dass man es eingeführt hat? Also wenn man eine bestimmte Form von Überwachung einführt, also ich bin generell gegen zu viel Überwachung, aber wenn man eine bestimmte Form von Überwachung einführt, dann muss man schon mal antizipieren, was das bedeuten würde, wenn Ministerpräsident Höcke dieses Überwachungstool nutzen kann.
Überwachung oder alle anderen Mittel? Also eine Bezahlkarte oder so?
Bezahlkarte, also diese ganzen Dinge. Welche Sachen stehen dann also der AfD zur Verfügung und welche kann sie dann nochmal ganz anders für sich nutzen? Auch interessant ist, dass hier so mehrmals herausgearbeitet wird, dass die AfD zwar noch nicht bei der ersten Wahl die ganz großen Veränderungen machen kann, aber man kann durchaus schon sehr viel auf den Weg bringen, was dann für eine Wiederwahl sorgen könnte. Und weiter heißt es dann, umfassende Gesetzesprojekte kann die AfD in ihrer ersten Regierungsphase nicht umsetzen. Sie breitet sich allerdings präzise darauf vor. Sie will in der darauffolgenden Legislaturperiode einen Volkskanzler installieren, der mit seiner Regierungsmehrheit Einfluss auf die Besetzung der Bundes- und Landesverfassungsgerichte nehmen und diese für seine politischen Ziele instrumentalisieren kann. Als Vorbild dient ihr die italienische Premierministerin Giorgia Miloni. Also auch hier nochmal der direkte Verweis. Die können schon mal da gucken, wie man das eigentlich macht. Und er schreibt dann weiter, der rechtsextremen Politikerin gelingt es, sich als so gewöhnlich darzustellen, dass sie auch international von EU-Partnern wie Olaf Scholz und Emanuel Macron als Gesprächspartnerin respektiert und geachtet wird. Kritik an ihrer frauenfeindlichen und rassistischen Politik gibt es international kaum. Auch, dass sie die italienische Variante des Bürgergeld abschaffte, erzeugte keine große Resonanz in den Medien. Also auch hier wieder der direkte Verweis darauf. Die Medien sind ja auch immer wieder jetzt bei Miloni schon gewillt zu schreiben. Postfaschistin ja, aber sie macht es doch gar nicht so schlecht.
Und jetzt weist er uns darauf hin, wo der Widerstand beginnen muss. Er nimmt sich den Magdeburger Soziologen David Begrich und umrahmt den vorpolitischen Raum. Er zitiert ihn. Der wichtigste Ort der Politik im Osten ist das Grillfest. Und das gilt es zu gewinnen.
Ja, ich habe es immer wieder mal bei Vorträgen gesagt. Der vorpolitische Raum wird fundamental unterschätzt. Der vorpolitische Raum ist der Raum, wo die meisten Leute sich fast die ganze Zeit ihres Lebens aufhalten. Dann gehen sie nur mal ganz kurz in dieses Wahllokal und machen das Kreuz. Dann gehen sie sofort wieder zurück in den vorpolitischen Raum. Das heißt Grillfest, Sportverein etc.
Und die Demokratie ist so organisiert, dass sie das genauso möchte. Sie will uns ja nicht alle politisieren.
Und der vorpolitische Raum ist aber politisch. Denn dort fallen solche Äußerungen wie, wenn das so weitergeht, dann ist das nicht mehr Deutschland. Solche Sätze fallen da. Das findet alles im vorpolitischen Raum statt. Die Linken spinnen ja alle. Solche Sätze fallen dort. Das heißt, wenn man jetzt von der anderen Seite aus, von der linken Seite aus, den Wähler erobern will, dann muss man den vorpolitischen Raum erobern. Und das macht er hier wunderbar deutlich.
Also dieser vorpolitische Raum, ich will es auch für unsere HörerInnen mal sagen, wenn wir in der CASE gerade von der Bühne kommen, kommen ja manchmal Leute zu uns, die uns dann sagen, ich möchte dir kurz mein Dissertationsprojekt vorstellen. Und dann sage ich, mach es gerne, aber mach es so, wie du es machen würdest, wenn du gerade nach 10 Stunden Zug fahren, weil alle Züge zu spät sind und du siehst mich spontan auf dem Bahnhof, wie du es dann sagen würdest. Und nicht im Sinne von, ah ja, morgen sehe ich ja Stefan oder Wolfgang. Ich bereite mal meine Talking Points vor. Mir doch egal, dass sie sich gerade entspannen wollen und dass sie gerade zwei Stunden auf der Bühne waren oder was auch immer. Ich will ihnen jetzt erzählen, worüber ich meine Dissertation geschrieben habe. Also dieser vorpolitische Raum, das Grillfest, überall und wichtig, dass man das einfach akzeptiert und versteht und dann nicht über die Stränge schlägt. Und die ganze Zeit, deswegen macht er ja diesen großen Aufschlag, es ist nicht die Sonntagsrede des Bundespräsidenten, sondern, er sagt es ganz deutlich, es ist eine absurde Situation. Da gibt es Menschen, die genau das umsetzen, was Politiker in ihren Sonntagsreden fordern. Sie halten zusammen, stehen für die Demokratie ein, engagieren sich trotz der Einschüchterungen und den Drohungen und erhalten doch kaum konkrete Unterstützung. Also dieses ganze Integrationsförderung, Demokratieförderung, das wurde von der Ampel alles zurückgefahren. Das läuft alles unter, ne, wir können leider nur Sonntagsreden im Parlament halten. Der vorpolitische Raum, für den haben wir hier kein Geld. Und das ist eine absurde Situation, so wie er schreibt.
Und die sorgen damit mit diesen Kürzungen oder mit den ganzen Streichungen, die ja so fundamental sind, dass dann Vereine sich auflösen müssen, dafür, dass die AfD es immer einfacher hat. Nicht nur gewählt zu werden, sondern sie hat es auch einfacher, wenn sie an der Macht ist, zu sagen, gut, dann können wir die wenigen Gelder, die da sind, auch noch streichen. Das heißt, alles, was jetzt... Wir haben doch bei der Pandemie die ganze Zeit über das Präventionsparadox gesprochen. Da hat man gesagt, ja, wir haben jetzt niedrige Zahlen, weil wir uns vor drei Monaten schon darauf vorbereitet haben und haben uns zurückgezogen und was weiß ich alles. Und genau dieses Präventionsparadox hat man ja jetzt wieder, wenn man einfach Gelder kürzt. Aber man müsste jetzt eigentlich so viel Geld raufwerfen, wie es nur irgendwie möglich ist, um dann eine AfD-Regierung zu verhindern. Und dann kann man nicht am Ende sagen, das war aber Geldverschwendung. Nein, das Geld hat dann dafür gesorgt, dass Projekte entstehen konnten, die die AfD verhindern.
Ja, und von Seiten des Staates gibt es jetzt ein ganz großes Missverständnis. Ein Prinzip, an dem ich mich in meinem Buch über Familie dann auch sehr abarbeiten werde. Er schreibt, das Problem der demokratischen, zivilgesellschaftlichen Arbeit im Prinzip ist, dass die Engagierten sie aus Überzeugung machen. Und die Arbeit für den Staat so wahnsinnig billig ist. Das ist bei Familien ganz genauso. Familie, Kinder, die mütterliche Liebe wird es schon richten.
Punkt.
Und das war's. Und sich darauf zu verlassen, ist ein großer Fehler. Entweder man fördert das und nimmt es ernst und stellt es ins Zentrum der Gesellschaft, oder es gibt das einfach nicht.
Er sagt dann das, was wir auch mehrmals unterstrichen haben, als wir über diese Proteste gesprochen haben. Und man uns dann vorwirft, warum sollen sich denn da nicht... Man warf uns vor, dass wir Politiker ausschließen wollen. Wir sagten, ja, wollen wir auch. Wir wollen nicht, dass Politiker damit demonstrieren. Und er sagt dann auch, dass da Olaf Scholz und Baerbock und alle rumrennen und sich für die Demokratie aussprechen. Das sei inhaltsleer. Und er sagt, es fehlt die Einsicht, dass gerade die Mitglieder der Bundesregierung nicht bloß einfache Bürger sind. Es ist ihre Aufgabe, die richtigen Rahmenbedingungen für Demokratiearbeit zu setzen. Die Zivilgesellschaft ist nicht für die Wohnungskrise zuständig. Also ganz, ganz deutlich gesagt. Und dann macht er einen Vorschlag, hier einen Vorschlag. Die Bundesregierung und der Bundespräsident dürfen erst dann von der Bevölkerung Engagement für die Demokratie einfordern, wenn sie sich merkbar selbst dafür einsetzen, anstatt weiterzumachen wie bisher. Es würde ihnen gut anstehen, wenn sie von sich aus konkrete Maßnahmen umsetzen, wie die Demokratie gestärkt werden könnte. Dann können sie es auch von anderen fordern. Also dieser Aufstand der Anständigen und so, dann seid anständig. Also dann müsst ihr diese Gelder geben. Und er bringt ja auch diese Summen.
Ja, die Gelder.
Diese Gelder. Du hast ja auch schon toll diesen Banker, der Olarius, und hast das dann verglichen mit dem Bürgergeld. Oder was war das?
Also wir hatten auf der Bühne diese 13.000 Totalverweigerer, 170 Millionen, und wir haben eine Bürgergelddiskussion zum Thema. Aber wenn jemand 42 Millionen alleine für sich verbucht und das einer von Tausenden ist, die noch mal vor Gerichten müssten, dann werden die einfach alle aus gesundheitlichen Gründen freigesprochen. Und da geht es um 30-40 Milliarden Euro Cum-Ex.
Das größte Demokratie-Leuchtturm-Projekt der Bundesregierung heißt Demokratie leben. Wieviel bekommt dieses Projekt? Im Jahr knapp 200 Millionen Euro. Er schreibt zum Vergleich, so viel gibt die Bundesregierung 2024 für drei neue Luxushubschrauber der Flugbereitschaft aus. Die gescheiterte Rettung von Galleria Kaufhof kostete 590 Millionen Euro, der Cum-Ex-Skandal 32 Milliarden. Also man gibt 200 Millionen aus. Und dass das nicht genug sein kann, sollte eigentlich jedem einleuchten.
Und wieviel Geld er fordert, schreibt er dann. 200 Millionen Euro sind nicht genug. Es sollten 200 Milliarden Euro sein, die die Bundesregierung für Demokratie lieben ausgibt. Warum so viel? Und die Erklärung finde ich so gut. Wer vom Staat Millionen erhält, ist anerkannt. Wer Milliarden erhält, ist wichtig.
Man kann sobald auf der Bundesebene Politiker irgendetwas sagen mit Millionen, sofort weghören.
Er verweist dann auch direkt auf die Schuldenbremse. Was für die Bundeswehr möglich ist, soll da auch für die Demokratieförderung drin sein. Ich finde absolut, auch das muss man nochmal strapazieren, wir haben immer mal wieder diese kleine Pointe gebracht, wenn wir junge Menschen in den Krieg ins Ausland schicken, dann sollten wir ihnen vorher sagen, was sie verteidigen, denn so richtig einsehen tun sie nicht, dass sie gerade ihre Corona-Schulzeit, ihr Bologna-Studium und ihr G8-Abi verteidigen müssen, sondern man sollte ihnen nochmal erklären, was ist an der Heimatfront so wichtig für sie? Was verteidigen sie? Und in der Hinsicht, Verteidigung nach außen, immer nur mit inklusive Verteidigung nach innen. Wer 100 Milliarden für die Bundeswehr gibt, sollte erst einmal einen 100 Milliarden-Wert für die jungen Menschen schaffen in Deutschland, den sie dann verteidigen. Und nicht, wie wir es nachher lesen, einfach nur Gerichtsprozesse, weil sie einen Shampoo geklaut haben oder was auch immer. Also in Hinsicht hier sehr gut. Finde ich das Buch fast noch ein bisschen zu zurückhaltend. Er nennt die großen Zahlen, aber in der Argumentation finde ich, kann er noch mal den Bulldozer ein bisschen betanken. Können Beamte Widerstand leisten? Ja, es gibt in Deutschland eine Remonstrationspflicht. Sie steht im Paragraf 63 des Bundesbeamtengesetzes.
Um das kurz einzufügen, er widmet den Beamten ein ganzes Kapitel. Denn die werden als erstes auf AfD-Leute dann treffen in ihrem Arbeitsalltag. Also das heißt, sie müssen mit AfD-Leuten zusammenarbeiten im Sinne von, sie müssen vielleicht Dinge umsetzen, die AfD-Politiker, Landräte, was auch immer verlangen.
Ja, er beschreibt dann dieses Szenario. Jemand bekommt eine Weisung, von der er sieht, also als Laie auch erkennt, die ist rechtswidrig. Er muss sie nicht ausüben, sondern weist seinen Vorgesetzten darauf hin. Der sagt aber, führe trotzdem aus. Dann geht er im nächsten Schritt zu den Vorgesetzten. Wenn er dann immer noch die Weisung erhält, führt er sie aus und macht aber eine Protokollnotiz. Ich bin dafür nicht verantwortlich, ich habe nur Befehle ausgeführt. Also dass dieses, ich habe nur Befehle befolgt, so im Gesetz steht, das eigentlich als Widerstandsgesetz gilt, finde ich ein bisschen fragwürdig. Und dann kommt er wieder auf die politische Realität zu sprechen. Noch heute schwärmt der Personalrat des Ministeriums von Seehofer harte Abschiebepolitik und Strafanzeigen gegen Journalistinnen hin oder her. Seehofer ermöglicht seinen Beamten, flexible Arbeitszeiten und remote zu arbeiten. Ist also ein gelieferter Chef. Egal, welche Anweisungen ich bekomme, solange ich da in meinem Garten sitzen kann und die Füße im Pool hängen, unterschreibe ich alles. So ungefähr ist der T-Nord hier. Also der Seehofer, wir haben ja immer gesagt, wir wollen eine Auswertung von Merkels Amtszeit. Seehofer im Innenministerium wäre vielleicht auch noch mein Thema. Gerade zu dem, was ich nachher noch Christian Drostens Erfahrungen mit Seehofer als Innenminister und was Georg Mascolo über Seehofers Ideen, wie man Corona, wie er sagen, bewältigen kann, aber haben im Subtext nutzen kann, um da ein paar Sachen zu regeln. Sehr wichtiger Hinweis von ihm, das ist, wir hatten es alle so im Hinterkopf oder geahnt, aber hier steht es ganz deutlich drin, das Innenministerium ist heute schon darauf ausgerichtet, Sicherheit, innere Sicherheit und Migration immer in einem Atemzug zu binden. Man könnte auch genauso gut sagen, innere Sicherheit und Integration sind zwei verschiedene, bis hin zu Integration fällt vielleicht sogar in ein eigenes Ministerium, so wie Bauern ja hier auch rausgenommen wurde, hat einen riesigen Beamtenapparat, der sich um Integration kümmert, aber so ist es ja nicht. Wir haben jetzt schon die Situation, dass er schreibt, Migration bedeutet im Innenministerium immer auch ein Sicherheitsrisiko. Und das im größten Beamtenapparat, den die Bundesregierung hält.
Das war mir auch gar nicht klar. 1700 Planstellen hat das Ministerium in seinem festungsartigen Behördenbau in der Nähe des Berliner Hauptbahnhofs. Mehr als 85.000 Menschen arbeiten außerdem in den neunsten Behörden, die dem Ministerium unterstehen. Die größten davon sind die Bundespolizei, das Bundeskriminalamt und das Bundesamt für Migration und Flüchtlinge.
Und ein Hinweis, der ja gar nicht so im Buch steht, aber das Innenministerium hat ein höheres Budget für Beratungsleistungen als für den eigenen Personalkörper. Also da kommt noch unglaublich viel Expertise und Manpower so draußen dran geklatscht, da mit drin.
Ja, er zitiert hier den Kulturwissenschaftner Werner Schiffauer. Der hat die Machtstrukturen im Bundesinnenministerium erforscht. Und da heißt es, als ein besonderes Merkmal der Beamten im Ministerium stellt Schiffauer dabei den Legalismus im Ministerium heraus. Der Begriff bezeichnet eine technokratische Herangehensweise an Politik, bei der die Beamten betonen, stets legal und im Rahmen der geltenden Gesetze zu handeln. Laut Schiffauer ist dieses starre Festhalten an Vorschriften und Paragrafen im Innenministerium Konsens, ein Bürokratieansatz, wie gemacht für eine Politikverschiebung nach rechts. Das heißt, wenn man es noch irgendwie legal begründen kann, dann kann es nicht falsch sein.
Und er beschließt dieses Kapitel mit einem Hinweis auf das nicht zur Verfügung stehende Streikrecht. Man kann also einen inneren, wie nennt er das, Dienstagvorschrift und so weiter, einen schleichenden Streik, einen stillen Streik, wie auch immer.
Man kann Whistleblowing betreiben, da gibt es durchaus Möglichkeiten. Man kann Dinge leaken, man kann sie weitergeben, zum Beispiel fragt den Staat. Er sagt auch ganz klar, wenn da so eine AfD-Regierung käme und man unter ihr arbeiten sollte, dann kann man sich als Beamter wunderbar krankschreiben lassen und das sehr lange ziehen. Also, worum es ihm jetzt wirklich geht, wir müssen jetzt in diesem Bulldozer-Bild das Ganze denken. Man muss verhindern, dass die AfD vernünftig arbeiten kann. Und dazu sind dann alle Mittel Recht, sich krankschreiben zu lassen. Man kann natürlich auch versuchen, sich versetzen zu lassen. Und man kann versuchen auch, dass man innerhalb der Beamtenschaft andere Verbündete findet. Aber er sagte auch, ja, mit den Beamten, das ist eine heikle Sache. Also viele, die lange dabei sind, sind natürlich auch ganz zu diesen Institutionen selbst geworden. Beziehungsweise, wenn sie lange dabei sind, einfach aus dem Beamtenstatus rauszugehen, ist natürlich ein Riesenschritt, auch weil dann in der freien Wirtschaft nicht so viele Möglichkeiten da sind für Leute, die ewig in der Behörde gearbeitet haben. Aber da zeigt sich schon jetzt hier an ganz konkreten Stellen, wie dann doch Widerstand zu leisten ist. Also man darf sich dann genau nicht auf diese Neutralitätsidee stützen und sagen, ja, ich mache ja hier nur was Legales und damit ist gut.
Ja, Beraterleistungen kommt dann doch nochmal zu sprechen, aber nicht am deutschen Beispiel, sondern am amerikanischen. Also Trump wird Präsident, hat diese Ausländerbehörde, die eine Immigrationsbehörde hat, ICE, und sie beauftragen McKinsey mit einem Plan, wie man diese Behörde schnell um 10.000 Beschäftigte erweitert. Sodass man wirklich flächendeckend durch die Straßen ziehen kann, da irgendwie Hausbesuche zu machen. Wer sind sie und leben sie hier legal? Und damals gab es ja schon große Abschiebewellen, dass Menschen, die 40 Jahre in Amerika gelebt haben und dort auch arbeiten und Familie haben, plötzlich den Vater abgeschoben bekommen und solche Sachen. Außerdem hier schon mal ein Snippet zu seinem Lieblingsthema Transparenz. Also Behörden machen, was Verwaltungen so tun. Es kommt zu Rechtsstreitigkeiten, wie auch immer. In Deutschland werden gerade 0,9% aller begründeten Urteile öffentlich bekanntgegeben. Also 110 von 111 Gerichtsverfahren bleiben praktisch vor der Öffentlichkeit verborgen. Man kann also, das ist ja dann sein Frag-den-Staat-Thema, hier gar keine Muster in Gerichtsurteilen erkennen. Wir kommen ja heute noch mal auf einen Text, bei dem ich auch sage, das ist crazy, also das sollte man unbedingt mal ein Muster herausarbeiten und da vielleicht dagegenhalten.
Ja, er bringt ja auch ein sehr hübsches Beispiel für Widerstand. Und zwar Otto Schili, manche werden sich erinnern, SPD-Innenminister, kam 1998 ins Amt und er wollte ein Dienstmädchen. Da heißt es, wenn er im Ministerium abends noch Herrschaften empfing, sollte der Legende nach dazu aufgetischt werden. Und diese Aufgabe sollte nach Schili's Wunsch von einem Dienstmädchen erledigt werden. Das Ministerbüro gab diese Bitte zur Prüfung an die mächtige und teilweise intern gefürchtete Verwaltungsabteilung des Ministeriums weiter, die unter dem Buchstaben Z formiert. Sie sollte einen Weg finden, die Einstellung zu ermöglichen. In der Abteilung Z hingegen waren die Beamten von Schillys Vorhaben überhaupt nicht begeistert. Die Beschäftigung von Dienstmädchen hat in deutschen Behörden keine Tradition. Dementsprechend gibt es auch keine Richtlinie, wie sie tariflich eingestuft werden würde. Zudem taten sich weitere rechtliche Fragen auf, auf deren Lärung die Beamten nun wahrlich keine Lust hatten. Sie entschieden sich für eine Verzögerungstaktik, wie aus dem Lehrbuch, die man im Beamten-Deutsch Dienst nach Vorschrift oder auch Bummelstreik nennt.
Bummelstreik, genau.
Den Prüfauftrag nahmen die Beamten zwar an, brauchten dann aber zunächst zwei, dann drei, dann vier Jahre für die Prüfung, die immer neue Schleifen nehmen musste und neue Rechtsfragen aufwarf. Wie wären die Arbeitszeiten geregelt? Wie sähe es mit der Herstellung von Speisen aus? Irgendwann hat das Ministerbüro keine Energie mehr, bei diesem dann doch etwas nebensächlichen Anliegen weiter Druck zu machen. Also man kann sehr gut dieses ganze bürokratische Zeugs auch nutzen gegen die Herrschenden. Und das wurde dann hier getan und es ist sehr schön, wie ihr das aufarbeitet.
Ja, aber diese Hausverwaltung lässt sich halt auch umdrehen.
Genau, also wenn man denen sagt, flexible Arbeitszeiten und ein bisschen Homeoffice, und dafür wollen wir aber, dass ihr Folgendes in puncto Abschiebungen macht, kann das ganz schnell gehen. Also der Opportunismus wird sicherlich das größte Problem sein.
Ja, was eben bedeutet, wir brauchen, klar Transparenz schon angesprochen, einen Medienbetrieb, der mithilft, den wir aber nicht haben. Zum einen müsste man den Medienbetrieb selber erst mal schützen vor der AfD-Übernahme.
Du bist jetzt schon zu den Medien gesprungen, oder?
Noch nicht.
Wo bist du jetzt, in welchem Kapitel, wenn ich fragen darf?
Acht.
Okay, dann bist du jetzt schon sehr weit. Also wir haben ja eigentlich noch Kapital.
Die Unternehmen.
Willst du das alles überspringen?
Nein, geh uns die Unternehmensseite durch, die ist ja auch schon Teil der Öffentlichkeit. Nun, vorpolitischer Raum.
Naja, also du hast ja schon McKinsey angesprochen. Es ist ja ganz interessant, dass wir eigentlich sehr viele Unternehmen haben, die jetzt gerade sagen, wir sind gegen rechts. Aber wenn man dann sich überlegt, naja, wenn dann erstmal ein Regierungswechsel stattgefunden hat, sind die dann auch noch gegen rechts? Oder kooperieren sie dann? Also wenn McKinsey, die ja die ganze Zeit so Kampagnen machen wie Diversity Wins, Women in Workplace, Power of Party, ich hab mal die bei LinkedIn mir so ein bisschen angesehen, ja. Also Power of Parity, wenn man lauter solche Kampagnen hat und zugleich aber der Trump-Regierung zugearbeitet hat, um effektiver abschieben zu können, um eine rassistische Politik durchzusetzen, ist also die Frage, inwieweit sind also die Unternehmen bereit, doch sehr kooperativ zu sein? Ich meine, wir sehen das ja jetzt auch gerade in Frankreich. Da haben wir jetzt die Parlamentswahlen vor der Tür stehen. Ich hab mitunter den Eindruck, wenn man sich so die französische Wirtschaft ansieht, dass die mehr Angst vor einem Linksruck als vor einem Rechtsruck haben.
Also ja, wir haben ja Kampf der Nationen gelesen, dass französische Unternehmen gerne staatliche Hilfe in Anspruch nehmen, um ihre Properties zu schützen. Ist nicht ganz verwerflich, würde ich sagen, nach der Auslieferungsgeschichte, die da stattfand.
Wie meinst du das jetzt?
Na, die wurden ja wirklich im Stich gelassen. Also es gab ja keine Art Protektionismus für die französische Autoindustrie. Und von den Stromrichtern weiß ich, dass selbst deutsche Unternehmen sagen, die Franzosen sind stolze und sehr gute Ingenieure. Aber sie haben halt keine Frankreich AG drum herum gestrickt. Und deswegen ging alles durch die Lappen unter diesem deutschen Protektionismus, dass man ein 2-Prozent-Ziel hat, an das sich die französischen Unternehmen halten, auch bei der Preissteigerung von Lohnkosten und die deutschen Ebenen nicht. Und da haben die sich ja so eine Produktivität und Lohnauszahlungslücke von 20 Prozent herausgearbeitet, wie Patrick da schrieb. Und darunter litten natürlich die Franzosen, die genau wissen, das kann man auch staatlich anders organisieren. Also Frankreich kann sich genauso verhalten, wie Deutschland sich in Europa verhalten hat. Und dann sieht das schon anders aus.
Nur ist es ja jetzt gerade so, dass es ja bei diesen Parlamentswahlen darum geht, dass wenn dann Linksruck kommt, ja solche Dinge wahrscheinlich sich nicht fundamental ändern werden, sondern dass möglicherweise das Kapital mit mehr Streiks, mit höheren Lohn zu wechseln, zu rechnen hat. Und dann sagen, vielleicht ist ja Le Pen doch nicht so schlimm.
Ja, die haben halt jetzt wieder diesen strategischen, also wir kritisieren das ja in Deutschland auch, aber das ist ja dort noch crazier durch dieses Mehrheitsprinzip. Die gehen jetzt in diese Stichwahlen und streichen landesweit diese dritten Kandidaten, um dann so Sammlungskandidaten gegen die Le-Pens-Partei zu machen. Und so ist natürlich kein Staat zu machen. Also da hat man dann zwar noch eine nicht rechte Mehrheit, aber die sich nur identifiziert über die, wir sind die nicht rechte Mehrheit. Und so ist natürlich kein Staat zu machen, muss man dann ehrlicherweise sagen.
Was man aber sehen kann, ist, dass das Kapital durchaus bereit ist. Oder wir gucken in die USA. Da ist jetzt nicht mehr so diese Anti-Trump-Stimmung wie damals, beim ersten Mal. Also man hat jetzt schon sich da arrangiert. Und es drohen auch gar nicht mehr so viele Hollywood-Stars mit Ausreise, wenn Trump gewinnt. Also man gewöhnt sich und diese Gewöhnungseffekte, die ihr beschreibt, sind interessant. Aber nochmal auf die Zahlen. Er sagt, die deutsche Wirtschaft ist ja nicht unabhängig vom Staat. Und die Staatsquote in Deutschland, also der Anteil der Staatsinvestitionen am Bruttoinlandsprodukt, liegt bei rund 50 Prozent. Jeder zweite Euro, der in die Wirtschaft fließt, kommt vom Staat. Davon profitieren natürlich viele Unternehmen. Und er sagt dann, wenn die AfD in eine Regierung kommt, müssen sich Tausende Unternehmen in Deutschland die schmerzliche Frage stellen, wie sie mit ihren Regierungsaufträgen umgehen sollen. Nimmt man auch Regierungsaufträge von der AfD an. Er bringt ja dann Beispiele aus den USA, Peter Thiel, die Koch-Milliardäre, was da so alles in Gang ist. Aber wir können das auch hier sehr gut sehen. Er beschreibt dann noch etwas anderes, nämlich wie eigentlich jetzt schon Anwälte dabei sind, eine Verschiebung herzustellen. Ich lese es mal vor, weil ich mich nicht in justiciable Gefilde begeben will. Und zwar sagt er, eine besondere Position im unternehmerischen Umfeld der AfD nimmt die Anwaltskanzlei Höcker von Ralf Höcker ein, seines Zeichnesexpresses Sprecher der Werteunion. Höcker vertritt nicht nur die AfD und ihre Parteien nahe desiderius Erasmus-Stiftung vor Gericht zu seinen Mandantenzellen, auch Rechtsextremisten wie Hans-Georg Maaßen, der in der Vergangenheit selbst in der Kanzlei mitwirkte, Teilnehmer des Potsdamer Geheimtreffens, sowie der autoritäre türkische Ministerpräsident Recep Tayyip Erdogan. Höckers Unternehmen ist in einem vergleichsweise jungen Geschäftszweig des Medienrechts aktiv, auf den die AfD und ihr Umfeld besonders vertrauen. Die SLAPs, Strategische Klagen gegen die Meinungsfreiheit. Mithilfe von Abmahnungen und Klagen versuchen Akteure des rechten Spektrums, gezielt Recherchen über sie zu behindern, betroffene Mundtote zu machen und mit hohen Geldforderungen einzuschüchtern. Und er schildert dann ja in acht Punkten, wie diese Einschüchterungsversuche laufen. Also das heißt, man sieht hier gleich, wie sehr man dafür sorgen kann, dass dann plötzlich nicht mehr so viel gesagt wird. Und dass dann auch, du siehst ja, ich bin jetzt schon vorsichtig hier in so einem Podcast, dass man nicht in irgendeiner Weise belangt werden kann und plötzlich ein Abmahnbrief bekommt und nicht weiß, wie man damit umzugehen wird.
Auf Twitter kursieren ja auch wieder Hinweise. Ich habe jetzt seinen Namen leider nicht beraten, aber 8.000 Euro drohen für einzelne Tweets, weil man irgendwelche juristischen Formulierungen, die die AfD thematisieren im juristischen Konflikt mit dem Verfassungsschutz und so weiter. Und wir sehen ja auch, wie Halderwang in Interviews vorsichtig agiert. Es wird dann so gelobt, dass er ohne Schnitt durchsprecht und am Ende nichts zu korrigieren hat. Ja, wenn man von Anfang an so in das Gespräch reingeht, dass man weiß, hier gibt es nichts zu korrigieren, weil ich mich juristisch die ganze Zeit nur damit befasse, wie ich etwas ausdrücke, damit man da nicht belangt wird, münde das eben in solchen Formulierungen, die dann immer mal wieder warnen, aber keine Namen nennen und so weiter, in der Ansicht ist, dass das auch ein großes Verdienst von diesem Buch, dass da einfach Namen genannt werden.
Kommen wir zu den Medien.
Na gut, jetzt können wir die eine Frage, also, sollten Unternehmen Demokratieförderung vergütet bekommen, gezielt? Sehr guter Vorschlag. Also, das sind ja auch so Sachen, an die denkt man gar nicht. Aber wir haben so viele steuerliche Privilegien hier, irgendwas da, keine Ahnung. Und Unternehmen sind nun mal Einflugschneisen über die Belegschaften auf diesen politischen Vorfeld. Also, wer organisiert Grillfeste? Das sind vor allem Unternehmen. Warum sollte man da nicht genauso gezielt fördern?
Die Frage ist halt, ob die Unternehmen daran Interesse haben. Das Thema Streik kommt ja mehrmals vor, sie will zum Beispiel ein Streikrecht für Beamte. Er sagt aber auch, es ist falsch, dass in Deutschland politische Streiks verboten sind. Die wären jetzt genau richtig und wichtig. Und da könnte man natürlich überlegen, wer von Kapitalseite will, dass politische Streiks genehmigt werden. Nicht allzu viele vermutlich, aber dafür wäre eigentlich zu kämpfen. Also wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel sich als Sozialdemokrat verstehen würde, also jetzt nicht Kevin Kühnern, sondern jetzt wirkliche Sozialdemokraten, die würden sich stark machen für politische Streiks.
Also politische Streiks, was ja schon mal bedeutet, dass eine, und das versuchen ja die Gewerkschaften, immer zu dem konkreten Anliegen, das man hat, einen großen Bogen um das Management. Also man ist für die Anliegen der Belegschaft. Und dann versuchten ja die Gewerkschaften, also zumindest die IG Metall, immer noch so ein globales Argument oben drüber zu legen, was ihnen wirklich schwerfällt, weil das juristisch einfach nicht einfach ist, weil dann relativ häufig dann doch Gerichte sagen, nee, also das Streikrecht ist so eng gefasst, ihr dürft hier gerne die Straße blockieren und euer Thema, aber ihr dürft nicht die Management-Entscheidung kritisieren, ihr dürft kein über die Belegschaft hinausgehendes politisches Ziel formulieren und so weiter. Also hier wäre es schon mal auf Öffnung geboten.
Gab es ja auch schon so ein bisschen mit den Klima-Aktivisten, die gemeinsam mit Gewerkschaften gestreikt haben.
Genau, Gewerkschaften haben dann häufig so Solidaritätsadressen, dass sie sich so zeigen. Aber dieses allgemeine Gespräch darüber, dass mehr Gewerkschaft hier besser ist. Wir haben Belegschaften im Süd-West-Mobil-Automobilbau, bei denen die Betriebsräder durchdrängt sind mit rechtsradikalem Denken und auch den Gewerkschaften das große Sorgen macht. Weil die Betriebsräder an sich sind ja keine Gewerkschaftseinrichtungen. Die Gewerkschaften haben Vertrauensleute in den Unternehmen, aber die Betriebsräder sind ja eigene Gremien. Ich will jetzt keine Namen nennen, aber wir haben deutsche Autohersteller, die immer mal wieder darüber auffallen, dass in Betriebsräden es zu sehr zur Sache geht. Gerade, weil wir dieses Sonderproblem haben, dass die Belegschaft, für die der Betriebsrat kämpft, also alle mit einer Personalakte, dann doch irgendwie so urdeutsch-biodeutsch sind, während die Kollegen als Leiharbeiter, die einfach als Sachleistung abgerechnet werden, die die gleiche Arbeit machen und nur die Hälfte verdienen, schnell dann auch mal als minderwertig in der Belegschaft angesehen werden. Von daher ist dieses einfach nur mehr Gewerkschaftsarbeit usw. nicht per se, sondern auch da müsste man wieder sensibler, fokussierter und mit so einem klaren Bulldozer-Einschlag rein. Ansonsten fährt dieser Bulldozer in die falsche Richtung.
Ja, das ist ja ein großes Problem und man muss auch da deutlich machen, dass die Gewerkschaften sich klarer gegen AfD und auch gegen so einen atmosphärischen Rassismus wenden müssen. Also wo man dann genau das, was du jetzt gerade beschrieben hast, dann nicht mehr vorfindet, dass man so diese Entscheidung macht, ja wir und irgendwie die anderen, die sind ja nicht da bei uns, aber die sind ja auch eh nicht so ganz deutsch. Also dass das nicht Einzug hält immer weiter, das ist sicherlich ein großes Problem. Ich will nur eine kurze kritische Anmerkung machen, nämlich dieses Buch ist ja zum Teil gegendert und zum Teil nicht gegendert. Mir ist es im Prinzip egal, ob jemand ein Buch gendert oder nicht, nur die Argumentation hier ist, dass wenn es um rechte Politik geht, also wenn zum Beispiel AfD-Leute oder was beschrieben werden, zum Beispiel AfD-Juristen, dann wird nicht gegendert. Und er sagt, ich habe in diesem Buch versucht, in Bezug auf Politik und Aktivisten im Umfeld der AfD nicht zu gendern, um deutlich zu machen, dass große Teile des Rechtsextremismus generisch männlich sind. Da muss ich sagen, entweder gendert man oder man gendert nicht. Aber man kann jetzt diese Unterscheidung nicht machen, wenn wir zugleich Meloni haben. Nein, ich will keine Gender-Diskussion. Du hast Recht. Ich will sagen, dass das einfach unsinnig ist. Also entweder oder. Aber man kann nicht mehr im Jahr 2024 behaupten, dass der Rechtsextremismus ein rein männliches Phänomen ist. Er mag, gerade in Deutschland, männlich überwiegen. Und man hat es auch beim letzten AfD-Parteitag immer sehr gesehen, sucht die Frau auf den Wimmelbildern und irgendwo steht Alice Weidel. Ich weiß darum. Ich freue mich auch darüber, dass die AfD es nicht schafft, offenbar so viele Frauen für sich zu bekommen. Wir haben ja auch Statistiken dazu. Aber allgemein ist der Rechtsruck nicht darauf rückzuführen, auf männlich weiblich. Denn sonst können wir Phänomene wie Meloni und Phänomene wie Le Pen und auch Weidel immer schwieriger erklären.
Christian, du hast recht, grundsätzlich. Und trotzdem gibt es hier ganz viel, aber es müsste eigenständige Literatur sein, die dieses Problem behandelt. Denn wir sehen jetzt gerade in Amerika. Und die New York Times hat es sehr ausführlich behandelt. Und ich habe mich auch erst gewundert darüber. Aber ich habe mich dann überzeugen lassen, indem sie es einfach gar nicht zu offen angesprochen haben, sondern nur die Zahlen genannt haben. Wir hatten diese Debatte in Amerika. Unter den Wählerinnen hat sich nichts geändert in der Zustimmung für die Kandidaten. Sie sehen den alten Joe Biden und haben Mitleid und sind davon überzeugt, ich kann deswegen nicht Trump wählen. Bei den Männern, grandiose, also wirklich unfassbare Wanderungsbewegung hin zu Trump. Im zweistelligen Prozentbereich sind die Männer abgewandert von Joe Biden, weil sie keine Ahnung, Angst davor haben, Subkotan spüren, ich kann ja selber mal ein alter Mann sein, ich will so nicht vorgeführt werden, ich kann mich mit dem nicht identifizieren, ich muss etwas tun, ich verändere mein Denken und politisches Handeln und so weiter. Mir sind die Inhalte egal. Also irgendwas ist mit den Männern in diesem Metier.
Definitiv, definitiv.
Das ist wirklich ganz erstaunlich gewesen in diesen ersten Polls.
Nur wir können nicht irgendwann dann dazu kommen, denn das ist ja, das findet ja von konservativer Seite schon statt, dass man eigentlich uns Georgia Meloni und auch Le Pen zunehmend als moderne, selbstbewusste Karrierefrauen einfach verkauft und sagt, es ist doch toll, dass so viel Diversität auch möglich ist unter den Rechten. Also deswegen gleich sagen, ja, es gibt bei der Wählerbetrachtung, bei der Ursachenforschung, das alles sehr differenziert zu sehen. Aber generell sind die Akteure des Rechtsradikalismus nicht auf ein Geschlecht reduzierbar. Wir sind im Jahr 2024.
Yes, Medien. Zum einen muss man die Medien schützen, denn die Ministerpräsidenten haben so eine gewisse Entscheidungsgewalt über die Finanzierung, wie er schreibt. Das könnte man durchaus einer Indexierung unterwerfen, macht man ja mit Mietverträgen auch. Also das Preisniveau steigt, also steigt dann auch diese Kosten. Nein, es dürfen immer mal wieder die Ministerpräsidenten und deren Staatskanzleien darüber entscheiden. Wenn da einer aus der Reihe fällt, fällt das alles in sich zusammen. Also ein Ministerpräsident der AfD reicht da schon, um das ganze Ding zu torpedieren. Und er weiß daraufhin, es besteht durchaus die Gefahr, dass die AfD umschwenkt von weniger Beitragsgeld auf, nee, das Beitragsgeld ist schon okay in der Höhe, aber wir brauchen es für uns. Wir füttern damit unsere eigene Redaktion, unsere TikTok-Kanäle. Also das ist ja auch wieder so eine Gefahr. Ich meine, wir sagen alle, diese 10 Milliarden wäre doch gut, wenn man die mal so ein bisschen allgemeiner nutzen könnte. Wenn wir einfach sagen, okay, wir lesen nur Bücher, das qualifiziert uns dann für irgendeinen kleinen Zuschuss. Nur ja, das ist das Einfallstil für die AfD, zu sagen, wir machen politische Information, also her mit der Kohle. Und dann fließt plötzlich dieses und dann halt wirklich Zwangsgeld in irgendwelche AfD-TikTok-Kanäle. Das wollen wir alles nicht. Talkshows, eigenes Thema bei ihm. Völlig zurecht, denn er ist sehr betrübt darüber, wie die AfD dort als legitimer Gesprächspartner akzeptiert wird. Wir haben das vorhin schon diskutiert. Die AfD ist eine anders funktionierende Partei mit anderen Zielen. Das wird dort nicht reflektiert und thematisiert. Sondern dann behandelt sie sie wie jede andere Partei. Ach, sie sitzt im Bundestag? Ja, dann darf sie auch in die Elefantenrunde. Er weist daraufhin, niemand käme bei Protesten gegen eine zunehmende organisierte Kriminalität auf die Idee, den Kopf der kriminellen Organisationen in die Talkshow einzuladen.
Genau das findet aber statt.
Genau. Ich finde, das ist zum Teil ein haarsträubender Gedanke, den er formuliert. Aber der ist auch nicht ganz falsch. Denn man muss sich jetzt hier prinzipielle Fragen stellen. Diese Parteien, die GOP, die AfD, Melonis-Partei, Peace-Partei, Orban-Partei, das sind Parteien, die schon bewiesen haben oder in ihrem Programm drinstehen haben, dieses demokratische Gefüge zu überwinden. Und dieser besondere politische Vorfeld, Medienbetrieb, muss das auf besondere Art und Weise thematisieren. Macht er aber nicht.
Er sagt ja dann auch, wenn die Talkshow-Hosts das nicht machen, und bei Maischberger oder so hat man ja jetzt keinen Glauben daran, dass die, also ich würde das mal zuspitzen wollen, die Maischberger-Sendung wird auch in einem AfD-absolute Mehrheit geführten Deutschland stattfinden, einfach so weiterlaufen. Und dann sagt er aber, naja, dann sollen alle anderen Gäste grundsätzlich absagen. Also wenn AfD-Politiker kommen wollen, können alle grundsätzlich absagen. Es gibt eine Politikerin, die mir gerade einfällt, die das mal gemacht hat in den Anfangsjahren der AfD, das war Marlou Dreyer. Da wurde sie sehr ausgeschimpft für. Und es hat sich auch niemand angeschlossen. Ja, also das ist ganz interessant.
Also es gibt Medienhäuser, ich war überrascht, aber der Spiegel führt keine Interviews mit AfD-Ladies zu machen.
Ja, man muss natürlich vorsichtig sein, wenn zu Grundsätzchen sind, weil der Spiegel auch eine Verschiebung nach rechts macht, ohne mit der AfD zu sprechen. Denn es gibt ja noch eine Zeitung, die nicht mit der AfD spricht, nämlich die Bild-Zeitung. Hättest du gar nicht gedacht, ne?
Ja, ich hab's auch beim Spiegel nicht gedacht.
Weil du bei der Bild-Zeitung denkst, wenn die nicht mit der AfD sprechen, was ist denn da los? Ja, die führen auch keine AfD-Interviews. Das war so eine wahnsinnige Ausnahme, dass mal dieses Springer-Duell da stattfand mit Vogt und Höcke. Eigentlich ist das nicht das, was die tun. Aber man muss sich zum Beispiel fragen, wieso sind jetzt mittlerweile Nios-Moderatoren auch bei Maischberger zu Gast und kommentieren da irgendwas?
Oder warum ist Lindner bei Nios?
Genau. Nios war dafür gesorgt, dass die stellvertretende Chefredakteurin der Süddeutschen Zeitung beschuldigt wurde, sie sei ein Falschwanger. Sie hätte ein Plagiata angefertigt. Und wir wissen, was dann war. Die Polizei hat sie überall gesucht. Sie ist unterkühlt aufgefunden worden. Sie war also wirklich am Ende. Es hat sich aber dann als Ente herausgestellt. Und wenig später ist dann jetzt der Finanzminister Christian Lindner genau dort zu Gast.
Der seinerseits z.B. Markus Lanz boykottiert.
Ja.
Also wir haben es ja mit einem Gefüge zu tun, bei dem die FDP...
Oder er bringt noch mal dieses Lied, manche werden es vergessen haben, Kinderchor singt im WDR. Meine Oma ist eine alte Umweltsau. Und dann ist Tom Buhrow nicht derjenige, der sich vor seiner Redaktion und die Leute stellt, sondern der in der Bildzeitung und sonst wo dann sagt, dass das ja so nicht sein kann. Also das finde ich wirklich gut. Sommerinterviews sagt er einfach abschaffen. Es ist die richtige Forderung, mehr muss man nicht dazu sagen. Und dann finde ich wirklich sehr gut, er widmet da einen ganz großen Abschnitt Jens Spahn. Jens Spahn.
Warte, das ist ja dieser Forderungsjournalismus. Das Kapitel lief ja auch über Ebermedien noch mal. Also das ist sozusagen, das kann man für alle, die können es nachlesen. Er nennt in diesem Medienkapitel noch mal Namen von Personen, die man einladen könnte, um beispielsweise über Migration oder sowas zu sprechen oder Sozialpolitik, also Bürgergeld, die eben gerade nicht von der AfD kommen, sondern die was zum Thema zu sagen haben. Also Gilda Sahibi, wir haben ihr Buch gelesen, Christina Klemm, Naika Forutan, Lena Steinhaus, werden wir ihr Buch gelesen, Clara Bünger, Asha Hedeyati, Pia Klemp und Nefrod Duman. Ich kenne nur die Hälfte, aber er kommt einfach mal mit in eine Liste, erinnert mich an diese Podcasterei, wo es auch mal hieß, lade doch mal Podcasterinnen ein. Und dann gab es so eine Organisation, sprecherinnen.org, podcasterinnen.org und so, dass man solche Namenslisten mal geführt hat. Die können natürlich immer auch gleich dann missbraucht werden von der anderen Seite. Guckt mal, das ist die Namensliste. Aber ich schließe mich unbedingt dieser Empfehlung an. Man möchte grundsätzlich mal weniger Politiker an diesen Runden sehen. Das ist der politische Vorfeld. Die Politiker reden im Parlament. Die brauchen nicht die Talkshows. Also glaubt denn irgendein Talkshow-Moderator, dass er die bessere Frage stellen kann als ein Abgeordneter bei einer Regierungsbefragung.
Nee, aber er weiß, dass er die bessere Show machen kann. Also der Pressegrupp ist ja nicht auf Show ausgelegt und deswegen finden da die interessanteren Diskussionen statt. Während in den Talkshows es natürlich darum geht, wie können wir jetzt den größtmöglichen Effekt herstellen. Und das wäre am besten, wenn jeden Abend irgendein AfD-Politiker auf Marie-Argne Strack-Zimmermann trifft. Und genau das wird ja dann auch geboten.
So, der Forderungsjournalismus.
Ja, ich fange mal an. Jens Spahn, der CDU-Oppositionspolitiker und Ex-Gesundheitsminister, stellt immer mal wieder Forderungen. Das passiert auffallend häufig. Wirklich? Googeln Sie mal, Jens Spahn fordert. Alleine in dem politisch relativ ruhigen Zeitraum zwischen Mitte Dezember 2023 und Mitte Januar 2024 schaffte es Jens Spahn mit acht verschiedenen Forderungen in die Schlagzeilen überregionaler, reichweitenstarker Medien. Jetzt, Jens Spahn fordert die Finanzierung von Moscheen über eine deutsche Stiftung zu regeln. Jens Spahn fordert längere Arbeitszeiten für Arbeitnehmer. Jens Spahn fordert, das Bürgergeld abzuschaffen. Jens Spahn fordert, die Rente mit 63 abzuschaffen. Jens Spahn fordert, die Verfassung zu ändern, um noch drastischere Vollsanktionen gegen manche Bürgergeldempfänger durchzusetzen. Jens Spahn fordert, überirdische Stromleitungen zu ermöglichen. Jens Spahn fordert, Abschiebungen zu verstärken. Jens Spahn fordert, Fraktionszwang im Bundestag bei manchen Fragen abzuschaffen. Ja, also weniger als einen Monat, acht Forderungen. Jens Spahn zeigt zum Beispiel auf, wie dann das ZDF damit umgeht. Nehmen wir mal eine Forderung von Spahn vor, die er im Oktober 2023 äußerte und die das ZDF handbuchartig schlecht vermeldete. Spahn hatte in einem Interview gefordert, dass Deutschland und die EU an den Außengrenzen zur Abschreckung physische Gewalt gegen Migrantinnen einsetzen sollten. Eine schockierende Forderung, die schlicht menschenrechtswidrig ist. Die AfD-Politikerin Beatrix von Storch wurde für ähnliche Forderungen im Jahr 2015 noch stark kritisiert und musste dann zurückrudern. Spahn hingegen musste sich für gar nichts entschuldigen. Das ZDF titelte, basierend auf einer Meldung einer Nachrichtenagentur, Spahn für Gewalt bei irregulärer Migration. Diese Überschrift alleine birgt bei sechs Wörtern schon drei Probleme. Ja, und dann geht er das durch. Also Spahn fordert nicht Gewalt bei Migration. Spahn will ja nicht das Frontex-Beamte-Supermärkte verwüsten, wenn sie mitbekommen, dass es Migration gibt. Spahn befürwortet also Gewalt gegen Migrantinnen. So muss die Meldung heißen. Ja, dann geht er das weiter durch. Ich glaube, das kann sich jetzt jeder selbst denken, wie irre eine solche Meldung ist. Wird aber vom Journalismus fortwährend so gestaltet.
Ja, und vor allem Jens Spahn ist ja für nichts zuständig gerade.
Gar nichts.
Er ist einer von 736 Bundestagsabgeordneten, ohne in irgendeinem Ausschuss Vollmitglied zu sein. Und er geht es dann so illustriert durch, wo er überall nicht für Migration und erst recht nicht federführend und sprechfähig ist.
Also noch nie war er für Migration.
In der Unionsfraktion gibt es andere für das Thema. In seinen Ausschüssen, in denen er Stellvertreterrollen einnimmt, ist das kein Thema. Er ist Gesundheitspolitiker. Und kommt da mit physischer Gewalt irgendwie. Das passt ja auch so alles nicht zusammen.
Ja, und die eigentliche Meldung müsste, wenn Spahn dann sowas fordert und man will es aufgreifen, lauten, Spahn fordert menschenrechtswidrige Gewalt gegen Menschen auf der Flucht. Das wäre die korrekte Meldung. Und er sagt dann auch, dass die New York Times, dass er dann irgendwann oder die Washington Post anfing, wenn Trump etwas forderte oder sagte, dass sie dann einfach schrieben, Trump falsely claims. Und eigentlich muss man genau so auch damit umgehen. Also es ist für mich nochmal ein sehr, sehr wichtiges Kapitel, das er hier geschrieben hat.
Der Forderungsjournalismus muss sterben. Was wir stattdessen brauchen? Gemeinnützigkeit im Journalismus. Ja. Vereine wie Frag den Staat, die ja sehr viele Informationen bereitstellen, kann man durchaus als gemeinnützige Medienprojekte, ohne dass sie das immer über Umwege, Bildungsarbeit oder was auch immer, sondern der Journalismus selbst, das ist ja auch eine Forderung von Ulf Bohrmeier, Lage der Nation, in der Sicht, der können wir uns ja auch mal anschließen. Paywalls machen es halt schwierig.
Genau, deswegen ist ja auch für ihn noch mal ganz klar, der Öffentlich-Rechtliche ist wichtig. Und das wissen glaube ich viele nicht. Das sieht man einfach, dass der sich jemand auskennt. Es gibt für die Öffentlich-Rechtlichen eine Depublikierungspflicht. Immer noch. Das heißt, Dinge, die im Netz standen, müssen wieder rausgenommen werden. Man wundert sich ja auch manchmal, wieso verschwinden wieder so tolle Arte-Dokus oder irgendetwas.
Da steht dann immer, ist verfügbar bis. Und dann hat man so ein halbes Jahr Zeit.
Und das hat die freie Wirtschaft ausbaldobert.
Presse.
Oder wir können auch gleich sagen, wehe, vor allem Matthias Döpfner von Stringer. Die wollen nicht, dass die Öffentlich-Rechtlichen zu viel Konkurrenz machen. Und deswegen sind die Öffentlich-Rechtlichen gezwungen, gute Recherchen wieder zu löschen nach, ich glaube, etwa zwei Jahren. Bei manchen geht es auch ein bisschen länger. Und damit verschwinden eigentlich diese Recherchen alle wieder. Das heißt, die Informationen werden künstlich verknappt, dadurch, dass man sagt, nee, sonst sind die eine zu große Konkurrenz für die Medienhäuser. Und das ist einfach der reine Wahnsinn. Denn hier würde ich einfach mal unterstreichen wollen, das haben wir ja bezahlt, dass genau ein solcher Journalismus entsteht. Und dann soll ich jetzt auf das, was ich bezahlt habe, wieder verzichten. Also auch mal dieses ganze Argument mit den zu hohen GEZ-Gebühren, das da immer von den Konservativen gemacht wird. Dann muss man wirklich denen auch mal entgegenhalten, ja wieso eigentlich zahle ich das Geld oder ich kann auch sagen, das ist viel Geld. Und dann darf ich nicht mal diese Inhalte so lange haben, wie ich will. Ja, die müsste ich zurückfordern.
Zwei Jahre später fordern wir den Betrag wieder zurück. Also wir haben immer so einen Durchlaufposten.
Genau, und deswegen müsste man eigentlich hier die großen Medienhäuser angehen, vor allem Springer angehen, die diese Depuplizierungspflicht durchgesetzt haben. Dagegen müsste man auch kämpfen.
Zu diesen AfD nicht einladen. Er hat ja noch mal ein eigenes Subkapitel nach den Talkshows. Dazu, ich will mal vorlesen, wie er es schreibt, weil er es sehr gut schreibt. Es sind nur zwei Sätze, aber ich bin trotzdem dagegen. Wann hat es mal einen echten Erkenntnisgewinn gegeben, als ein AfD-Politiker in einer Talkshows zu Gast war? Nie, würden wir jetzt sagen. Und er fügt dann an. Mit Rechtsextremisten redet man nicht freiwillig, sondern nur, wenn es sein muss. Vor Gericht zum Beispiel. Richtiger Gedanke, ich würde ihn aber ummünzen auf, ja dann muss eben das Fernsehstudio als Gericht fungieren. Denn wenn verfassungswidrige, menschenrechtsverletzende Politik gefordert wird, dann muss man genau darüber reden, aber über nichts anderes. Also die AfD, wenn man mit ihr spricht, und man muss mit ihr sprechen, nur über die rechtsradikalen Belange. Solange die Partei welche hat, nur die thematisieren. Anstatt jetzt mit der AfD plötzlich über Rente, Sozialpolitik, Bildung oder so.
Oder noch einen Schritt weitergehen wie Karamioska, die dann mit Tino Krupalla darüber spricht, dass er doch eine Ausbildung hat. Wie ist es denn eigentlich sonst so? Fahren sie auch in den Urlaub?
Also ich bin absolut dafür, mit der AfD zu reden. Auch Karamioska kann das machen. Aber es gibt dann nur einen Fragenkatalog. Warum sollen Menschen an der Grenze sterben? Warum wollen sie die hier deportieren? Und das sind ja nun mal die Ziele, solange die da formuliert werden.
Ich glaube halt, dass das auch nicht viel bringen wird. Unterhaltsam wird es jedenfalls nicht. Ich traue das aber den Host nicht zu.
Ich traue denen das auch nicht zu. Aber ich bin trotzdem dafür, dass man den Gider-Azahibi-Satz, die haben rechtsradikale Belange, dann thematisieren wir sie auch.
Jaja, aber dann müsste da wirklich jemand sitzen, wie Michel Friedman, mit denen darüber reden. Oder Arne Semsrott. Aber wenn jetzt Karen Mioska sich von ihrer Redaktion mühsam vier Fragen diktieren lässt und sie zwei davon vergisst und dann mit denen im Gespräch ist, dann hat das keinen Zweck.
Ja, die machen das schon nicht, weil es ihnen keinen Spaß macht. Ja. Er kommt auf die Wäscheklammer in Frankreich zu sprechen, finde ich einen guten historischen Einwand. Allerdings, also man wählt nicht Le Pen, also Chirac in dem Fall, aber eigentlich will man das gar nicht. Also setzt man sich eine Wäscheklammer auf die Nase und zieht Handschuhe an im Wahllokal und es sich so fotografieren, um zu zeigen, ich mache das hier ganz widerspenstig, aber eben trotzdem eine Stimme gegen Le Pen. Vielleicht kann man das noch mal institutionalisieren, dass man sagt, ich wähle niemanden, aber nicht die AfD. Also dass man die Repräsentation von Nicht-Wählern, wie das ja die Partei, wir lesen es ja gleich, ein bisschen versucht hat, wir repräsentieren die Nicht-Wähler im Parlament. Wir behelligen niemand mit irgendwas, wir sind einfach nur die Nicht-Wähler. Irgendwie so.
Aber dann ist ja auch die Frage, das finde ich auch gut, dass er sich da ein bisschen aus der Deckung wagt, dass er jetzt nicht so Aminata-Berli-Klaas-Häufer-Umlauf-mäßig sagt, und wir retten die Demokratie, indem wir nicht die AfD wählen. Er sagt ja, was bringt eine Brandmauer, wenn es auf beiden Seiten brennt? Und dann hat er die Union als Beispiel. Inhaltliche Schnittpunkte zwischen Union und AfD dürfte es vor allem bei der Migrations- und Sozialpolitik sowie bei Themen rund um Kulturkampf und Leitkultur geben. In Bezug auf Asyl werden die Grundsatzprogramme von AfD und CDU immer ähnlicher. Der neue CDU-Entwurf für das Grundsatzprogramm sieht nämlich vor, der AfD nachzueifern und ebenfalls zu fordern, das individuelle Recht auf Asyl vollständig abzuschaffen. Der einzige Unterschied, die CDU geht in ihrem Programm sogar noch weiter als die AfD und fordert, dass Schutzsuchende in keinem Fall mehr sicher nach Deutschland einreisen dürfen. Richtig gelesen, die CDU fordert ein noch schärferes Asylrecht als die AfD. War mir auch so nicht klar.
Sollte man mit der CDU auch nur noch über rechtsradikale Belange, solange sie sie haben, reden?
Im Prinzip schon, ja.
Fünf-Prozent-Hürde abschaffen, bin ich auch total dafür. Einfach jetzt alle Parteien da unten zulassen. Gerade wenn die Jungen so viel sonstige wählen, also 15, 20 Prozent, die werden alle aus dem Spiel genommen.
Du weißt ja, wer die drei-Prozent-Hürde jetzt, die wahrscheinlich ja kommt, im Europaparlament eingeführt hat oder wer sich dafür über Jahre stark gemacht hat. Michael Roth von der SPD.
Ja, es ist einfach brutal.
Und Künert ist ja auch, nachdem dieses Debakel der Europawahl war, am nächsten Tag schon vor die Presse getreten hat gesagt, ja diese Frikassierung des Parlaments sei ja auch ein großes Problem. Also ich würde mal sagen, wenn ich so sehr verloren habe, dann würde ich mal gucken, ob ich den Schuldigen in den eigenen Reihen finde.
Also wenn die SPD verliert, verliert sie. Da kann sie nicht einfach da, aber Wahlrechtsdiskussionen in Deutschland ist ja eh. Wir kriegen ja demnächst große Verfassungsgerichtsurteile, so die CSU mit der Linken zusammen dagegen, gegen den Ampelgesetzentwurf dagegen. Das Gesetz ist ja schon ein Gesetz, nicht nur ein Entwurf. So, ich will einen kurzen, zum Familienwahlrecht vorlesen. Nicht zu wählen ist ein Recht in der Demokratie, aber dass 23 Millionen Menschen in Deutschland nicht wählen dürfen, weil sie zu jung sind oder keinen deutschen Pass haben, ist schlicht und einfach undemokratisch, finde ich auch.
Ich bin sehr dafür, dass auch Menschen, die hier leben, die keinen deutschen Pass haben, aber schon länger hier leben, auch wählen dürfen. Ich bin nach wie vor nicht dafür, und das werden wir ja dann nochmal ausdiskutieren, dass kleine Kinder wählen dürfen.
Gut, er macht ein ganz klares AfD-Verbieten jetzt, wenn nicht jetzt, wann dann, was soll dieses Gesetz, wozu haben wir es denn, wenn wir es nicht machen in so einer Situation. Ich schließe mich dem nicht ganz an. Willst du noch was dazu sagen, sonst Prepping, dieses Finale.
Lass uns doch noch übers Prepping sprechen, weil das AfD-Verbot, das führt jetzt so weit, das müssen wir vielleicht irgendwann nochmal eigens behandeln.
Also Tag X kennen wir, was ist Tag Y? Y, Prepping, aber nicht individualistisch, sondern kollektiv. Also hier nähern wir uns den Schutz-Ehen. Es ist ein Ansatz, der beinhaltet, Gesellschaft vor allem lokal zu organisieren, Politik von unten. Ich habe kürzlich eine Diskussion mit Dietmar Daert gesehen bei YouTube, er war bei Checker Pin eingeladen und meinte dort…
Ah, die habe ich auch gesehen.
Der große Ansatz linker Proteste, marxistischer Verwirklichung ist, schon im Protest gegen die Zustände, wie sie sind, zu leben, was man leben möchte. Also nicht einfach nur gehen auf die Straße und marschieren, sondern nehmen eine Suppenküche mit und unsere Decken und dann machen wir da schon mal so einen schönen Tag, als ob wir schon erfolgreich gewesen wären. Das erinnert mich so ein bisschen hieran. Er sagt es auch ein paar Mal so explizit, dass Leben schon mal leben, das man gerne leben möchte. Und wenn es im Großen und Ganzen noch nicht geht, dann halt in der kleinen Nachbarschaft. Also strömet aus, liebe Hörerinnen, und lernt euren Kioskbesitzer kennen, den ihr am Tage des Stromausfalls konsultieren könnt auf der Suche nach Essen. Er hat wahrscheinlich einen Lager voll.
Ja, das ist gleich so ganz existenziell, aber das, was ja eigentlich auch da mitschwingt, ist sicherlich das, was ich zu Anfang des Teasers angesprochen habe. In dieser Art des Aktivismus, der hier beschrieben wird und der nicht mal so ein Ad-hoc-Aktivismus nur ist, liegt sicherlich auch eine Erfüllung, was dazu führen könnte, dass man nicht in der Sparkasse mit 80 Jahren steht und sagt, im Grunde ist das Leben an mir vorbei gegangen.
Ja, der Professor-Podcast Moritz Klenk hat auf Instagram, ich verfolge das ganz interessiert, aus Mannheim, die machen da so Kittchen, die haben auch so einen Namen dafür, die Kittchen, also die haben einfach vor dem Hauptbahnhof oder wo das da ist, so eine Küche aufgebaut, wo dann Vorträge gehalten werden, während man zum Essen kommt. Und ich habe ja in meinem Buch auch diese Idee des Urlaubs bis ans Lebensende, also wenn man ins Rentenalter kommt, muss der Staat einem zusichern, nie wieder alleine essen, wenn man das nicht will. Also man findet einfach immer eine Adresse und zwar nicht 45 Euro das Steak im Restaurant, sondern für den üblichen eine Frosttüte kostet 3,50 Euro und dann geht man für 3,50 Euro essen. Sowas zu institutionalisieren, halte ich für immer, immer, immer wichtiger. Ich war jetzt die Woche bei dir in der Gegend da, Montabauer Westerwald, also ganz ab vom Schuss und es gab eine Veranstaltung, die ich angenommen hatte, weil die Einladung so charmant war und das fand in dem, in so einem Gemeinschaftssaal eines Altenheimes stand. Die Bewohner hat man natürlich weit und breit nicht gesehen, aber es saßen so die Leute aus der zivilgesellschaftlichen Umgebung da und in diesen Gebäuden über sowas zu reden ist fast ein Selbstläufer. Du stehst neben dieser Mensa und da gibt es Personal, die es auch immer gut fänden, wenn jemand vorbeikommt, der nicht schon 92 ist und so. Das sind eigentlich die totalen Anlaufspots, aber man braucht halt noch solche Häuser. Ich habe denen dann auch gesagt, ich komme jetzt mit einem Zug, also die Einladung war so, wenn sie mal von Köln nach Frankfurt fahren, steigen sie doch mal in Montabaur aus. Und ich habe dann das so als Witz aufgegriffen und meinte, ja genau, wenn ich mal von Köln nach Frankfurt fahre, weil ich befinde mich natürlich nicht in der Alten Republik, ich befinde mich zwischen Köln und Frankfurt und dazwischen sitze ich im Zug und er fährt mit 300 kmh. Aber wenn ich dann mal aussteige, bin ich dann eigentlich in der Alten Republik. Und dann habe ich gesagt, ne hier nicht. Wenn ich in Thüringen, wo ich aus einem Regionalzug aussteige, da bin ich in der Alten Republik. Weil da gibt es solche Veranstaltungen nicht, schon weil es solche Räumlichkeiten nicht gibt und sich niemand mehr um irgendwelche Älteren kümmert. Hier aber schon. Also es gibt dann, und das sollte man sich dann einfach explizieren. Wenn man so ein Altenheim sieht, das stand wirklich ganz idyllisch oben auf so einem Hang. Dieser Saal hinter mir stellte die Kirche so im Zentrum des Dorfes dar. Also es war wirklich idealtypisch und an solchen Sachen geht man zuachtlos vorbei. Weil das sind die Einflugschneisen in die Bewältigung der alten republikanischen Probleme der nächsten 15 Jahre. Da sind jetzt 100 Leute, die da bettlägerig arbeiten und 12 Leute, die ambulent so Tagespflege, die dann einfach tagsüber kommen. Nur es werden demnächst einfach 100 Leute tagsüber kommen. Und die kriegt man da trotzdem unter. Also man kann denen da Essen geben. Und solche Sachen, an sowas muss ich dann immer denken, wenn er das hier so beschreibt. Also das kann man durchaus mal als großes politisches Programm irgendwie aufziehen. Dass man Nachbarschaftspflege, er kommt da natürlich auf den zivilgesellschaftlichen Sommer der Migration 2015, Corona, all diese Sachen, wo man einfach eine, wie er dann sagt, Verwaltungskrise auf eigener Faust ausgleicht.
Erwähnenswert ist noch dieser Begriff Prepping. Den kennen wir aus Prepping for Future. Der rechten Szene, der Libertäernszene. Das sind also Leute, die skeptisch gegenüber dem Staat sind.
Und die Tanksler.
Und sich sagen, ich muss mich vorbereiten. Er zeigt hier aber, wir sollten auch skeptisch gegenüber dem Staat sein. Er erkennt den Staat sehr gut. Er weiß, welche Veränderungen da schon stattgefunden haben. Er beschreibt uns sehr viel davon. Wir sollten einer Regierung, in der jens sparen ist, nicht vertrauen. Wir sollten einer Regierung auch nicht allzu viel vertrauen, in der jemand Kanzler sein kann, der mal Brechmittel eingesetzt hat und das legitimiert hat. Also er geht sehr viel durch und zeigt uns immer näher. Also der Staat ist doch ein recht kaltes Ungeheuer. Und er zeigt uns hier, dass dieses Prepping von der anderen Seite auch eines ist, dass eine gewisse Skepsis an den Tag legt gegenüber dem Staat. Beziehungsweise man sollte schon jetzt erkennen, deswegen diese Vorbereitung, dass man sich möglicherweise, im Falle aller Fälle, auf den Staat nicht wird verlassen können.
Du sagst jetzt dem Staat nicht vertrauen. Ich würde noch hinzufügen, dem Staat auch nicht zu viel abzuverlangen. Wir hatten ja gerade hier in Hessen Erinnerungen an diese Zeit, als es hieß, wo kann ich hier gegen Ausländer unterschreiben? Da könnte man genauso gut sagen, wenn Leute an den Wahlkampfstand gehen und sagen, wo kann ich denn hier für Ausländer unterschreiben? Da kann man dir noch sagen, sorry, aber das ist keine staatliche Aufgabe. Wenn du was gegen Ausländer hast, musst du die schon selber verprügeln. Nimm deinen Rückstock und mach selber. Aber komm hier nicht zum Staat. Also diese Art von den Staat noch mal neu definieren. Ich finde auch, sehr viele Sachen, die ihr hier beschreibt, also lokal gegen Gesellschaft, so eine eigene Gesellschaft aufzubauen, in dem Maße dann gegen den Staat, wie der Staat sich rechtsradikal gebietet. Und dann versuchen, über diese kleine Gruppenarbeit in die Gesellschaft hineinzuwirken. Das kann man mal ganz unabhängig von Staat machen. Ja, denn wir wollen jetzt den Staat nicht, also auch nicht einen sozialdemokratisch vernünftigen Staat, wollen wir jetzt aufblasen auf DDR-Verhältnisse. Wir vermuten einfach mal, jeder ist ein Teil des Staates irgendwie. Sondern, nee, der Staat hat so ein paar Aufgaben, die muss er regeln. Und darüber hinaus bleiben einfach Aufgaben, die die Menschen mal selber machen müssen. Wer einsam ist, wer gelangweilt ist, wer auch immer, es gibt doch die Vereine vor Ort. Dann geh doch einfach mal hin, streife deinen Stolz ab. Er schreibt ja hier, aus der eigenen Gruppe zu versuchen, in die Gesellschaft hineinzuwürgen und Menschen zu erreichen, die man nicht kennt, ist eine große Herausforderung. Das gilt für alle.
Und die kann auch der Stadt einem nicht abnehmen, diese Herausforderung.
Die Leute haben Angst vor ihren Nachbarn, sie trauen sich nirgendwo mal jemanden anzusprechen, leben so vor sich hin. Und dann mündet das alles in so einer 23 Uhr, ich gehe jetzt ins Bett, ich radikalisiere mich noch bei YouTube, wie der Staat scheitert. Aber es ist ihr Ereignis scheitern.
Auch das.
Dann muss hier die Leute mal so ein bisschen...
Naja, das ist manchmal, hat man so sehr dieses Prinzip Eigenverantwortung mit FDP assoziiert, dass man jetzt plötzlich glaubt, dass alles, was man eigenverantwortlich tut, eigentlich schon eine neoliberale Subjektivität ist. Und das stimmt ja nicht.
Ja, wir kriegen so oft diese Frage, wir haben es schon so häufig thematisiert. Warum geht ihr nicht in die Politik, Stefan? Warum bist du nicht in der Politik, Wolfgang? Wieso lagerst du das aus an irgendwen? Nur weil er dir gefällt oder du da gerne zuhörst oder was? Geh doch selber in die Politik. Weißt du, ich mache nur meine Podcasts, will ich in Ruhe gelassen werden. Und ich belästige auch nicht die ganze Zeit den Staat damit.
Du willst ja dann zum Beispiel dich um den Schwimmverein kümmern und nicht sagen, ich will mich jetzt mit irgendwelchen Politikern schweigen. Ich habe einen Termin bei meinen Schwimmkindern.
Wenn du in die Politik gehen willst, dann geh selber in die Politik. Das Plädoyer hätte dadurch noch ein bisschen stärker machen können. Zivilgesellschaft nicht nur als Gegenmodell des rechtsradikalen Staates, den er befürchtet, sondern als grundsätzlich mal gute Idee. Aber das steckt ja alles so weit drin. Also das ist kein Vorwurf an ihn, sondern an Leser, die hier irgendwie denken, ja, und jetzt baue ich mal den, die gegen, ne, baue erst mal überhaupt was auf. Mach erst mal überhaupt irgendwas.
Wir können jedenfalls dieses Buch empfehlen.
Absolut.
Denn es ist konkret, es ist pragmatisch, es ist empirisch fundiert, es ist ein Buch, das wirklich jetzt wichtig sein wird, wirklich als Gebrauchsanweisung. Es heißt ja eine Anleitung zum Widerstand. Und genau das hat man hier auch bekommen. Also nicht eine Sonntagsrede, die braucht auch jetzt niemand. Da kann man auch zur Not irgendeine KI bitten, schreib mal für mich eine Sonntagsrede gegen den Rechtsruck. Wird wahrscheinlich dann alles vorkommen, was wir schon kennen.
Das kannst du eigentlich zumachen, dieses Amt da in Berlin, ne?
Das kannst du zumachen. Stattdessen hat man hier eine konkrete Anleitung. Und ich bin sehr, sehr überrascht, dass wirklich mal das so klar auf 230 Seiten geschieht.
Ja, ich hatte fragt den Staat auch nicht auf dem Schirm. Bis jetzt, wie der Cars-Communication-Kongress war, nach langer Corona-Pause, vergangenen Dezember. Und da hat er ja mehrere Talks gehabt auf der Bühne. Und es waren, das muss man dann in diesem Kontext auch immer sagen, die unterhaltsamen. Denn da stehen wirklich sehr viele Nerds auf der Bühne, die so, keine Ahnung, ach, ich soll hier was sagen und so. Und er hat sich wirklich sehr viel Mühe gegeben, hat da sein Team mit auf der Bühne gehabt, die haben auch gesungen und so weiter. Ich habe es ja schon betont. Man kann jetzt unabhängig des Buches, oder abhängig des Buches, auch mal bei fragtdenstaat.de einfach auf die Webseite gehen und sich so angucken, was die machen und diesen Talk sich anschauen, wo er Nina Tschuba singt. Nina Tschuba adaptiert das Lied gut auf der Bühne. Also du gehst ja mehr in die Schlagerrichtung und so, aber da wird es popkulturell natürlich ein bisschen interessanter. Den sehe ich sehr gutes Buch, empfohlen.
Arne Semsrott legt mit Machtübernahme eine Anleitung zum Widerstand vor, die sehr, sehr gut ist, denn dieses Buch ist pragmatisch, es ist konkret, es ist empirisch fundiert und es zeigt, dass es jetzt, wo der Rechtsruck immer stärker wird, keine Sonntagsreden braucht, sondern man braucht ein klares Handlungsgerüst. Man braucht ein Verständnis für die Macht, für die Institutionen des Staates. Und wie kann man es verhindern, dass sie von rechts angeeignet werden?
Und wir kriegen noch mal Hinweise darauf, dass man sein Leben nicht allein damit füllen muss, auf den Staat sauer und wütend zu sein, sondern man kann im Kleinen, unabhängig davon, ob man in einer rechtsradikalen Gesellschaft durch und durch lebt oder nicht, ein kleines Gegenmodell einfach für sich planen und leben. Diese Hinweise sind sehr gut. Was sagst du als Filmkritiker zu diesem Titel?
Brügge sehen und sterben ist ein sehr sehenswerter Film. Brüssel sehen und sterben, ein vielleicht etwas abgeschmackter Titel, da man ja diese Formulierungen sehen und sterben durch diesen erfolgreichen Film schon sehr häufig hatte. Aber offenbar funktioniert's. Der Verlag hat es wahrscheinlich ausgesucht, würde ich mal denken.
Ja, wer sonst? Also wenn der Autor schon sagt, ich habe da nur ein paar Notizen abgegeben und das fertige Werk nicht mal gelesen, war ihm wahrscheinlich ganz egal, wie das restliche Buch gestaltet wird.
Ja, also für die Leute, die Nico Semsrott nicht kennen, da gibt es bestimmt auch einige. Nico Semsrott war im Europaparlament, ist gewählt wurden für die Partei. An der Seite von Sonneborn ist er eingezogen. Dann gab es einen Streit zwischen Semsrott und Sonneborn. Daraufhin ist Semsrott aus der Partei verabschiedet. Er hat sich dann der Grünen-Fraktion im Europaparlament angeschlossen, ist jetzt aber nicht wieder zur Wahl angetreten, sondern reflektiert jetzt diese Jahre von 2019 bis 2024, die er im EU-Parlament verbracht hat. Er ist bekannt geworden als Stand-up-Comedian oder Poetry-Slammer, der sehr deutlich immer macht, ich bin ein depressiver Mensch. Und als depressiver Mensch mache ich zwar hier Unterhaltung, aber ich kombiniere immer alle meine Auftritte auch mit der Figur, die ich geschaffen habe, nämlich er tritt immer mit Kapuzenpulli auf. Und zu dieser Figur gehört auch, dass sie immer wieder über ihre Depressionen redet. Aber das bedeutet nicht, das wird manchmal verwechselt. Es handelt sich hier um eine depressive Kunstfigur. Und in Wahrheit haben wir da einen freundlichen, gesunden Menschen. Nein, Nico Semsrott hat Depressionen und macht das aber auch zum Thema auf der Bühne. Und es ist auch ein großes Thema seines Buchs. Der Untertitel lautet, wie ich im Europaparlament meinen Glauben an fast alles verloren habe. Und Glauben kann man ja nur verlieren, wenn man an etwas geglaubt hat. Also da ist offenbar jemand mit einem gehörigen Maß an Idealismus in das Europaparlament gegangen und war dann verwundert darüber, welche Zustände da herrschen. Oder vielleicht war die Erwartung nicht ganz so hoch und dann wurde sie aber noch mal so unterboten, dass er jetzt gar nicht einen noch ausweist.
An diesem Punkt eine Klammer zu seinem Bruder. Arne Semsrott schreibt ja und den Spruch hat er auch auf der Bühne gebracht. Es ist eigentlich total hoffnungslos, doch dann passiert etwas und ich merke, ich hatte doch noch Hoffnung. Also es geht immer noch eine Etage tiefer und so ist dann auch dieses Buch hier zu verstehen. Es ist eine Reise des Scheiterns, wie er sagt, durch die deprimierendste Phase seines Lebens, nämlich im Europaparlament zu sitzen und mit unendlichen Privilegien nichts geregelt zu kriegen. Und zwar nicht nur, weil man selber antriebslos ist, sondern weil man sich die ganze Zeit fragt, wozu mache ich das hier eigentlich gerade? Und er schaut dann nicht nur auf sich, sondern auch auf die anderen und sagt, keine Ahnung, wie die anderen das machen, so zu tun, als wären sie von ihrer Rolle überzeugt, als würde das, was wir da tun, irgendeinen Sinn machen. Also die Stimmung ist gesetzt. Und was ihn erschüttert hat, ist der Egoismus. Und dann fragt er den Leser, niedlich, oder? Ich dachte, es ging weniger um Karriere, weniger um eigene Vorteile, mehr um Überzeugung. Das ist dann so ein Punkt relativ früh im Buch, bei dem ich mir denke, ja, wir haben uns halt alle in die Irre führen lassen. Und dann kommt irgendwie ein Fall selg und sagt, die ganzen Demokratientheorien stimmen nicht mehr. Ich sage, nee, die haben nie gestimmt. Lasst euch doch nicht von irgendwelchen Leuten im Medienbetrieb oder der Politik vorgaukeln. Es ginge hier um das Gemeinwohl oder was auch immer. Es gilt die Logik von Adam Toos, Mehrheiten organisieren. Es bleiben Minderheiten übrig, okay. Dann die Mehrheiten so organisieren, dass nicht die Minderheiten so wütend werden, dass es überschlägt und wir die Mehrheit verlieren. Aber bitte in den Bulldozer setzen und durch die politische Landschaft fahren und nicht hier appellieren, dass die Gegenseite ja auch am Allgemeinwohl interessiert. Nein, ist nicht. Er sagt dann Egoismus, ja, die vernünftige politische Literatur, die das alles reflektiert, spricht hier von Rationalität.
Und von Interessen.
Von Interessen, genau, von all dem Kram.
Egoismus ist ein Begriff, den kann man anwenden in der Familie, in der Beziehung, in der Freundschaft. Du bist aber egoistisch, du kannst jetzt auch mal ein Kompromiss mit mir eingehen. Diese Debatten kann man führen. Das braucht man nicht jemandem von der CSU zu sagen, der dort sitzt, um seinen Agrarbetrieb zu sichern.
Ja, also diese Ernüchtertheit hat sehr viel mit Unaufgeklärtheit, mit Ahnungslosigkeit, mit Naivität zu tun. Er unterstellt sich das dann irgendwann selber.
Und er sagt aber dann, meine Naivität ist richtig, sagt er ja schon zu Anfang. Da würde ich sagen, nein, diese Naivität, in dem Sinne ist sie richtig, dass, wenn ich das moralisch beurteile, sage, ja, Menschen sollten nicht betrügen. Menschen sollten nicht korrupt sein. Menschen sollten sich für andere Menschen einsetzen. All das kann ich so sagen und so empfinden, aber ich muss einfach wissen, dass die Politik ein anderes Spiel ist. Und deswegen habe ich ja auch diese Adam-Tooth-Clips mitgebracht. Und Tuth hatte in einem anderen Podcast gesagt, die Politik ist ein schweinisches System. Und Trump zeigt den Leuten wenigstens, dass es exakt so ist. Und das lieben sie durchaus daran. Jetzt muss man nicht in einen solchen Zynismus verfallen. Aber man muss sich klar sein, dass es ein Kampf um Macht ist und dass man den Bulldozer braucht. Wenn man aber jetzt der Ansicht ist, dass man eigentlich nur darauf warten muss, dass sich genügend Versammeln oder genügend Wähler finden, die nur noch gute Menschen zulassen, dann wird man vergeblich warten. Also dann wird man immer wieder sagen, warum eigentlich nicht? Das ist am Ende so hilflos wie ein an sich hübsches Lied, aber es ist politisch hilflos von Nicole ein bisschen Frieden. Man kann dafür sein und das ist auch schön. Und immerhin ist man nicht für ein bisschen Krieg. Aber es ist eine relativ hilflose Geste. Und was ich aber hier sehe, ist, dass man so Idealismen hat, quasi auch Maximalforderungen an die Politik stellt. Selbst dann Teil im Betrieb wird, damit aber nicht zurechtkommt, dass es plötzlich um Machtpolitik geht, die man ausüben muss. Und dann sich quasi wieder so ganz rausnimmt, indem man sagt, ich trete da nicht mehr an, schreibe jetzt noch mal ein Buch, Brügge sehen und sterben, Brüssel sehen und sterben und dann ist gut. Und das ist, glaube ich, eine generelle Haltung. Vor allem bei jüngeren Leuten, die dann in so einen, also vom Idealismus direkt in den totalen Vaterlismus gehen. Und ich glaube, wir können das auch sehr gut erkennen, jetzt bei den ganz vielen jungen Abgeordneten. Die sind natürlich nicht wie Semsrott. Viele sind da nicht idealistisch. Die sind opportunistisch unterwegs. Aber was bei denen, aber manche haben ja wirklich Anliegen, das würde ich ihnen glauben. Aber sie sind ja nicht bereit, für diese Anliegen selbst einmal in der eigenen Partei den Bulldozer rauszuholen. Das heißt, es gibt bei sehr vielen Leuten, die jung sind, die in die Politik gehen, dieses Machtbewusstsein nicht, sondern nur ein Opportunismus, der darauf schielt, ob ich das Privileg Bundestagsabgeordneter bleiben zu können haben oder nicht. Und das ist etwas, was Semsrott mit den vielen jungen Politikern dann auch verbindet.
Ja, wenn man ein Mandat erringt, ist das der Führerschein für den Bulldozer. Wenn man dann nicht losfährt, ist nicht der Bulldozer schuld, weil er irgendwie nicht losgefahren ist, sondern man hat dann seinen Piloten postend bekommen. Und wenn man sich als einer von 700 Abgeordneten, ja, dann ist man halt nur einer von 700. Aber eine Stufe vorher ist man einer von so und so vielen Millionen Wählern. Und näher ran an die Macht kommt man nicht. Also als Parlamentarier muss man dann auch mal was machen. Und in deren Sicht ist dieses Buch wahnsinnig interessant, weil es uns einfach so eine Forensik erlaubt. An enttäuschten Wählern. Und wie Politik dann doch mal wirklich funktioniert. Aber nicht im Sinne von, oh, die große Aufklärung und so weiter, sondern einhegen der Ernüchterung. Es ist, wie es ist. Aber das muss man dann einfach akzeptieren. Und trotzdem schon mal anfangen, das Leben zu leben, das man gerne, auf das man abzielt. Das kann man durchaus als Parlamentarier ja schon machen. Gerade, wenn man sich sagt, nach dieser Amtszeit ist mir egal und mein Mandat ist frei. Dann kann man das einfach machen. Also, der hindert Ihnen jetzt niemand dran.
Bei ihm ist ja einfach eine Krankheit, die vorliegt. Und ich würde aber dann auch sagen, ja, man kann die auch als solche thematisieren, wie er das tut. Ich würde aber sagen, dass man schon auch eine Trennung vornehmen muss dann in der Analyse. Das heißt also, man kann zum einen sagen, ich habe eine Krankheit, nämlich Depression. Und ich habe zugleich ein deprimierendes Umfeld. Aber ich darf es nicht zu sehr miteinander verkoppeln. Denn viele sind im Parlament, die nicht Depression haben und die also einen anderen Umgang damit finden. Und dann kann man immer noch sagen, die Situation als Ganzes ist deprimierend, aber sie führt nicht in die Depression. Also ich glaube, dass man nochmal dieses individuelle, der Krankheit etwas stärker abspalten sollte von dem Erlebten dort im Parlament, dass natürlich das Frustrierende im Parlament dann möglicherweise seine Krankheit verstärkt, so wie er es ja beschreibt. Das ist bestimmt so, das will ich ja auch gar nicht in Frage stellen. Ich glaube nur, dass man das, um es analysieren zu können, ein bisschen auseinanderhalten muss. Und was mich bei dem Buch wundert, ist, dass man sich doch mal vorstellen muss, was ist eigentlich die EU? Das ist eine Konstruktion aus sehr vielen Staaten mit sehr vielen Interessen. Es gibt dort verschiedene Institutionen, die einander kooperierend oder blockierend zur Seite stehen. Und dann haben wir 700 Abgeordnete. Das Parlament hat kein Initiativrecht. Das kritisiert er auch, das kritisiert er zurecht. Wir haben eine Kommissionspräsidentin, die nicht gewählt wurde. Sie wurde von der Bevölkerung gewählt, sondern irgendwelche Deals werden gemacht. Und dann ist das Ursula von der Leyen.
Ja, sie ist indirekt doppelt demokratisch legitimiert. Also gewählte ist eigentlich sogar über drei eng.
Aber wir haben ja sehr, also wenn wir jetzt die SPD...
Wir wählen aber auch den Innenminister nicht, sondern das sind ernannte Verwaltungschefs.
Genau, den Innenminister wählen wir nicht.
Und das ist auch ein Verwaltungschef der Kommissionsposten. Komm, also alle Kommissare.
So kann man das sehen. Aber du würdest ja nicht sagen, es gibt da erhebliche demokratische Defizite, wenn da noch nicht mal das Parlament ein Initiativrecht hat.
Naja, die Erklärung...
Und sehr stark zum Abnicken verdammt ist.
Die Erklärung der Politikwissenschaftler ist doppelt indirekt legitimiert, weil wir haben die Parlamentarier gewählt, die sie bestätigen. Und das machen sie ja inzwischen. Und wir haben unsere nationalen Regierungen gewählt, die sie entsenden. Ja. Es ist also doppelt, aber indirekt. Ich würde auch sagen, aber das sind so Themen, ich würde mich da gar nicht groß dran aufhängen. Denn manche Themen laufen einfach unter, es ist, wie es ist.
Okay, aber man muss ja ein bisschen erklären, woher die Frustration kommt. Und die Frustration wäre ja wahrscheinlich bei einem jeden erst mal da, wenn man dort ist und sieht, okay, man kann relativ wenig bewegen, weil es jetzt auch nicht so ist, dass man einfach eine parlamentarische Mehrheit sich besorgt und dann geht etwas, sondern er beschreibt ja dann sehr gut an den Kommissionen, an diesem großen Einfluss, den die nationalen Regierungen auf die EU haben. Es ist ja nicht losgelöst, abgetrennt davon, dass also die eigenen Möglichkeitenräume äußerst klein sind. Und wo wenig Wirksamkeit zu erzielen ist, wächst die Frustration. Das kennt ihr auch. Also dieses Bürokratische, was ihr hier beschreibt, jeder aus großen Unternehmen oder auch aus Behörden. Was ich jetzt nur erst mal deutlich machen will, ist, dass wo man es mit einem solch modernen Konstrukt zu tun hat, hat man es auch mit modernen Bürokratien, Bedingungen, einem Verwaltungskonstrukt zu tun. Dass diese Art von Idealismus, den jeder hat, ich gehe rein und verändere die Welt, die sind gemacht dafür, dass das nicht stattfinden kann. Also dann muss man König werden. Dann muss man König werden und sagen, Stefan, ab jetzt machst du dies und das. Dann weise ich dich da an und dann musst du das befolgen. Wenn man aber nicht in Königreich unter sich hat, dann muss man sich in diese Gefilde begeben. Dann muss man diese mühende Ebenen durcharbeiten, die sehr absurd zum Teil sind. Also ich würde sagen, die Dysfunktionalität, die man da in Brüssel errichtet hat, die schreit schon zum Himmel. Und da ist man erstaunt über das, was man alles lesen kann. Aber grundsätzlich wird man nicht unbürokratisch ein Konstrukt wie Europa leiten können.
Also wir steigen mal in das Buch ein. Und ich will aber zu dieser Vorrede, insbesondere weil ich das unerhört finde, wie der Semsrott das schreibt. Nico Semsrott hat hier keine Sensibilität für die Geschichte dieses Hauses und für seine aktuelle Funktionsweise. Man könnte dieses Buch auch, man müsste es ganz anders anlegen. Die Europäische Union war nicht handlungsunfähig wie er in der Zeit, in der er dort im Parlament saß. Er selber sagt uns, ich wollte da rein, um da als Kulisse für meine Videos und so weiter, ich habe mich weiter als Comedian verstanden. Und dann hat die Parlamentsverwaltung mir verboten, Räumlichkeiten zu nutzen, um sie als Kulisse zu benutzen. Und darüber ereifert und ergötzt er sich ohne Ende. Und da würde ich sagen, ja, das ist nun mal nicht die Funktion dieses Hauses. Du hast in Brüssel auch die Kulisse, machst wie jeder Journalist, stell dich vor das Haus. Da kommt niemand. Und wir wissen ja, dass du ein Teil dieses Hauses bist. Das wird dann schon transportiert für den Zuschauer. Das Europäische Parlament ist kein Parlament mehr, in das deutsche Abgeordnete, also Bundestagsabgeordnete, entsandt werden, um alle drei Monate mal ein Wortwechsel mit dem Polen zu führen. Das Europäische Parlament ist auch kein Parlament, in dem man einfach nur rumsetzt und nichts bestimmen darf. Sondern er beschreibt ja, wie viele Entscheidungen den Parlamentariern vorgelegt werden, was er ganz albern findet. Ja, aber so laufen Abstimmungsprozesse. All das macht das Europäische Parlament, weil sich die Parlamentarier diese Rechte erkämpft haben, eigene Abgeordnete zu sein, gewählt zu werden, darüber bestimmen zu dürfen, welche Vorschläge aus der EU-Kommission kommen, sie nicht nur ja oder nein zustimmungspflichtig sich hinzulegen, sondern auch noch mitreden zu dürfen, dass die Europäische Kommission hat ein Initiativrecht für Vorschläge, die dem Parlament vorgelegt werden. Das Parlament verhält sich dazu, formuliert um, koppelt das zurück. Am Ende wird mit dem Ministerräten im Trilog zugegebenermaßen sehr klein und intransparent darüber befunden, was passiert. Aber diese deutsche Logik, kein Gesetz kommt aus dem Parlament raus, wie es reingegangen ist von der Regierung, ist nicht. Hier wird nicht durchregiert. Also es findet eine Europawahl statt. Die Kommissare müssen sich dem Parlament erklären und können dort auch abgelehnt werden. Und vielleicht in dieser Runde auch schon einzeln und gar nicht mehr alle und so. Also es geht Schritt für Schritt voran, weil sich Menschen eingebracht haben, um diese Schritte zu gehen. Und diese Schritte waren alle sehr anstrengend. Aber so wie er das beschreibt, dass hier einfach nicht ein politisches Thema vorkommt aus seiner Amtszeit, er nennt nicht ein einziges. Er erklärt uns nicht, welche Fraktionen haben denn in welchen Ausschüssen welche Berichterstatter ernannt, um sich in diesen Themen zu engagieren. Wie läuft dieses Engagement ab? Auch bei ihm kamen irgendwann mal die Berichterstatter vorbei und fragten, hör mal zu, Nico, du bist zwar jetzt hier nicht in der Regierungsabteilung, also du gehörst nicht zu den Fraktionen, die die Geschäfte führen, aber du sitzt ja in diesem und jedem Ausschuss. Was sagst du denn zu diesem Vorschlag der Europäischen Union? Ich sammle gerade alle Vorschläge der Parlamentarier zusammen, um die danach aufzusummieren, damit wir darüber befinden können, wie wir uns dazu verhalten. Wenn er diese kleinen Schritte nicht mitgeht, die ihm nun wirklich angeboten wurden zu gehen, dann braucht er sich darüber nicht zu beklagen. Also diese ganze Anlage dieses Buches finde ich unter dieser Maxime wirklich bescheuert, weil es ist sozusagen das Gegenbuch zu Arne Semsrott. Arne Semsrott sagt uns, du bist mittellos, freundelos, jung an Jahren und weißt nicht wohin mit deinem Leben, versuch trotzdem eine bessere Gesellschaft zu machen. Und hier, ich war Abgeordneter im Europaparlament, ich hatte unendliche Privilegien, ich bin mit erster Klasse durch Deutschland gefahren, musste mich nicht darum kümmern und habe trotzdem noch 539 Euro Reisekostenpauschale abgerechnet. Leider konnte ich gar nichts machen. Und das geht so einfach nicht. Also das ist keine Ansprache an... Ich hoffe nicht, dass junge Leute dieses Buch lesen und ernst nehmen.
Ja, ich finde gut, dass du das so klar herausarbeitest. Denn ich muss auch sagen, er will eigentlich Aktivismus, und zwar Aktivismus mit, seht mal her, was ich gemacht habe, im Europaparlament veranstalten. Also er bringt ein Beispiel, da geht er unglaublich lange drauf ein, dass er mit Geldern, die da sein Büro für irgendwelche Werbeaktionen und so weiter zur Verfügung hat, Tampons kauft. Und die mit irgendwelchen Logos und Sprüchen versieht. Und diese Tampons, also er kauft dann für ein paar Zehntausend Euro diese Tampons, die werden dann verschenkt an Frauenhäuser etc. Ja, da kann man jetzt sagen, seht her, was ich gemacht habe. Ich habe für 30.000 Euro Tampons verschenkt, und er hat dann auch noch aufgefordert, andere Politiker sollten es ihm gleich tun. Dies mindert das grundsätzliche Problem nur minimal. Ich kann auch mit dem Klingelbeutel mal rund gehen bei den Abordneten für irgendwas Geld sammeln. Schön die Aktionen. Wichtig ist, das Gesetz einzubringen, das Hygieneartikel für Frauen kostenlos macht. Das ist das Entscheidende. Nicht 30.000 Euro habe ich aus meinen Bürogeldern locker gemacht, um dies und das zu machen.
Über 200 Millionen Frauen in Europa, was hat er hier gemacht? Er beschreibt am Anfang, er wollte in dieses Parlament, um dann meine Videos dazu machen. Ich hatte gar nicht Dodi Große und so weiter. Das ist dieser Punkt, den wir gerade noch beschrieben haben, als Vorsicht, wenn die AfD Budgets für so einen Quatsch bekommt. Wir haben gerade noch davor gewarnt. Er versucht uns jetzt, das als ernsthaften Lebensinhalt eines Parlamentaris zu verklickern.
Dann beschreibt er, dass er vorhatte, so eine Late-Night-Show zu machen, in der er Europathemen, EU-Parlamentsthemen verhandelt. Dann haben sie da eine Räumlichkeit. Dann haben sie ein Team, haben Gagautoren und was weiß ich alles angeheuert. Also er kann ja auch Mitarbeiter dann bezahlen, wenn er diese Position hat. Und dann kommen ein, zwei Sendungen zustande oder vier Sendungen zustande und das war es dann. Wir wissen doch, wie die AfD Content macht. Maximilian Krah holt das Smartphone raus und sagt, Türken in Deutschland würden recht sein. Warum? Das sage ich dir in einer Minute. So funktionieren heute Inhalte. Warum hat man hier nicht mit drei Leuten jeden Tag Content gemacht, der überall verbreitet wird? Also man hat ja tolle Möglichkeiten, indem man für sich das Geld bekommt und noch Mitarbeiter beschäftigen kann. Warum will man jetzt ein ZDF-Studio erst mal nachbauen und will so eine Böhmermann-Situation schaffen und erst dann kann ich was machen? Nein, man könnte eigentlich, weil man die Miete alles ist bezahlt, könnte man jetzt wirklich frei drehen. Also wir machen hier ein Podcast. Ganz ohne Mandat. Darum geht es mir jetzt gar nicht. Wir erreichen viele Leute, indem wir einfach in zwei Mikrofone sprechen. Du hast ein bisschen Equipment, kannst das schneiden und so. Aber das sind ja Produktionskosten. Die hier gar nicht auffallen, wenn du so ein Budget hast. Das ist irgendwie das, was du auch für Kugelschreiber ausgeben könntest im Büro. So, das reicht. Nur man muss es dann machen.
Genau, man muss es machen. Man muss in den Bulldozer steigen und dann egal welchen.
Das findet aber hier nicht statt. Und dann muss ich sagen, ja, das ist im höchsten Maße ärgerlich, dass das nicht ist. Und ja, ich stehe sehr ratlos vor diesem Buch. Oh, ich will dich was fragen, wir haben ja diese Privilegien-Geschichte, du hast es gerade schon gesagt, man bekommt da irrsinniges Fahrtgeld.
Die gehen wir auch gleich mal durch. Die Forensik, die hier angeboten wird, die sich für uns ermöglicht, ist schon nicht schlecht.
Ja, sollen wir die mal durchziehen?
Unabhängig der Ideen, die der Autor damit verbindet. Aber wir haben ja doch mal einen Einblick, der so ein bisschen uns jenseits seiner eigenen Ansinnen, also klar, er wiederholt noch mal diese ganze Geschichte von seiner Partei, wie er da als Nichtwähler, als Repräsentant der Nichtwähler hingeht und sagt, okay, dann filmen wir jetzt einen Höchstwalter ein. Wir haben ja ein 18. Lebensjahr Mindestalter, jetzt 16 Jahre. Warum nicht ein Höchstwalter? Das sind halt so kleine Pointen, die man dann machen kann, bei denen ich auch, wenn ich das kurz erwähne, dann immer so bei solchen Veranstaltungen wie jetzt am Westerwald. Ich sag dann dazu, das ist nicht meine Meinung. Ich will nur kurz thematisieren, illustrieren, wo ich Ungerechtigkeiten sehe, die man durchaus ausgleichen kann. Mindestalter, warum nicht ein Höchstalter? Aber ich würde niemals sagen, da machen wir eine Pointe draus, kleiden das überhaupt in Comedy oder wie auch immer. Dennoch, die Partei erfolgreich, finde ich auch zu Recht. Ich finde es auch nicht verkehrt, im Sinne wie Sonneborn das macht, die eine Minute Redezeit auszubeuten und daraus YouTube-Videos zu machen. Das ist nicht verkehrt. Na gut, also, er wundert sich darüber, dass so viel gelogen wird und sich niemand für irgendetwas interessiert. Wahrheit, da kommt natürlich immer auf die CDU-Politiker zu sprechen. Also, warum dem nicht einfach Satire gegenüberstellen. Und diesen Hinweis finde ich auch ganz gut. Wenn Menschen Satirikerinnen wählen, ist vorher an anderer Stelle etwas kaputtgegangen. Nicht Satirikerinnen sind ursächlich verantwortlich, sondern die Parteien, die an der Macht sind. Denn, sagt er dann, es findet ja ohnehin Satire statt. Nur ich flacke meine aus. Ich stehe nicht wie Manfred Weber da und steige aus meinem extra in Bayern noch anberaumten Dienstwagen, um dann zu sagen, das Bürgergeld ist aber viel zu hoch und eine gemeinsame europäische Sozialpolitik geht nicht. So, dann würde ich sagen, ja genau. Daran sollte man sich auch mal abarbeiten. Nur das hat er uns ja auch nicht in den fünf Jahren angeboten, mal über die anderen so aufgeklärt zu werden. Er geht die Institutionen kurz durch. Das finde ich ganz interessant, wie er welche Illustrationen erwählt. Der Europäische Rat, okay, ist irgendwie eine Blackbox. Der Hochadel, der Europäische Rat ist der Hochadel. Ihm gegenüber steht der Klerus, die europäische Kommission. Hochadel und Klerus klären die Sachen unter sich. Das hat natürlich so ein gewisses Geschmäckler nach diesem Supreme Court-Urteil in Amerika, dass wir jetzt hier nicht nur eine satirische Denkart angeboten bekommen, sondern irgendwie so ein bisschen Realität. Und zwar strukturell in Grundbegriffen beschreibende Realität, dass sich hier Geschichte in diesem Maße wirklich wiederholt. Und dass Parlament dann eben nur ein Bauernparlament ist, von dem ich aber wieder sage, ja, es ist aber nicht nur ein Rede- und Laberparlament, wo man mal hin entsandt wird, sondern es ist eben ein eigenständiges Parlament. Und in diesem Maße wie er sich über die Parlamentsverwaltung, die ihn da immer auskreuzt. Ja, aber es gibt so eine Parlamentsverwaltung. Und die sichert ja auch die Integrität des Hauses dort ab. Die Frage ist halt nur, wie sie inhaltlich unterfüttert. Und darüber kriegen wir jetzt Aufklärung. Und das macht es dann auch interessant für uns. Ich würde eben sagen, dieses Buch muss dann aber in aufgeklärte Hände, die da ganz spezifisch mit eigenen Fragestellungen an die Sachen rangehen und herauskristallisieren, wie dieses europäische Parlament funktioniert, ohne sich vom Autor jetzt in die Irre führen zu lassen oder in eine Depression stürzen lassen. Also sozusagen ist es eigentlich das ideale Buch für einen Salon wie unsern, angeleitetes Lesen. Wir sind eure Firewall gegen die Depression, die hier drin steht.
Ja, aber man muss schon sehr inspirativ rangehen an die Sache. Oder man muss schon sehr viel Wissen mitbringen über die EU, um dann nochmal was dem abzugewinnen.
Hier habe ich ein Beispiel, was er witzig findet. Und ich aber gar nicht. Und unter keinem Umständen.
Ich gucke mal, ob ich das witzig finde.
Ja, er schreibt, also das Parlament an sich ist ein symbolischer Ort. Guck mal, wir sitzen hier alle zusammen und statt Krieg zu führen, haben wir uns in einem mega komplizierten und unerträglich langweiligen Prozess geeinigt. Es gibt Momente, in denen ich in einem stickigen Raum sitze und denke, dann lieber Krieg. Solche Sätze, finde ich, haben jetzt einen Geschmack. Oder sie sind irgendwie regierter Le Pen und die Bundesregierung ist auf nichts vorbereitet. Also während sie glaubten, Trump wird verhindert und sie werden einen europäischen Abwehrschirm für alles Mögliche inklusive Atomwaffen mit Amerika organisieren, stellen dann fest, ach so, nee, ist gar nicht. Und das Umschwenken auf Frankreich ist dann auch nicht möglich, weil dort einfach Deutschlandhasser regieren. Dann sind solche Sätze, dann lieber Krieg, nee. Ich bin dagegen. So kann man nicht darüber reden.
Ja, man muss ja erkennen, dass die Verhinderung des Krieges auch bedeutet, Bürokratie zuzulassen. Also da, wo nicht mehr die große Bürokratie waltet, wo man dann nur noch aufeinander losgeht. Also Karl Schmitt war ja ein Verächter des Parlaments. Er hat ja dieses berühmte Buch geschrieben über die geistesgeschichtliche Lage des Parlaments, der parlamentarischen Demokratie und er beschreibt da, dass es eine ewige Diskussion im Parlament gibt und das hasste er. Er wollte natürlich die Entscheidung haben, die eine Entscheidung, die trifft der Einzelne, der Souverän, der Souverän. Und die ewige Diskussion führt natürlich dazu, dass es wahnsinnig frustrierend ist und geht es dann nicht mehr voran. Es kann doch gar nicht sein, warum dauert das dann so lange. Alles auch richtig und mitunter Dinge effizienter zu gestalten, ist immer möglich. Und ich glaube, im Europaparlament ist da vieles zu beschleunigen. Aber die Schnelligkeit, die man da eigentlich gerne haben möchte, die gibt es da nicht. Dann muss man auch wieder sagen, dann zurück in die frühe Neuzeit. Dann habt ihr den Souverän, der entscheidet von heute auf morgen. Der kann sich aber auch morgen wieder ganz anders entscheiden. Vor allem wird er sich nicht vorher absichern, ob ihr auch Lust darauf habt, sondern er wird das für sich so tun, wie er will. Siehe Trump, hätte das vielleicht vor. Und alles andere, also ich komme mir selbst ein bisschen langweilig vor, dass ich jetzt hier so den Parlamentarismus verteidige, aber man kann es sich auch nicht so einfach machen. Wenn man aber die Opposition hat, die Option hat Krieg oder langweiliger Parlamentarismus, würde ich sagen, langweiliger Parlamentarismus scheint mir die Sinnvolle zu sein.
Man kann sich einfach die Gegenfrage stellen. Schützen graben, Ukraine, man verteidigt auf Befehl von, man weiß es nicht mehr, man wurde einfach aus einem weißen VW-Bus rausgeschickt und dann wurde gesagt, da ist die Front, da drüben steht der Russe, wenn du was siehst, schieß. In diesem Moment sagt man sich dann, das ist viel besser als jetzt im Europaparlament mit 12.000 Euro im Monat und so weiter. Er hat es natürlich witzig gemeint, aber ich finde, hier ist nicht mal ein versteckter Witz drin. Das ist einfach bittere Realität, mit der wir jetzt klarkommen müssen.
Ich habe dann mal so ein bisschen überlegt. Ich meine, er ist jemand, der quasi als selbständiger Comedian unterwegs ist. Eigentlich führt er kein sehr viel anderes Leben als wir beide, die in der Selbstständigkeit sind und jetzt so entscheiden, wie wir so alles gestalten, was wir so machen wollen. Also schreiben wir jetzt ein Buch, machen wir Auftritte, nehmen wir noch einen Podcast auf. Und wir haben ja keine Organisation. Und du hast ja eigentlich es auch, sobald es kompliziert wird, sobald man jetzt mit drei Redaktionen noch mal was besprechen müsste. Und deswegen können wir ja auch das hier so gut machen, weil wir das alles nicht dazwischen haben. Wir wären wahrscheinlich keine guten Parlamentarier. Aber wir sind auch nicht da.
Also es könnten. Also ich sitze zum Beispiel weder im Bundestag noch im Europäischen Parlament und erkläre mir das immer damit. Ich sehe im Fernsehen Franziska Brandner und denke mir dann, sie ist für mich da. Franziska Brandner ist eine Grüne, glaube ich. Sie ist parlamentarische Staatssekretärin im BMWK Habecks Laden und führt dort Geschäfte und war relativ lange, soweit ich weiß, im Europäischen Parlament. Und alles, was sie sagt, sie hat einen sehr aktiven Instagram-Account. Also sie gestaltet richtig Videos und ich finde, sie macht inhaltlich und in der Methode alles richtig. Ich fühle mich von ihr bestens vertreten, sie ist aber nicht in meinem Wahlkreis oder wie auch immer, sondern ich denke mir immer, wenn dann die Hörer kommen und fragen, warum bist du nicht im Parlament, du redest so viel über Politik. Ich habe da keine Lust drauf, ich habe auch keine Lust auf eine Depression, die ich dann bekäme, sondern das macht ja Franziska Brandner für mich. Und damit fahre ich eigentlich sehr gut in meinem Kopfe, mit so einer Vorstellung. Wir gehen mal hier durch, wie er unsere Forensik, wie er Empirie für unsere Forensik darlegt, denn es ist ja durchaus interessant, wie das Europäische Parlament funktioniert. Es ist höchst passiv. Man hat sehr kurze Redezeiten, ein bis zwei Minuten, das ist ein Witz, das wissen wir alle. Er beschreibt die Parlamentarier als kleine Bundespräsidenten, die Sonntagsreden halten und sonst nichts. Er sagt dann, ja, die rufen verschiedene Preise aus. Es gibt auch einen Filmpreis, wie auch immer. Kennst du den Filmpreis? Er heißt Lux Publikumspreis.
Ist aber nicht so bedeutend.
Also es ist nichts bedeutend dort. Und er sagt dann auch, ungeschickterweise ist das EU-Parlament im Vergleich zu den nationalen Regierungen machtlos. Deswegen macht es ja so viel Symbolpolitik. Das Problem, Symbolpolitik macht nur Sinn, wenn jemand zuguckt. Also es ist im Grunde, wenn da nicht gerade ein Gast aus der Ukraine eingeladen wird, der dann mal vor dem ganzen Plenum spricht, ist da relativ wenig los und es ist zusätzlich wenig los. Da kommt sein einziges Lob, Parlamentssitzungen sind wenig besucht, weil zeitgleich Ausschusssitzungen stattfinden. Da würde ich sagen, ja gut, so ist das halt. Dankenswerterweise hat er sich dafür fünf Jahre durchs Parlament gequält, um uns die aller Weltsweisheit, die nun wirklich jeder aufgeklärte Politiklehrer mal seinem Schülerpublikum dann kurz sagt, und da wird man nicht vermutet, dass die da alle nur faulenzen, ne, die arbeiten da gerade und die Arbeit, eine Rede zuzuhören, ist nicht unbedingt das Zentrale, womit man es zu tun hat. Dann kommt er auf die Ungleichbehandlung der Parlamentarier zu sprechen, das ist wahnsinnig interessant, denn man kann, obwohl die Fraktionen ja nicht eine Art Regierungen abbilden, aber man sieht ja doch, dass so die EVP dann mehr so auf der Regierungsseite und andere kleine linker Parteien dann doch irgendwo anders stehen, die Grünen, dass es dazu krassen Ungleichbehandlungen kommt bei der Zuteilung und auch Nachkontrolle von irgendwelchen Privilegien. Wer muss sich für was rechtfertigen?
Also es ist generell empfehlenswert, in der CDU zu sein.
Er beschreibt dann auch, wie Leute die Seiten wechseln und dann plötzlich feststellen, es ist ja alles wahnsinnig kompliziert, ich kriege immer Anrufe von da und hier und so, das war vorher alles selbstläufig, aber er hat einfach gesagt, ich will da hinfahren und da stand ein Auto bereit und jetzt plötzlich nicht mehr.
Also dieser Verwaltungsapparat ist nicht unpolitisch, um es so zu sagen.
Die Parlamentsverwaltung scheint so ein eigenes Thema zu sein und er hat dann auch einen schönen Satz, die Anonymität ist die größte Macht des Parlaments, sie kann ignorieren. Also egal was vorfällt, egal wer wen anschwärzen will, egal was, bei ihm wird irgendwie geklaut im Büro und so weiter. Man kümmert sich einfach nicht darum, während die anderen da rumgechattet werden. Er kommt aber dann auch in diesen Lebensstil, Champagner am Flughafen. Er hat irgendwie erst nach drei Jahren festgestellt, dass er Reisen doppelt abrechnen kann und so was. Bei ihm die Lernkurve war sehr flach und dann kommt er noch mal auf diesen Unsinn zu sprechen, dass ja auch in Straßburg die ganze Infrastruktur vorgehalten wird, weshalb einmal im Monat für ein paar Tage der ganze Apparat nach Straßburg umzieht. Und er dann den Witz machte, wir können auch den Plenarsaal in Brüssel einfach in Straßburg umbenennen, dann sind wir in Straßburg, obwohl wir noch in Brüssel sind und müssen uns die mehrere hundert Millionen Euro im Jahr teure Doppelinfrastruktur nicht leisten.
Aber natürlich hat Frankreich ein Interesse daran, dass das auch da stattfindet.
Deswegen hält ja auch der Zug in Montabaur, weil es da einfach Bundesländer gibt, die auch noch mal zwischen NRW und Hessen einen Stopp haben wollen. Also klar, solche Proporzachen schlagen sich dann da nieder.
Naja, du musst ja immer nur Bonn ansehen, die alte Bundeshauptstadt, wo immer noch Büros sind und dort hin und her fliegen.
Wir haben viel Glück mit der UN gehabt, dass die Räume alle genutzt werden konnten.
Ja, aber lass uns mal über diese Privilegien sprechen in der Form, dass die ja nicht nur Diäten bekommen, sondern alle möglichen weiteren Gelder.
Also es ist wirklich haarsträubend, das, was man hier liest. Zum Glück macht er auch das zum hauptsächlichen Thema in der Besprechung seines Buches außerhalb. Aber es ist unglaublich. Also man kriegt einen Diplomatenpass, Versicherung gegen Krankheit und Diebstahl, Rentenzusicherung ab 63 Jahre. Falls man jemals wieder abgewählt wird, hat man ein Übergangsgeld für jeden Monat im Parlament. Für jedes Jahr bekommt man ein Monat Übergangsgeld, Bankkart 100 1. Klasse, Bankkart 100 1. Klasse Belgien, Chauffeurdienste des Europäischen Parlaments und des Deutschen Bundestags. Alle Reisekosten werden zusätzlich zur Bankkart 100, dem Chauffeurdienst und der Flugbereitschaft, also man kriegt Flüge gebucht, zusätzlich noch mal erstattet. Auch wenn es private Reisen sind und er auf den Zettel schreibt, es war eine private Reise. Ich weiß nicht genau, ob sie es mir erstatten dürfen. Falls nicht, erklären sie es mir kurz. Keine Erklärung, einfach die Erstattung plus nochmal 100 Euro Trinkgeld obendrauf. Also das sind unfassbare Zustände zu dem...
56 Cent pro Kilometer.
Ja, und zusätzlich zu diesem ganzen Kram gibt es dann die Diäten, die bei 38 Prozent des höchsten Richtergehalts, also auch so bei 12.000 Euro liegen, plus nochmal 5.000 Euro, für die man sich nicht rechtfertigen muss, die man einfach für... Man hat ja so ein paar Sachen. Dann das Büro, also es ist unfassbar. Er beschreibt es zurecht, als mehr als zweimal dort reingewählt zu werden, mach den Kopf dicht, du verwechselst dich dann mit dem Amt, du hältst das für normal, du kannst dir nicht mehr vorstellen, wie normale Leute leben und ich kann mir auch das, was er beschreibt, mal tausend nur als einzige Erklärung fruchtbar machen, warum der Supreme-Core da entscheidet, dass wir jetzt einen König brauchen, weil die von dem einfach unberührt sind und sich das nicht mehr vorstellen können, wie es ist, ohne geschenkte Häuser, geschenkte Reisen, unendliche Spesen konnten und so weiter zu leben. Also die leben eh wie Könige und für die ist das ein ganz kleiner Schritt, dem Präsidenten zu sagen, wir können dich auch rausnehmen aus dem Feuer. So, also das scheint mir hier zu beginnen, dass man schon als einfache Abgeordnete im Europäischen Parlament jeden Kontakt zur Realität verliert und das System auch genauso angelegt ist. Er kriegt hier eine Wohnung angeboten, 5000 Euro im Monat. Der Typ, der ihm die übergibt, auch ein Parlamentarier, sagt, ganz einfach zu finanzieren, es reicht das Tagegeld. Also zusätzlich zu allen Gehältern, Personal, Büro, was auch immer, bekommt man Geld. Pro Tag Anwesenheit im Parlament 300 irgendwas Euro.
Und man muss nur unterschreiben, also man muss dann nicht da sitzen.
Ja genau, man geht nur hin, unterschreibt und diese Gelder alleine aufsummiert, wenn man an allen 200 Sitzungstagen da ist, reichen, um für 5000 Euro im Monat in Brüssel eine ganze Villa zu mieten. Das ist einfach grotesk. Also so ist kein Staat zu machen. Da ist kein Wunder, dass, und man liest das dann immer und denkt, ja das machen die AfD-Typen gerade. Die sind alle gerade da reingerutscht in dieses System.
Naja, der Graf wird den ganzen Tag lachen.
Ja, und das Mandat ist frei, unabhängig. Er sagt dann, man könnte jemanden erschießen, ins Gefängnis verurteilt werden und man hätte trotzdem all diese Privilegien. Man säß halt nur im Gefängnis. Aber das Mandat bleibt bei einem und dann fragt er den Leser, ich habe mir das nicht ausgedacht. Der eine Griecher hat ja jemanden erschossen, sitzt im Gefängnis, nimmt sogar eine Abstimmung teil, während des Corona, wie sich Remote stattfand.
Da haben wir eigentlich schon so eine Königskaste.
Er sagt dann auch kurz, das Mandat ist frei und das soll auch so sein. Die Demokratie darf dann unbeschädigt. Dafür gibt es ja eine Amtszeitbegrenzung. Aber es ist wirklich haarsträubend, das zu lesen.
Aber jetzt würde ich mal ein bisschen ketzerisch fragen. Ja, das sind großartige Privilegien und man sollte da auf jeden Fall mal ran. So viel muss das nicht sein. Aber findest du das wirklich angemessen, dass man so ein halbes Buch damit vollschreibt? Also die Informationen, die du jetzt gebracht hast, die waren es ja jetzt auch. Jetzt kann man auch über Pensionsansprüche sprechen, kann sagen, ja, wenn man dort eine Legislaturperiode war, dann hat man mehr als der Durchschnittsrenner.
150 Prozent der deutschen Rente kriegt man dann.
Ja, okay. Kann ich jetzt alles so sagen? Ich kann dann sagen, dann müssen wir das halbieren oder was auch immer. Aber ist das das größte Problem? Also ist das, wenn wir jetzt über Europa nachdenken, ist das jetzt unser Problem? Sorgt das dafür, dass wir da eine abgehobene Klasse haben? Ja. Sorgt das dafür, dass wir eine sehr elitäre Klasse haben? Ja. Ist das nur damit zu begründen, dass die solche Privilegien haben? Nein. Ich würde mich jetzt nicht stark machen wollen für diese bekloppten Entlohnungen da. Ich würde nur deutlich machen, dass man jetzt nicht die ganze Zeit nur darauf schließen kann, sondern wir haben es ja einfach auch mit anderen sehr privilegierten Jobs oder so zu tun, wo die Leute sich genauso korruptschweinisch und sonst was verhalten. Also ich, oder um es mal anders zu sagen, ja, da sind sehr viele in diesem Parlament, die sicherlich ihre Arbeit nicht so nachgehen, wie das eigentlich sein sollte und die dann entsprechende Gelder abgreifen. Und das ist auch schlimm. Und da von außen darauf einzuwirken, wird besonders schwer, weil die sich ja selbst diese Privilegien schaffen, wie auch die Leute im Bundestag einfach ihre Diäten erhöhen können, wenn sie meinen, jetzt ist aber mal wieder Zeit dafür. Und da kann ich jetzt sehr viel darüber klagen. Andererseits kann ich jetzt auch sagen, ja, ist das so? Es sind ja am Ende auch noch Beträge, bei denen ich sage, ja gut, dann bekommen die da nochmal 5000 Euro oder so. Also kommen wir nicht in ein sehr kleinliches Denken, insofern als wir hier über Europa als Ganzes reden und über eine EU-Politik, die ganz, ganz entscheidend ist für unseren Alltag. Und soll ich mich jetzt lange damit beschäftigen, dass die sich immer mal wieder noch mehr Privilegien zuschustern? Das ist mir irgendwie ein bisschen zu viel Zeitverschwendung, dass ich mich jetzt damit beschäftige.
Also einfache Antwort meinerseits, dieses Thema-tisieren dieser Privilegien, so wird ja direkt gespiegelt im Buch, mit seinem Ansinn, eine Transparenzplattform im Internet zu schaffen, die eben ja von der Parlamentsverwaltung in Grund und Boden geschossen wird. Also einfach verunmöglicht. Er meint, das Mandat ist frei. Ich kann hier alles machen, was ich will, außer über das Parlament aufklären. Weil dann kommt das Parlament und dann wird plötzlich so diktiert, wie sich der Abgeordnete zu verhalten hat. Das ist das eine Problem, denn wir haben es nicht nur mit diesem Privilegien-Apparat zu tun, sondern auch mit einer institutionalisierten Verschleierung. Dadurch, dass es keine internen Rechtfertigungspflichten gibt für diese Gelder. Er beschreibt das ja an einem Punkt. Die Nebenkosten zur Diät belaufen sich auf 40 Millionen Euro im Jahr, für die man sich nicht rechtfertigen muss, aber eigentlich müsste, weil sie ja zweckgebunden sind. Und dann fragt er sich, wie viel davon werden eigentlich zurückgezahlt am Ende?
Ja, das ist Wahnsinn.
Weil Politiker sagen, habe ich ja gar nicht gebraucht, ich hatte schon genug Bleistifte. Und zurückgezahlt werden 1,25 Prozent. Was bedeutet, diese Privilegien finanzieller Art gehen einher mit einer Denke, die so im Jenseitigen liegt. Also nicht mehr im Diesseitigen, demokratisch, durchschaubar. Der Wähler wird darüber aufgeklärt, um was es hier geht, wie es funktioniert, dass man vielleicht auch selber mitmachen könnte, wie auch immer. Also hier ist sozusagen eine Informationsbrandmauer nach außen, die das Parlament selber für diejenigen, die, sagen wir mal, ab der dritten Legislaturperiode dabei sind, so einer sektenartigen Charakter plötzlich entwickelt.
Das heißt, was ich jetzt eben als Kollateralschaden eigentlich gefasst habe, indem ich sage, naja, die haben wichtige Dinge zu klären, sollen wir uns jetzt um die 5000 Euro, die da im Monat, die da nochmal sich einsackt, kümmern, würdest du sagen, nein, das ist das Symptom für eigentlich eine generelle Dysfunktionalität, eine generelle korrupte Haltung gegenüber denen Institutionen, die man eigentlich mit Transparenz reinhalten sollte. Das heißt aber, und diese Zahl ist ja nochmal so interessant, 1,4% wird da zurückgezahlt, der Rest wird sich eingesagt, dann sind alle ja Teil des Problems.
Genau.
Also es ist nicht eine Sache jetzt, ja und die AfD macht da so schlimme Dinge, sondern die Kaste, die dort entstanden ist, ist Teil des Problems.
Hier haben wir es jetzt in der abgeschwächten Form mit der gleichen Diskussion wie in Amerika zu tun. Diese Parallele ist eigentlich wirklich interessant. In diesem Podcast, We the People, von diesem Constitution-Institut behandeln die das so. Der Journalismus interessiert sich nur für Personen, so wie wir uns hier einfach. Er führt sie uns ja namentlich vor. Dieser Wieland von der CDU, auf der einseitlich verantwortlich für den Haushalt, ist von Präsidiumseite der CDU Abgeordneter Rainer Wieland. Er hat für seine Bürovermietung, äh, Bürorenovierung weit mehr als 600.000 Euro ausgegeben. Bewilligt vom Parlament, weil er braucht ja ein Büro. So, ja, das sind solche Sachen, die, wenn die irgendwo stehen, wissen wir darüber Bescheid und dann könnten wir sagen, der Herr Wieland hat sich aber ganz falsch verhalten. Das ist viel zu viel Geld und so weiter und so fort. Das ist eine Einflugsschneise in das Problem und das Thema über die Person. Und jetzt weisen aber diese Juraprofessoren in Amerika darauf hin, bei diesem Urteil geht es nicht um Trump, seine Vergehen, seine Immunität, sondern es geht um eine Entscheidung for the ages, wie handhaben wir das Verfassungsgefüge Amerikas. Es ist ein struktureller Umbau Amerikas. So, was hier bedeutet, wenn ich sowas lese, kann es für mich ad hoc, ich könnte natürlich dann mit Claude im Gespräch noch klügere und weitreichendere Prinzipien, aber ad hoc kommt mir erst mal in den Sinn, ok, Mandatzeitbegrenzung maximal zwei Zeiten, zwei Legislaturperiode im Europäischen Parlament. Jeder, der hier reingeht, muss vorher wissen, um welche Privilegien es geht. Von mir aus pauschal jeden Monat 20.000 Euro. Man muss es niemandem rechtfertigen, nirgendwo abrechnen. Diese ganze Bürokratie ist ja auch eine Phase, also das kann man ja einfach alles streichen. Jeder bekommt einfach 20.000 Euro überwiesen, darf drei Leute anstellen, die wissen genau, ich bin jetzt hier angestellt, die Verwaltung überweist mir meine 5.800 Euro brutto oder was auch immer, was dann so dieser Posten dafür ist. Und man weiß aber auch, ich habe jetzt zwei Legislaturperioden Zeit. Ich kann die einfach, ich muss mich einmal wieder wählen lassen, wie so ein amerikanischer Präsident, nur dort schaffen wir es gerade ab. Ich lese das hier und denke mir, das sollten wir eigentlich mal einführen.
Damit nicht so Leute wie Elmar Brok oder Reinhard Bütikow da 100 Jahre sind.
In Europa leben hunderte Millionen Menschen. Es muss immer wieder neu ausgewürfelt werden, wer hier diese Art von Repräsentanz, dafür sind es ja 700. Wir können da durchaus mal 85 Idioten reinwählen, weil das trocknet sich dann schon weg. Also das ist dann auch egal. So dafür sind es ja 700 und nicht einfach nur drei. Und dann haben wir irgendwie so, keine Ahnung, wie in Amerika ja neun Leute sitzen in diesem Gericht und sechs davon sagen einfach, was jetzt das Phase ist. Das ist natürlich blöd. Bei 700 würde ich sagen, das Gesetz der großen Zahlen wirkt. Also eine große Lehre für mich hier raus ist, es braucht einen strukturellen Umbau.
Und das wäre Amtszeitbegrenzung?
Zum Beispiel eine radikale auf zwei Legislatur, also maximal zehn Jahre Amtszeitbegrenzung. Also Amt im Sinne von Mandatszeitbegrenzung im Parlament. Und diese Forderung möchte ich dann auch in solchen Büchern, also ich will kein persönliches Leiden an den Egos der Arme, sondern ich will hier eine strukturelle Aussage, welche Konsequenzen ziehen wir aus solchen Beobachtungen. Und ich denke mir auch irgendwie, Parlamentarier, also Politik ist ein Beruf, aber nicht auf Lebenszeit. Man macht das aus Berufung, man fühlt sich berufen. Wir gehen mal davon aus, wenn 350, 400, 500 Millionen Menschen zu einer Wahl gehen und vorher Prinzipien haben, der Personalauswahl, werden schon Leute da hochgespielt, die der Ruf ereilt, die berufen sind, wie auch immer. Aber es gibt so viele, die man auch berufen könnte und die auch der Ruf ereilen könnte, dass man einfach ganz fair sagen kann, zehn Jahre und dann ist der nächste dran. So und diese Art von Begrenzung würde schon mal ganz viele Probleme hier rausnehmen. Denn das hier ist darauf ausgelegt, Menschen ab ihrer dritten Amtszeit komplett unter Kontrolle zu haben. Allein durch Privilegien, Vernebelung ihres Denkens.
Ja, das finde ich einen guten Vorschlag. Denn die Vorschläge, die gemacht werden, die sind doch eher dürftig oder ich würde fast sagen lieber nicht. Ja, also wenn er sagt mehr Transparenz, ok. Aber wenn er sagt, ich bin aber der Meinung, dass die EU Veränderung braucht, dass Gesetze geändert werden müssen und die EU-Bürgerinnen mehr Einfluss nehmen können. Letztlich sind sie es, die die EU ausmachen. Es ist ihr Steuergeld, von dem die Institutionen und eben auch die Abgeordneten des Europäischen Parlaments und unsere Mitarbeiterinnen finanziert werden. Ja, was meint er dann mit mehr Mitbestimmung? Also wir wissen ja, wie viele Menschen in Europa bereit sind, Recht zu wählen. Sollen die jetzt mehr mitbestimmen, dass dann irgendwelche Green Deal-Verordnungen doch nicht durchkommen, dass die das noch mal als Veto machen können? Also einfach nur mal zu sagen, wir brauchen mal mehr Mitbestimmung, so als gäbe es die guten, klar denkenden Menschen auf der einen Seite und die Politikerkaste auf der anderen Seite. Das ist ja offenbar nicht richtig. Sonst würden ja nicht so viele rechte Parteien gewählt werden. Also ich frage mich wirklich, ob diese Idee, die hier immer von Demokratie hochgehalten wird, ob die nicht grundsätzlich schon zum Scheitern verurteilt ist, weil sie irgendwelche bürgerlichen Subjekte voraussetzt, die es gar nicht gibt.
Ja, das ist ja wie vorhin schon Aufklärung über, was ist Politik eigentlich und wer das schafft. Man kennt auch seine Nachbarn und die Pappenheimer.
Ja.
Er hat trotzdem am Ende, finde ich, außer du willst noch zu seinen Lösungen, er hat ja am Ende noch mal so allgemeine Anmerkungen, die jetzt mit dem Thema des Buches gar nichts zu tun haben. Aber na gut, er macht zumindest einen kleinen Brückenschlag.
Ja, eine Sache will ich vielleicht machen. Er redet die ganze Zeit darüber, dass die Politiker so korrupt sind, beziehungsweise dass sie immer da zugreifen, wo noch was zu holen ist. Er sagt aber auch, aufgrund seiner Depression war er dann recht bald nicht mehr fähig, also eigentlich mit Beginn der Lockdowns, sein Amt richtig auszuüben, seine Mitarbeiter versuchen dann ein bisschen das Aufrecht zu erhalten. Und er sagt also, er hätte natürlich auch die Möglichkeit gehabt, zurückzutreten und jemand anders wäre dann an seiner Stelle gekommen. Und dann gesteht er aber selbst zu, dass er dies auch zuletzt deshalb nicht getan hat, weil er weiterhin dieses hohe Gehalt bekommen will und ja dann auch diesen Pensionsanspruch hat. Dann muss ich sagen, ich kann das verstehen, aber dann haben wir doch keinen fundamentalen Unterschied zu den Politikern, die er kritisiert, sondern nur in Graduellen. Die sind halt dann noch ein bisschen dreister und sagen, ich brauche jetzt die S-Klasse, nur in der kann ich mich chauffieren lassen. Aber grundsätzlich nutzt man doch auch dann schon diese Privilegien. Also ich kann dann, ich komme da nicht weiter. Also da muss man sagen, ich bin jetzt der Idealist und sterbe in Schönheit oder was auch immer. Aber man kann ja nicht sagen, naja, so ein bisschen Privilegien habe ich mir dann schon noch gesichert, obwohl ich schon weiß, dass es nicht so richtig ist. Aber naja, so ist es halt. Und zugleich schreibe ich ja mal ein ganzes Buch voll damit, wie privilegiert die Leute sind. Und das war eben mein Punkt. Also ich bin sehr dafür, dass man einschränkt, dass Amtszeiten nicht ewig gehen. Ich bin sehr dafür, dass die nicht absurde Gelder bekommen für irgendwelche Werbeartikel und all das. Nur ich würde immer sagen, wenn wir jetzt auf die EU als Ganzes blicken, was wir von ihr erwarten könnten, erwarten sollten und welche Verantwortung sie hat, dann sind dies für mich nicht die Hauptthemen, ob die 56 Cent pro Kilometer bekommen. Also da muss ich einfach sagen, das ist für mich ein Politikverständnis, dass so nicht da sind. Wir haben auch ganz viele Länder, in denen Politiker woanders her ihr Geld nehmen. Also Rishi Sunak musste nicht mal Geld verdienen und ist deshalb Premierminister geworden. Also wir müssen schon auch irgendwie bei dem Politischen bleiben. Und ja, da gibt es ganz schlimme Privilegien, das ist ja genauso beim Öffentlich-Rechtlichen. Ich kann natürlich jetzt nur über so Fälle wie Patricia Streisinger reden oder kann mich fragen, warum eigentlich Böbermann so viel Geld bekommt. Das ist auch zu recht kritisiert, wenn nur mir ginge, ist, wenn ich mich mit dem Öffentlich-Rechtlichen auseinandersetze, eher um strukturelle Veränderungen, die her müssen. Und die liegen jetzt nicht darin, wer soll 50.000 weniger bekommen, sondern warum gibt es eigentlich keine einzige, vernünftige Klassik-Sendung im Fernsehen?
Wenn man keine Ahnung von den strukturellen Phänomenen hat, kann man weder die Probleme richtig beschreiben, noch erst recht keine Lösung anbieten. Und darunter leitet dieses Buch. Da kann man halt noch so ein paar Anmerkungen machen. Apropos Rishi Sunak. Ich wusste nicht, dass se Préton auch Milliardär ist. Ich habe versucht, das nachzugugeln, ist schwierig zu finden. Aber anscheinend haben wir es hier auf allen Ebenen etwas komische Leute.
Wir brauchen ja gar nicht zu Sunak, Préton ist ja hier eventuell.
Er nennt die Milliardäre, weil er sagt, wir Parlamentarier, wir Menschen, wir Politiker können ja eh nichts machen, nur Superreiche können. Also sollten wir Superreichtum begrenzen. Er schlägt vor 100 Millionen Euro. Das ist die Höchstgrenze an Privatvermögen. Danach kann man einfach sagen, du kriegst eine Luxushartz-400-Medalje. Wir sagen, du hast den Kapitalismus erfolgreich durchgespielt. Diese Idee hat er auch schon im Podcast gemacht mit Apokalypse und Filtercafé und so. Dann sind wir eingeladen. Da hat er das schon mal vorgestellt, also ist einer größeren Publikumsklasse bekannt. Ansonsten hat mich das Lesen noch mal an Rutger Brechmann erinnert. Er hat diese Frage, warum sind Politiker so komisch?
Wenn diese Passage noch lesen, weil die wirklich ganz amüsant ist, ich verachte und bewundere diese Wesen um mich herum gleichzeitig. Politikerinnen, das sind Leute, die Fotos machen von sich an Parteiständen, um die genau Null Passantinnen verteilt sind, die das dann auch noch im Internet posten, um damit anzugeben und dass sie einen Stand aufgebaut haben. Und die dann sagen, hä, wieso, ist doch alles gut, ich reiße doch richtig was. Die in ihrem Narzissmus und Bedeutsamsein wollen so viel rausziehen, dass sie den Rest gar nicht sehen müssen. Ich will das auch haben. Die merken vor lauter Ignoranz nicht einmal, wie egal sie sind, wie vergeblich ihre Situation, weil ihr Narzissmus, ihre Eitelkeit, ihre persönliche Not so groß ist, dass sie sich selbst betrügen. Leute, euer Video wurde von 20 Leuten gesehen, nicht geliked, gesehen. Wie könnt ihr da einfach weitermachen und sagen, ich bewege mich hier richtig, ich verändere die Welt? Und das hat mich erinnert, als ich mal mit einem Leiter einer psychiatrischen Klinik sprach und wie er auf Politiker zu sprechen kam. Und er hat mir natürlich nicht verraten, wer schon alles da war. Aber er sagt, es waren schon viele Politiker dort. Er sagte, was sie alle über die Parteigrenzen hinweg und ihre persönlichen individuellen Leiden einte, war eine extrem hohe Frustrationsschwelle. Andere Leute würden sich nach solchen Tagen ins Bett legen und sagen, nee, damit will ich nichts mehr zu tun haben. Und so ist es eigentlich. Nico Semsrott hat gesagt, ich stehe nicht mehr auf. Und er sagt, nein, der Politiker-Typus kann ausgeschimpft werden, den ganzen Tag lang und steht morgen wieder strahlend vor der Kamera und holt sich die nächsten Watschen ab.
Und es ist ja auch beeindruckend, dass dann manche in diesem Aussiebeprozess plötzlich Innenminister werden. Und dann plötzlich entfalten sie ihre Wirkmächtigkeit. Und das ist einfach, da kommt dann dieser ganze frusttolerante Egoismus, kann dann plötzlich da ausgelebt werden. Und darüber kommt dann die ganze Gefahr. Eine sehr interessante Diskussion fand ich an Amerika. Die Young Turks waren eingeladen in diesen allgemeinen Besprechungen der Debatte. Und dann sagte der Dings, ich weiß jetzt seinen Namen leider nicht, aber für die, die die Young Turks kennen, wissen, wen ich meine, war dann so einer fünfköpfigen Kommentator runter und meinte, ja, was wir hier sehen ist, wir sagen immer Donald Trump, der Egoist und so weiter, der sich da einfach durchboxt. Wenn Joe Biden so glaubt, Präsident zu werden, hat er ein größeres Ego als Donald Trump, dann ist ihm seine eigene Person noch wichtiger als alles andere, vor allem als das Land. Dann bleibt alles links liegen. Er war schon Präsident. Er steht schon in den Geschichtsbüchern. Aber er versucht noch mal, diesen kleinen Schritt zu gehen, ohne körperliche Kraft, ohne alles. Einfach nur, weil ein Ego und diese Frustrationstoleranz ist mir doch egal, einfach, und das ist schon sehr bezeichnend und bedeutsam, das dann mal so zu sehen und so kommentiert zu kriegen, dass man denkt, ja, das stimmt. Er kommt immer so vernünftig daher und man denkt dann irgendwie, ja, das ist noch mal und so die gute Seite. Aber es ist wie bei dieser Ginsburg der Richterin, wo Obama zu ihr geht und sagt, nach mir wird es keinen demokratischen Präsidenten geben. Du wirst ersetzt werden durch einen von den Republikanen ausgewählten Richter. Und dann kommt es genauso, weil sie einfach nicht von diesem Supreme Court-Amt, sie ist es schon 30 Jahre, aber das eine Jahr, was sie glaubt, das Leben steckt noch in ihrem Wille, sie noch selber durchkämpfen. Und es sind einfach...
Ja, das ist richtiger Egoismus. Da muss man ja auch noch mal herausheben, was das für ein Schritt war, dass Papst Benedikt zurückgetreten ist.
Absolut. Eine der größten Taten überhaupt.
Wahnsinn.
Aus dieser...
Und das als Papst, wo das nun jetzt eigentlich nicht vorgesehen ist.
Genau. Also da, wo man sich dann wirklich erklären muss.
Bei Präsidenten ja, aber beim Papst eigentlich nicht.
Also er macht es ja ganz deutlich am Ende. Ich merke ja, wie sich Dinge verschieben. Irgendwann dächte ich nur noch an mich selbst. Hauptcharakterzug, Egoismus, es wäre genauso.
Brüssel sehen und sterben von Nico Semsrott ist kein gutes Buch. Es ist aber symptomatisch vielleicht für ein Politikverständnis, das nur Idealismus oder Fatalismus kennt. Ja, wir bekommen ganz gut gezeigt, wie verrückt manchmal die Bürokratie in Brüssel ist und wie privilegiert die Politiker sind. Echte Antworten aber darauf, was strukturell zu ändern wäre, die gibt uns das Buch nicht.
Nein, es gibt uns als aufgeklärte Leser, die schon das eine oder andere Politikbuch gelesen haben, die Möglichkeit, eine gute Forensik des bestehenden politischen Systems zu machen. Aber alle weiteren und die wichtigen Schritte muss man als Leser selber machen. Und das ist sehr schade.
Noch lieber als in die Oper gehe ich ins Streichquartett. Haben wir noch nie zusammen besucht, werden wir aber auch mal machen, denn es gibt einige Konzerte in der Alten Oper.
Ich war letztens bei einem, die Streichkonzerts waren große Sinfonien, aber Philharmonie, wie nennt man es, ist große Orchester. Ist große Sinfonieorchester. Mit Musik von Hans Zimmer und John Williams. Und während man bei John Williams denkt, okay, dafür sind diese Orchester da, denkt man bei Hans Zimmer, so kann ein Orchester auch spielen.
Wir nähern uns jetzt mal diesem Streichquartett. Und ich glaube, die meisten Leute, die uns jetzt gerade zuhören, das unterstelle ich jetzt mal, haben noch nie ein Streichquartettkonzert gehört oder hören auch nicht regelmäßig bei Spotify oder auf CD Streichquartette. Ich würde es aber wirklich allen ans Herz legen. Einfach mal irgendwas sich reinziehen. Haydn, Beethoven, Schubert, was auch immer. Einfach mal irgendeinen bekannten Namen, den man so kennt. Mozart hat auch Streichquartette geschrieben. Also Mozart, Streichquartett. Und da gibt es dann immer ganz viele zu auswählen. Aber einfach mal in irgendetwas reinhören. Und dann sieht man schon, das ist eine ganz besondere Form der Musik. Das ist sehr intim. Es unterhalten sich da eigentlich vier Menschen miteinander. Das ist das vernünftige Gespräch. So hat Goethe das geschildert. Und ich will auch nochmal dazu aufrufen, wir sind jetzt im Sommer. Es gibt ganz viele Klassikfestivals. Streichquartettkonzerte sind in der Regel sehr günstig. Da ist man oft mit 15, 20 Euro schon dabei. Deswegen ruhig mal, auch wenn man überhaupt gar keine Ahnung davon hat, dahingehen. Es ist großartig, das zu erleben, weil man so nah dran ist, weil man dort Musiker erlebt, die diese Instrumente zusammen zum Klingen bringen. Und darum geht es ja. Sonja Siemenauer ist Konzertagentin, das seit vielen Jahrzehnten. Sie hat ein Buch geschrieben, das hat den Titel Muss es sein? Leben im Quartett. Dieses Buch ist schon vor etwa zehn Jahren erschienen. Und sie hat dann während der Corona-Lockdowns eine Neuauflage vorbereitet, hat es nochmal ein bisschen bearbeitet. Und dann ist der Bärenberg-Verlag auf die Idee gekommen, das eben nochmal jetzt neu herauszubringen. Denn es ist eigentlich ein sehr zeitloses Buch. Und es ist auch sehr schön schon angelegt, weil sie erst mal so anfängt. Bremen im April. Ich bin mit meiner Mitarbeiterin aus Hamburg zum Konzert gekommen. Vor dem Konzertsaal treffen wir auf den Pratschisten des Quartetts. Er geht den Bürgersteig auf und ab, hart und schnell raucht eine Zigarette nach der anderen. Wir begrüßen uns herzlich. Dann schießt es aus ihm heraus. Dies sei leider das letzte Mal, dass wir uns sehen. Nach diesem Konzert verließ er das Quartett, der Rest der Tournee sei hiermit abgesagt. Dann eine andere Begegnung. Nach dem Festivalkonzert erscheint eine Kritik mit, kurz zusammengefasst, folgendem Inhalt. Die vier Herren hätten, trotz düsterer Mene, wunderbar gespielt. Nur schade, dass man das Vergnügen nicht mehr haben werde, da bekannt geworden sei, dass das Quartett, also es ist jetzt ein anderes Quartett, sich nach dieser Tournee auflösen werde. Sie wundert sich, ließ diese Kritik, also da ist irgendwas nach außen gedrungen, de facto ist es so, ja, es gibt in diesen Streichquartetten immer wieder Streitigkeiten. Man kann sich das vorstellen, das sind vier Leute, die leben eigentlich zusammen. Die reisen laufen, die müssen proben, die müssen sich verständigen, die müssen sich ganz, ganz klar verstehen. Und natürlich ist das schwierig. Und dann gibt es immer wieder auch solche Drohungen. Und sie beschreibt dann, ja, dann gibt es laute Auseinandersetzungen und große Ankündigungen, ich werde das Quartett verlassen. Wenn tatsächlich ein Quartett zu Bruch geht, dann passiert das nie so, sondern es passiert immer ganz still. Irgendwann entschließt sich jemand, ich mache so nicht weiter. Aber wie lebt man eigentlich, wenn man in einem solchen Quartett arbeitet? Wie probt man? Worauf kommt es eigentlich an? Und vielleicht ist es da sinnvoll, mal jemandem zu Wort kommt, so dass er sich da gut auskennt. Und das macht sie immer wieder in dem Buch. Sie spricht also mit ihren Musikern darüber, was ist dann eigentlich so das Besondere am Quartett? Und da ist dann zum Beispiel Walter Lewin vom Lasalle-Quartett. Und der, sag mal, worauf es eigentlich ankommt, also auf welche Feinheiten, wenn man spielt. Im dritten Streichquartett von Bartok gibt es eine Stelle, bei der die beiden Geigen plötzlich oben spielen müssen, auf der G-Seite. Was machen die Quartette? Praktisch jedes Mal, wenn es zu dieser Stelle kommt, schummeln sie. Sie spielen es gar nicht auf der G-Seite, sondern es ist ganz leicht zu spielen, wenn man es auf der D-Seite in der dritten Lage spielt. Und für den normalen Hörer, sagen sie, ist das doch gar nicht zu hören. Es sei doch wichtiger, es in Tune zu spielen, als dieser kleine Unterschied in der Klangfarbe. Ja, warum hat es denn Bartok dahingesetzt? Eben des Risikos wegen. Das gewisse Spannungsmoment, wenn man von einer hohen Schanze runterspringt, ist nun einmal etwas anderes, als wenn man einfach nur einen halben Meter springt, aber es so darstellt, als wenn es von weit oben ist. Das sieht ganz anders aus. Es geht nicht nur darum, dass etwas perfekt gespielt wird, sondern eben auch um die anderen Elemente, die hier hereinkommen, die vielleicht für den Uneingeweihten nicht zu hören sind. Für mich schon. Wenn ich einem Quartett, das dieses Stellespiel zuhöre, kann ich blind sagen, ob sie versucht haben, das auf der G-Seite zu spielen oder ob sie es sich einfach machen. Das Verändern des Textes ist auch eine beliebte Sache. Es ist leichter, einen Akkord anders zu setzen, als er von dem Komponisten geschrieben ist, indem man die Töne anders verteilt. Verändert man aber seinen Klang. Was es heißt, hier auf der G-Seite zu spielen? Zunächst das zu spielen, was der Komponist, in diesem Fall Bartok, vorschreibt. So will er es haben. Schwer ist es allemal. Es geht um mehr als nur um die Tonhöhe, nämlich eine Klangfarbe. Oft auch mit einer Form von Verzerrung, die dazugehören kann. Diese sprechenden Qualitäten bedeuten, dass es auch hässliche sogenannte Klänge geben muss, die man hässlich spielen muss. Und dass man nicht alles einem vermeintlichen Schönklang opfert. Wir sehen also hier, auf welche Details es ankommt. Welche Feinheiten wichtig sind. Und worüber man sich dann im Quartett miteinander verständigen muss. Sie beschreibt sehr gut, dass eigentlich dieses Quartett so eine Ehe ist. Also ich würde dir das Buch empfehlen, weil du ein Familienbuch schreibst. Im Prinzip ist das so eine Gemeinschaft, die sich da bildet, die eine Bedarfsgemeinschaft ist. Manchmal eine Zweckgemeinschaft ist, manchmal eine volle Leidenschaft und Liebe ist. Aber sie beschreibt auch, wie sie mit einem Mitglied eines Quartetts lange Zeit zusammen war. Und sie hatte ihr Büro neben dem Proberaum dieses Quartetts. Und wie sie immer wieder laute Streits hörte, weil man sich einfach über Kommunikation auch klar werden muss, wie legt man eigentlich etwas an? Wie spielt man es dann? Also es ist ein Buch, das einem wirklich sehr guten Einblick gibt in Konzertreisen darauf, was wichtig ist. Und das Tolle ist, man muss sich jetzt gar nicht mit Musik auskennen. Man muss nicht da sitzen können und wissen, ob das auf der G- oder D-Seite gespielt ist. Aber man bekommt einen Eindruck dafür, mit welcher Ernsthaftigkeit man daran geht. Ich will noch einen Abschnitt vorlesen über das große Thema kulturelle Aneignung. Denn es war auch schon früher Thema im Klassikbetrieb. Wenn ungarische Musiker, ungarische Komponisten oder französische Interpreten französische Komponisten spielen, wird gern behauptet, dass ihre Aufführungen authentisch seien. Das authentische Marken einerseits stimmen, ist aber nur eine Aufführungsmöglichkeit. Die Interpretation eines Werks durch Landes- und sprachfremde Musiker kann genauso packend und berührend werden, in ein anderes Licht getaucht, mit anderen Kriterien empfunden. Und dann hat sie hier eine Anekdote. Als das La Sal-Quartett 1954 Ravels Streichquartett F-Dur auf das Programm ihres Pariser Konzertes setzen wollte, wurde es ihnen erst nach einem bitteren Kampf gestattet. Der Veranstalter argwöhnte, ein amerikanisches Quartett könnte unmöglich in Paris ein französisches Werk aufführen. Das Publikum reagierte dagegen begeistert und am nächsten Tag erschien eine vor Lob überschäumende Kritik. Besser hätte man das Werk nie gehört, was aber nicht verwunderlich sei, da nur Franzosen den Geist davon verstehen könnten. Der Kritiker hatte vom Namen Lasalle messerscharf auf die Herkunft des Quartetts geschlossen. Also wir sehen hier auch kulturelle Aneignungen so natürlich. Es gilt, wer es spielen kann, wer es am besten spielen kann. Und wie eng diese Beziehung ist, will ich noch in einer letzten Passage deutlich machen. Nämlich, manchmal ist ja auch so ein Quartett löst sich deshalb auf, weil jemand stirbt. Manchmal ist es wirklich der Tod, schreibt sie hier, der das Ende eines Quartett-Lebens herbeiführt. Viele Quartett-Liebhaber werden sich an die eigene Betroffenheit erinnern, als die Nachricht vom plötzlichen Tod von Peter Schietloff, dem Archisten des Amadeus-Quartetts, sich wie ein Lauffeuer in der Welt der Kammermusik verbreitete. 40 Jahre lang waren Norbert Breinin, Sigmund Niesel, Peter Schietloff und Martin Lovett das Amadeus-Quartett gewesen. Zwar hatten die Herren ein Alter erreicht, in dem die meisten in Pensionen gehen, aber sie dachten nicht daran aufzuhören, zumindest drang nichts davon nach außen. Es waren Konzerte geplant, auch allerlei Festivitäten zu ihrer 40. Jubiläumssaison. Als wenig später Norbert Breinin gefragt wurde, ob sie denn weitermachen würden, antwortete er, es gäbe keine Literatur für zwei Geigen und Cello. Und als einige Wochen später in Paris ein unvergessliches Gedenkkonzert organisiert wurde, bei dem drei Mitglieder des Alban-Berg-Quartetts und die drei verbliebenen Mitglieder des Amadeus-Quartetts gemeinsam das zweite Brahms-Sextett und das Scherzo des ersten Sextetts für ihren verstorbenen Kollegen spielten, durfte es nur unter dem Titel Mitglieder des Amadeus-Ensembles und Mitglieder des Alban-Berg-Quartetts angekündigt werden. Das Amadeus-Quartett war mit Peter Schietloff gestorben.
Zum Glück bin ich nicht ganz so nah dran. Mir ist sehr wichtig, wer in der Oper singt, aber nicht so bei der Musik, wer spielt. Also da ist die Auswahl der Literatur immer noch wichtiger als dann die spezifische Interpretation, was ich glaube sehr entspannend ist.
Nein, ich würde eher sagen, also in vielen Dingen, ich weiß ja auch nicht, wer jetzt da genau im Orchestergraben in der Oper Frankfurt sitzt, aber bei einem Quartett ist es schon interessanter zu vergleichen, denn das Repertoire ist oft wiederkehrend. Also es gibt zwar viele, aber es ist oft wiederkehrend. Und das ist so wunderbar zu hören, wenn man große, gute Quartette erlebt. Eine Woche hört man die Interpretation von jedem Quartett, eine andere Woche vom anderen. Also das ist schon, ob ich jetzt Beethoven gespielt bekomme vom Hagenquartett, vom Jerusalem-Quartett oder, die ich ja jetzt sehr liebe, vom Leon Corot-Quartett, dem Jungen-Quartett, dann sind da natürlich fundamental andere Herangehensweisen, obwohl die ja dieselben Noten spielen.
Absolut.
Und das ist wirklich toll und ich kann nur sagen, jeder sollte sich für das Streichquartett begeistern lassen. Das ist großartig.
Meine banausrige Einflugsschneise ist ja, dass ich dir berichten kann, ich war zuletzt vor zweieinhalb Jahren oder so in einem Candlelight-Konzert. Das wird mehr so auf dieser Popkultur-Ebene im Kurhaus in Wiesbaden und da wurde eben zu viert Hans Zimmermusik gespielt, was für mich bedeutet, ich kenne ja die Musik und ich weiß, die ist nicht für Streicher und vor allem in diesem kleinen Rahmen gemacht. Also erkenne ich sie wieder, freue mich darüber und die Details der Wiedergabe sind mir dann in dem Moment gar nicht so wichtig. Okay, aber ich weiß natürlich, wie du das meinst. So, Drosten hat ein Buch mitformuliert, zusammen mit Georg Mascolo, alles überstanden, Fragezeichen. Eine offene Frage, von der wir wissen, wenn sie so gestellt ist, dann nicht. Und sie rekapitulieren inklusive, dass am Ende noch mal eine Chronologie der Pandemie durchgegangen wird. Man fragt sich jetzt auch so, gab es einen zweiten Lockdown? Wie war das noch mal mit den Schulen? Wann durfte man nicht einkaufen? Wie auch immer. Also eine sehr gute inhaltliche Aufarbeitung und die Dokumente und Mails aus der Pandemielzeit werden von Drosten mit in das Gespräch hineingewoben. Was bedeutet, finde ich dann ganz interessant, aus der frühen Zeit. Drosten kriegt die ersten E-Mails aus China, auch mit verdeckter Kommunikation, denn die wissen, die Partei liest mit. Also verweist eine Virologin auf ihre Arbeiten zu SARS-CoV-1, um zu sagen, dieser Text ist ganz interessant und Drosten versteht, ah ja, SARS-CoV ist zurück. Mal gucken, in welcher Form. Relativ früh, also klar, es ist keine Grippe. Wir haben sehr viele Aufarbeitungen zu was auch immer, viel Studienmaterial zu Grippewellen, aber die greifen ja alle nur so halb. Der Virologe ist also alarmiert, kriegt dann die ersten Nachrichten, ah ja, in München jetzt auch schon erste Ausbrüche, ganz sanft der Virologe ist aktiviert, alarmiert, weil okay, die sind alle nicht schwer krank, aber sie sind alle krank. Wir haben sich denn infiziert. Ach so, das überträugt sich eben ohne Sichtbarkeit. Er weiß also relativ früh, Achtung, Achtung, das CDF macht eine Berichterstattung im Januar, im Februar. Er sieht das und schreibt sofort eine Mail bzw. er bekommt eine Mail aus der CDF-Redaktion, am 11. Februar, mit der Frage, ja, uns ist zu Ohren gekommen, dass Sie als Top-Virologe nicht so ganz einverstanden sind mit unserer Berichterstattung. Was sollen wir denn jetzt ändern? Haben Sie Zeit für einen Hintergrundsprecht? Drosten, so, Gespräch wird jetzt zu lange dauern. Ich schreibe sofort eine Mail zurück. Er hat innerhalb von einer Dreiviertelstunde, also eine Mail, zurück ans CDF geschrieben, die hier im Buch komplett gewürdigt wird. Ich kannte sie vorher auch nicht, aber es ist wirklich erstaunlich, was er damals schon geschrieben hat. Es gibt eine unzureichende geistige Vorbereitung der Bevölkerung auf die kommende Pandemie. Also, so steht das Wort wirklich drin. Man gewinnt den Eindruck, dass uns diese Erkrankung in Deutschland nicht betrifft, weil unsere Behörden so effizient sind und Deutschland so gut aufgestellt sei. Ist aber nicht wahr. Druckschluss der Journalisten. Und da muss man jetzt ran. All die allgemeinen Empfehlungen zum Händewaschen usw. haben in Wirklichkeit fast keine Wirkung, schreibt er. Es gibt keine Impfstoffe und keine Medikamente, auch nicht in absehbarer Zeit. Kinder sind kaum betroffen. Wenn das Virus erst einmal in der Community zirkuliert, holt man sich die Infektion im Alltag ohne erinnerbaren Kontakt mit einem Kranken. Nicht vielleicht, sondern praktisch sicher, und zwar innerhalb der nächsten paar Wochen bis Monate, haben wir eine erste Pandemiewelle in Deutschland und ganz Europa. Ich weiß, dass es schwer ist, das im Rahmen einer Nachrichtensendung zu kommunizieren. Aber bitte, machen Sie es. Er schreibt dann darüber, ich hatte noch die Idee, dass ich die Bevölkerung durch gute Information, also wenn ich den Journalisten sage, vergessen Sie alles, was Sie da machen, machen Sie es richtig. Schauen Sie mal auf Monate im Voraus, gehen Sie schon mal in die Krankenhäuser, fragen Sie nach. Sind Sie bitte darüber informiert, Sie können jetzt hier nicht Bundesliga spielen, die Landesregierungen sind dafür zuständig. Und er kriegt dann aber mit, nee, funktioniert irgendwie nicht. Erste große Enttäuschung, die Öffentlichkeit einfach nur so zu informieren und zu glauben, das reicht dann, ist nicht. Er kommt dann auf die, finde ich diesen Satz nochmal, den er da schreibt, also jedenfalls eine sehr große Enttäuschung auf seiner Seite, dass diese Öffentlichkeit, ich lag bei meiner persönlichen Einschätzung zur Freiwilligkeit von Verhaltensänderungen komplett falsch, sagt jetzt Georg Mascolo. So, also kommt es dann zu Politikberatung, der sich dahin gibt. Zuerst Merkel, dann das Innenministerium. Die Pandemie läuft, man hat so diese ersten großen Ausbrüche. Und bis heute ist ja umstritten, wie das mit den Schulschließungen war, weist Georg Mascolo darauf hin und eröffnet damit einen sehr großen Anteil dieses Buches, wo Drosten nochmal erklärt, wie das so war. Also, er wurde nach Worst-Case-Szenarien gefragt und sagte dann im Innenministerium ja, bis August 2020 15 Millionen Infizierte in Deutschland. Bei einer Krankheit, bei der man nicht weiß, wie viele sterben und so. Das ist natürlich ein Horrorszenario für Politiker, wenn irgendwie substanzielle Anteile der Bevölkerung wirklich drohen zu sterben. Sie sprachen sich ja dann für Schulschließungen aus. Nein, sagt Drosten, Mascolo selber schaut noch mal ins Protokoll, was damals Seehofer angefertigt hat. Seehofer schrieb damals oder gab es zu Protokoll. Heute kann man es nachlesen. Ich werde nie vergessen, wie zwei der namenhaftesten Virologen bei mir im Hause waren, mit allen Spezialisten, die wir im Hause haben und die These vertreten haben. Schuhschließung ist gefährlich und am nächsten Tag in der Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz muss Schuhschließung stattfinden. Also Drosten war da, es ist einer dieser zwei namenhaften Virologen. Und Seehofer wundert sich rückblickend darüber, dass sie am einen Tag sagten, Schuhschließungen sind gefährlich, weil Nebenfolgen und so weiter. Und am nächsten Tag hieß es dann aber von den gleichen angeblich, Schuhschließung muss stattfinden. Und dann sagt Drosten, diese Darstellung der Politiker ärgert mich bis heute. Er hatte in der Nacht zwischen diesen beiden Beratungsgesprächen am 12. März 0 Uhr 3 eine E-Mail bekommen von einer ihm bis dahin nicht bekannten Virologin aus Amerika, die ihn auf eine Auswertung der spanischen Grippe hinwies. In 43 amerikanischen Großstädten haben Schuhschließungen etwas gebracht und die Pandemie dort mit eingedämmt. Also hat er dieses Wissen mitgebracht in die Beratung und gesagt, wir wissen schon, es ist keine Grippe, aber bei der Grippe, die ja auch eine Infektionskrankheit und gerade über Luft übertragen und so weiter angeht, hat das durchaus etwas gebracht. Und er weist nochmal darauf hin, also er war da mit Wieler, dann dem Charité-Chef und er selbst. Und er weist nochmal darauf hin, an der Charité und auch an meinem Institut war das Thema aus einem anderen Grund präsent. Medizin ist sehr weiblich, viele junge Frauen können nicht zur Arbeit kommen, wenn die Kinder nicht in der Schule oder im Kindergarten sind. Also solche Überlegungen spielten auf deren Seite immer eine Rolle. Und dann ist aber H. Krömer, der Vorstandsvorsitzender der Charité, Lothar Wieler und er eingeladen von der Politik zu diesem zweiten Treffen. Und dort haben die dann das Problem wie am Vortag bei Merkel schon behandelt und überhaupt und kamen dann eben auch auf diese Studie zu sprechen, dass Schulschließungen bei der spanischen Grippe sehr viel geholfen hat. Und dann stellen sie fest, wie der Laden läuft, nämlich dass ihnen Politiker unter der Hand sagen, es ist eh schon entschieden, wir werden die Schulen schließen. Und Markus Söder war der Erste, der es für Bayern entschieden hat. Und niemand hielt es aus, etwas offen zu lassen, was in einem anderen Land für unverantwortlich und gefährlich gehalten wurde. Also die Politiker haben sich selber in so einen Strudel begeben. Wir drei jedenfalls, also Wieler, der Charité-Chef und er, wir drei waren jedenfalls überrascht, als wir am nächsten Tag von der Entscheidung hörten, denn das ist nicht der T in der Beratung gewesen, jedenfalls solange wir dabei waren. Und er wiederholt noch mal, was er vorher schon im Podcast immer wieder angemerkt hatte. Er wurde damals gefragt, in Heinsberg waren ja die Schulen schon zu nach dieser Kappensitzung, ob das eine gute Idee ist. Und da hat er gesagt, so wie jetzt gerade in Heinsberg, so kann man das machen, lokal reagieren, wenn man einen Ausbruch hat. Mit diesem Satz hat er diese Konferenz da verlassen und hört dann am Abend, dass die die Schulenschloss geschlossen haben und dass die Politiker immer wieder auf, wir haben uns mit den Virologen getroffen und so weiter. Und Drosten weist hier noch mal in aller Deutlichkeit darauf hin, ich habe darauf hingewiesen, wenn man einen Ausbruch hat, kann man lokal mit einer Schulschließung dagegenhalten.
Also etwas, was später auch Streeck gesagt hat und dafür ja böse bestraft wurde dann von vielen.
Ja, also im Grunde, die Heinsberg-Studie qualifiziert er später auch als, die hat keine generale Aussagekraft. Also das, was er hier auch sagt.
Ich meine, das ist jetzt so ganz auf Heisman, aber es war ja dann später bei Streeck, dass er so regionale Lockdowns sagte, wenn die dann vonnöten sind. Und da wurde er ja als völlig verrückt dargestellt.
Manuela Schwesig, die zweite, die er nennt, nach Seehofer. In einer der späteren Runden der Ministerpräsidenten sagte Manuela Schwesig, Drosten hat uns empfohlen, die Schulen zu schließen. Niemand widersprach ihr. Dann, also das hat Georg Mascolo so ins Gespräch gebracht, dann Drosten, das mag sie so gesagt haben, aber es trifft nicht zu. Am Anfang dachte ich noch an Kommunikationspannen, aber hinter vorgehaltener Hand haben mir mehrere Spitzenpolitiker später zu erkennen gegeben, dass sie die Kommunikationslinien exakt verstanden haben. Also er wird bewusst in die Pfanne gehauen, damit Politiker nicht auf ihre Kappe nehmen müssen, was jetzt ihr Sachstand ist.
Ja, wir haben das ja auch, als wir dann immer mal wieder das Thema Tests, Selbsttests und so weiter anführten, als wir über ja, erneute Lockdowns oder sowas sprachen, dann hast du ja immer Clips aus dem Drosten-Podcast mitgespielt. Und dann haben wir uns immer gewundert, dass völlig andere Meldungen daraus gemacht werden. Und offenbar waren viele Journalisten nicht mehr willens, diesen Podcast komplett zu hören und das einzuordnen. Beziehungsweise haben sie es gleich mit der herrschenden Politiker-Meinung abgeglichen und haben daraus dann die Meldung gebastelt, die man so wollte. Denn das war ja erstaunlich, dass man da Konträres hören konnte. Und dass auch gerade dieses Zero-Covid-Lager meinte, sich noch auf Drosten beziehen zu können, wo das ja gar nicht mehr der Fall sein konnte, weil im Podcast schon anderes gesagt wurde.
Also hier gibt es sehr vielen semantischen Aufklärungsbedarf. Oktober 2020, jetzt Mascolo, sagte die damalige Kultusministerin von Rheinland-Pfalz, Stefanie Hubig, folgenden Satz. Manche Leute wollen, so scheint es manchmal, dringend die Schulen schließen, damit der Rest der Gesellschaft wie bisher weitermachen kann. Ich finde, es sollte genau umgekehrt laufen. Dann sagt Drosten dazu, sehe ich ähnlich. Das ist rückblickend die Frage, er kommt dann später nochmal drauf zurück. Dann als nächstes großes Thema, erster und zweiter Lockdown. Drosten ist ja ganz scharf mit uns allen. Bei vielen in der deutschen Politik entstand im Frühjahr 2020 im ersten Lockdown der Eindruck, wir können es besser als die anderen. Also, reportiert, Mascolo, dann schließt Drosten an. Das habe ich auch so geglaubt. Es gab dieses Phänomen, dass wir im ersten Lockdown irgendwie gut durchgekommen sind. Dann kam relativ früh der Frühling und wir hatten nur 7000 Tote. Und dann gab es eine deutsche Arroganz zu sagen, wir können das ja sehr gut, guckt euch mal die Schweden an. Das sind ja alles Deppen und die Briten kriegen es ja auch nicht auf die Reihe. Und wie auch immer. Und dann kam aber der zweite Lockdown, wo die Deutschen dann so, naja, die Politik macht das schon, wie auch immer. Wir kamen beim ersten auch gut durch, plötzlich 70.000 Tote. Nichts funktioniert mehr. Es ist wirklich kurz vor Bergamo und so. Und die beiden sind sich hier ziemlich einig. Ja, das ist so diese deutsche Arroganz einfach auf Politiker-Seite. Und dann aber auch im Sommer. Und wir haben ja alle noch, also ich konnte mich dran erinnern, wie ich im Urlaub war. Und dann hieß es plötzlich, in der Zeit, Drosten, ein Plan für den Herbst. So im Sinne von, es wird einen zweiten Winter geben, obwohl es dann wieder hochkocht. Und dann alle so, nee, keine Ahnung, können wir dann abwarten und so weiter. Also es hatte irgendwie gar keine Zugkraft. Und die Inzidenz war irgendwie auch gerade erst bei drei und so. Er kritisiert hier noch sehr, die Politik hat damals die Abwägung zwischen Arbeitsstätten und Schulbetrieb nicht kommuniziert. Ich habe darauf genau geachtet, also weist Mascolo noch mal drauf hin und das sekundiert dann Drosten auch immer. Außerdem sehr Thema im Buch, die Gewinne, die nicht zugunsten der Allgemeinheit hätte man ja nutzen können. Also es gab große Gewinne der Labors bei PCR-Tests, bei Masken und so weiter. Und beide fragen sich jetzt, warum hat man dieses Geld eigentlich nicht, das sind ja Pandemie-Gewinne, dann direkt genutzt. Stattdessen kloppen wir uns bis heute darum. Außerdem ein ganz großes Thema bei ihm, er weiß, der Journalismus ist nicht in der Lage, so zu informieren, dass die Leute von sich aus handeln. Also er entscheidet, sich einen Podcast zu machen und immer weniger in Talkshows zu gehen. Er guckt die Talkshows noch, ist sozusagen nur aufgeladen, um dann in seinem Podcast ein bisschen dagegen zu halten. Also Podcast ist für ihn das Medium gewesen, ist für ihn auch immer noch, das war genau richtig, das so zu machen. Aber er musste auch zur Politik, weil, und so, und er kritisiert dann heute, dass es da gerade mal zu Gedankenaustauschen kam, keine informelle Beratung, also nichts Großes wie bei den Briten, was er die ganze Zeit lobt und betont und am Ende auch sagt, wir sollten uns bei den Briten auch mal bedanken für deren, nicht nur...
Sequenzierung und sowas.
Genau, aber auch für diese politische Art und Weise, das zu machen. Also Gespräche mit Politikern so zu begleiten, dass sie danach auch zur Verfügung stehen als Handlungsbeispiel oder wie auch immer.
Aber zugleich hat doch die Johnson-Regierung tausend Fehler gemacht.
Genau, aber Johnson mal ausgeklammert, in Großbritannien gibt es formale Gesprächszusammenhänge, auch unter Zeitdruck, auch unter Notlage zwischen Regierung und Virologie. In Deutschland nicht. Es sind Gedankenaustausche, die eher so als, ja, da gab es einen Reflektionsraum. Aus diesen Gesprächen drangen nichts nach außen, es gab kein ordentliches Protokoll, es schrieb eigentlich niemand mit. Das fand er sehr problematisch und es spitze sich immer mehr auf ihn zu, was er hier kritisiert als, naja, das ist Wissenschaft, wenn sie jetzt einfach nur meine Meinung als, weil sie glauben, ich bin der Top-Virologe, sie brauchen hier auf jeden Fall einen wissenschaftlichen Austausch, also einen Austausch unter Wissenschaftlern für Politiker. Denen hat es hier gar nicht mehr gegeben. Merkel hat dann einfach nur noch mit ihm gesprochen, hat dann daraus irgendwas abgeleitet. Und dann gab es da sozusagen, also hat man sich einfach durch den zweiten Lockdown laviert, statt eben die Erfahrung des ersten Lockdowns zu nutzen und zu sagen, wir bauen jetzt hier nach britischem Vorbild oder wie man es auch nach der Tschernobyl-Katastrophe oder sowas hatte, baut man einfach Gremien auf, die die Politik informieren. Also er sagt hier ganz deutlich, Drosten, man sollte sich in aller Form bei den Briten bedanken. Das wäre ein sinnvolles Zeichen einer politischen Pandemienacharbeitung. Über Kikolé spricht er auch kurz, denn Mascolo spricht ihn darauf an. Sie haben ja diesen Tweet gemacht mit Kikolé kann man nicht kritisieren, weil ja nichts publiziert. Und sagt Drosten, ich habe recht früh auch an prominenten Stellen betont, dass ich mit den meisten seiner fachlichen Einschätzungen übereinstimme. Es ist also, sagt er dann auch Mascolo so, ja jetzt sind Sie wieder der Journalist, der so eine kleine Episode hoch jest zum allgemeinen Wissenschaftlerstreit. Aber ich habe hier nur auf eine Äußerung, die Kikolé in einer Zeitung geäußert hat, als es um die Menge der Viren im Rachen der Kinder ging. Da hat ja Drosten selber eine Studie gemacht, die halt Kikolé kommentiert, um daraus Schlüsse zu ziehen. Bei den Drosten sagt er, die Schlüsse kann man da nicht draus ziehen. So und nur um diesen Punkt ging es ihm, stellt er jetzt nochmal klar. Später dann wird er von Mascolo gefragt, naja und dann gab es ja dieses Gespräch von der Zeit mit Lanz und Böhmermann, wo Böhmermann unter anderem Kikolé meint und sagt, Menschen verachtend.
Und Streek meint er auch.
Und da fängt Drosten das aber nicht wieder ein, obwohl er vorher Kikolé noch in Schutz genommen hat und sagt, nee, das war schon ganz gut, dass jemand wie Böhmermann da mal darauf hinweist, aber spezifisch auf, wer wird denn eigentlich von Lanz so in die Sendung eingeladen? Also ganz allgemein formuliert. Fand ich so ein bisschen dadurch.
Ja, also wie gesagt, ich finde, dass Drosten ein ungeheurer Kommunikationskünstler ist. Das ist uns ja auch schon damals aufgefallen. Aber ich finde auch, dass er das im Nachtrag dann nochmal anders sieht. Aber ich finde, dass es manchmal mehr Klarheit gebraucht hätte. Und wenn er mit der Politik ja nicht dann zufrieden gewesen wäre, hätte er ja auch nochmal deutlicher sagen können, wie auch seine ganzen Kollegen deutlich aufgetreten sind, für Schulschließungen zu sein, dann zu sagen, ich bin dagegen. Und dies hat er versäumt, in meinen Augen.
Also ich finde, man sollte von Drosten nichts verlangen, sozusagen, was nur…
Naja, aber es hatte oft den Eindruck, als würde der Status quo, der ist von Drosten auch im Podcast bestätigt werden, nicht bei allem. Also wir haben ja gerade gesagt, gerade dann mit den weiteren Pandemiewellen gab es da so eine gewisse Kluft zwischen Politik, Medien und dem, was im Drosten Podcast gesagt wurde. Aber ich würde schon sagen, dass gerade jetzt hier es schon eigentlich dem Wissenschaftler gut ansteht, da einen Böhmermann zurück zu pfeifen, der sich völlig verranntlacht.
Ich lese mal vor, wie er schrieb, dass Böhmermann in dieser Zeitdiskussion den Mut hatte, jemanden wie Lanz so anzugehen und ihm mal zu sagen, welche Positionen er da immer wieder die Bühne bereitet, das fand ich völlig in Ordnung. Und da habe ich mir dann auch in den Tweets gemacht, naja, Kikulé kannst du grad nicht meinen. Also Böhmermann hat Kikulé und Streg gemeint, während Drosten jetzt hier sagt, wen Lanz so allgemein einlädt. Und da würde ich sagen, wenn wir jetzt hier…
Reden wir jetzt darüber, dass der mal AfD-Leute da sitzen hat, dann wäre das eine andere Diskussion nicht mehr für den Beweis.
Ich meine mal, allein auf die Pandemie, also Lanz hatte eben nicht nur Leute, die auch noch mehr Lockerungen und so weiter fordern, sondern eben auch krasse Schuhschließer. Und die würde ich jetzt einfach mit einbeziehen. Also da würde ich genauso sagen, Drosten meinte auch die. Da Drosten sich hier nicht festlegt, wen er meint und Kikolé Schorr vorher schon aus dem Feuer kam.
Naja, aber es ging bei Böhmermann, der ja auch 0-0-0-Covid war, außer natürlich für seine eigene Show, die ging immer weiter, ging es ja hier nicht darum, dass Böhmermann kritisiert hat, dass Melanie Brinkmann dort sitzt und für mehr Schuhschließung ist.
Genau, das würde ich aber jetzt hier einfach mit einpreisen, da Drosten sich nicht traut, einen Namen zu nennen.
Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, also das brauchen wir jetzt nicht, den Drosten jetzt ganz in Schutz zu nehmen. Er ist da schon auch so ein merkwürdigen Böhmermann.
Also wir nehmen Drosten bei folgendem in Schutz und sagen, unser Mann. Mascolo fragt Ihnen, nennen Sie mal drei Punkte.
Also ich habe ja selbst auch nach dieser Böhmermann-Sache mit Leuten im Hotel gesessen, die aus der Medienwelt sind und die auch ganz auf der Böhmermann-Seite waren, aber trotzdem sich da in den Armen lagen und was weiß ich, ne. Also wie gesagt, ich bin da sehr allergisch.
Ja, naja, folgende Punkte. Also Sie wollten Ihre Punkte nennen, wo Sie Berichterstattung vermisst haben und heute noch vermissen. Ich bin gespannt, sagt Mascolo. Drosten sagt, ich kann Ihnen mal drei Punkte nennen, die mir persönlich fehlten. Wie wurde an der Pandemie verdient? Also PCR-Tests für 150 Euro das Stück oder so. Um welche Themen dreht sich die Pandemie-Nachbearbeitung in anderen Ländern und was war eigentlich das politisch-gesellschaftliche Ziel unserer Pandemie-Kontrolle? Hatten offene Schulen oder hatte die Wirtschaft Prioritäten?
Die Frage ist schon beantwortet.
Aber noch nicht breit mal thematisiert. Also hier kann man durchaus mal. Und haben wir unsere Ziele erreicht? Und klar, er sagt jetzt, das sind drei offene Punkte. Also wir haben unsere Ziele nicht erreicht. Er sagt für sein Metier, weil er angesprochen wird auf, sie haben ja gesagt, öffentlich sollten Wissenschaftler nur noch von ihrer Organisation beauftragt und nicht auf eigene Faust auftreten. Das hat er bei so einer WHO-Konferenz gesagt. Und er bekräftigt das hier nochmal. Ich erwarte, dass Wissenschaftskommunikation und das Rollenbild der öffentlichen Experten in Zukunft wichtige Themen werden. Die Wissenschaft ist eine Bastion gegen eines der größten Probleme unserer Zeit, die Desinformation. Was bedeutet, der wissenschaftlichen Bearbeitung der Pandemie gehört unbedingt die ausstehende, anstehende Evaluation, die er nicht kommen sieht? Von der er aber sagt, die Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler, die sich hier in Deutschland an der öffentlichen Diskussion beteiligt oder die Politik beraten haben, dürfen bei einer nachträglichen Evaluation keine Rolle spielen. Mascolo fragt also sie auch nicht, Drosten sagt keinesfalls. Also durchaus eine große Aufarbeitung, in der alle zum Objekt der Aufarbeitung werden und niemand aus dem Sprechern damals da noch eine Rolle mitspielt, sondern es wird dann einfach darüber geurteilt, was stattfand. Finde ich sehr wichtig, gerade bei Melanie Brinkmann und so, dass man da noch mal sich ordentlich zuschaut. Außerdem sagt er, bei den Briten steht auch hervor, dass sie ein National Covid Memorial Wall haben, also eine unendlich lange Mauer an der Thamse, an der alle Namen stehen können. Sofern Leute gerne ihre Verwandten, Freunde, wie auch immer, die zu Tode gekommen sind durch Corona, das gibt es in Deutschland nicht. Wir sind hier wirklich Weltmeister des Verdrängens und Vergessens.
Naja, wir verdrängen auch die Leute, die tatsächlich Long-Covid haben.
Wir verdrängen eigentlich alles.
Naja, aber das war ja das große Anliegen, zumindest in Worten von Lauterbach, sich um Long-Covid-Leute zu kümmern. Und wir haben sehr viele davon und um die wird sich ja nicht entsprechend gekümmert.
Die Masken-Sache ist einfach nur, weil es um Milliarden geht, jetzt ein Skandal. Aber die Politik versucht es so klein wie möglich zu halten.
Also man merkt dann auch so, dass die SPD da wenig angriffslustig ist. Nicht, dass da noch so ein paar andere unschöne Dinge... Also ich finde, dass die Parteien sich alle so zurückhalten bei dieser Masken-Affäre. Ich glaube, es ist einfach so eine Angst da, dass noch andere Leichen, die so im Keller liegen, aus der Covid-Zeit noch mit vorkommen.
Ein Wort noch zu neuer Pandemie, also warum so ein Buch. Sie reden kurz über die Vogelgrippe H5N1, denn die kommt in Amerika jetzt immer häufiger bei Tieren vor, also Kühen genau genommen. Kühe, das klingt besorgniserregend, sagt Mascolo und Drosten schließt an. Ja, das sind Säugetiere wie wir. Hier können Anpassungen des Virus an den Menschen beginnen. Man sollte sofort und durchgreifend die Verbreitung stoppen. Ich habe dann selber nochmal nachgeschaut, was so gerade der Sing-Sang ist in Sachen Vogelgrippe. Und in Amerika, das sieht wirklich besorgniserregend aus. Die ganze Kühstelle sind da voll, Menschen relativ nah dran. Und dann habe ich bei NTV diesen einen Virologen, der auch damals immer zugeschaltet wurde, die haben ja so ein tägliches kleines Corona-Zahlen-Update gemacht. Und der Typ meinte so, also wenn die Vogelgrippe auf Menschen umschlägt, und das macht sie ja schon, aber sich dann auch von Mensch zu Mensch weiter, dann ist erstmal Sense. Dann ist Corona wirklich nur ein Spaziergang gewesen.
Schön.
Steht nicht im Buch, aber ist sozusagen der Tenor, wenn man so bei YouTube guckt, bei den alten Experten.
Okay, wir wollen uns ein bisschen philosophisch mit dem Krieg beschäftigen. Gunnar Hindrichs hat einen Essay veröffentlicht bei CHBEC, Abseits des Krieges. Dieses Buch ist sehr gut strukturiert, weil es verschiedene Themen durchgeht. Weltgeschichte, Recht, Macht, Befreiung, Selbsterhaltung, Helden, Institutionen, Angst, Religion. So lauten die einzelnen Kapitel und es schließt dann mit Militarismus. Und zwar will dieser Philosoph uns zeigen, in welche Aporien man gerät, wenn man anfängt über den Krieg nachzudenken, wenn man sich Fragen der Macht des Rechts, der Befreiung stellt. Und er sagt zunächst einmal, leben wir, wenn wir von der Zeitenwende leben, nun in einer Kriegs-Zivilgesellschaft. Die zeigt sich daran, dass man sich die ganze Zeit positionieren muss. Man muss also in irgendeiner Weise Partei ergreifen. Und das macht es für die Philosophie gar nicht so einfach, denn man muss sich, um nicht Partei zu ergreifen, erst einmal herausbewegen und dann erst ist Reflexion möglich. Er sagt, erstens hält sich die Philosophie nicht an die Vorgaben der Kriegsparteien, auch nicht an die Vorgaben ihrer zivilgesellschaftlichen Reflexe. Stattdessen spiegelt sie die Sachverhalte von der Seite aus und sucht sie, auf Begriffe zu bringen. Nur so entzieht sie sich der Selbsteinberufung des Denkens. Das finde ich eine sehr schöne Formulierung. Zweitens aber läuft die Philosophie auch Gefahr, ins Abseits gestellt zu werden. Ja und wie kommt man daraus? Wir können natürlich jetzt nicht dieser einzelnen, sehr dichten Kapitel durchgehen. Ich will sagen, dieser Autor arbeitet im Denken dialectisch. Das macht das Lesen manchmal nicht ganz so leicht. Ich kann auch nicht alles mitgehen, was er dort erläutert, analysiert und in seinen Paradoxien vorführt. Ich will aber sagen, dass es eine sehr lesenswerte Lektüre ist, weil er sich zum Beispiel in einem Kapitel mit dem Helden auseinandersetzt. Und wir kennen diese These von Herfried Münkler. Wir leben in postheroischen Zeiten. Und dann gibt es diese Auseinandersetzung. Darauf geht er auch hier ein zwischen Münkler und Karl Schlögl. Was ist denn nun jetzt mit der postheroischen Gesellschaft gemeint? Und Hindrichs macht es dann sehr klar. Er geht nämlich darauf zurück, was Ferdinand Tönnies schrieb in Gemeinschaft und Gesellschaft. Nämlich, dass es einen Wesenwillen und einen Kürwillen gibt. Also der Wesenwillen, da gestaltet sich das Miteinander durch Sitte, Tradition, Sinn verstehen. Im Kürwillen, also da ist die Kür die Wahl entscheidend, Satzung, Vertrag, Konvention. Die postheroische Gesellschaft kennt Satzung, Vertrag, Konvention, ist aber nicht diese Art der Gemeinschaft, die über Sitte oder so geht. Und daraus schlussfolgert er dann folgendes. Was indessen ist das heroische Ideal? Nichts anderes als das Selbstopfer für eine Sache. Es steht in der Tat in keinem Widerspruch zur postheroischen Gesellschaft. Also das ist sehr interessant, denn man denkt immer postheroisch, also ohne Selbstopfer. Darum können sich innerhalb einer postheroischen Gesellschaft auch alte und neue heroische Gemeinschaften bilden. Militär, Aktivistinnen, Terrorgruppen. Und darum können sich individuelle Selbstopfer gelten machen. Lebensretterin, Krankenhauspfleger, Sozialarbeiterin. Manche sprechen von postheroischen Helden. Indessen müssen wir festhalten, in beiden Fällen handelt es sich um eine Wahl innerhalb einer auf Kürwillen beruhenden Gesellschaft und nicht um die Übernahme von Sittetraditionen Sinnverstehen einer Gemeinschaft. Das gilt nicht nur von den einzelnen postheroischen Helden. Auch der Anschluss an eine heroische Gemeinschaft innerhalb der postheroischen Gesellschaft gründet heute in einer Wahl. So sehr er von Motivlagen, Beeinflussungen oder Prägungen abhängen mag, so sehr bildet er eine Alternative unter Alternativen. Er beruht daher auf Kür und unterscheidet sich dadurch von der Teilhabe an einer wesentlichen Gemeinschaft. In diesem Zug vermag sich innerhalb einer Gesellschaft nach dem Heldentum ein neues Heldentum einzurichten. Und darum bildet das neue Heldentum der Ukraine nicht zuletzt sichtbar in seinen Bildern, Inszenierung des ukrainischen Staatspräsidenten, Ruhmes Bekundung der Massen, Eologen der Intellektuellen, keinen Einwand gegen die Diagnose postheroisch. Das war ja der ursprüngliche Streitfall zwischen Münkler und Schlögl. Man kann nun sagen, hier macht sich kein allgemeines heroisches Ideal gelten. Vielmehr erfolgt eine Wahl für das individuelle Selbstopfer. Und das ist ja genau der Diskurs, den wir die ganze Zeit finden, nämlich immer wieder wird betont, die Ukrainer wollen kämpfen. Also es ist nicht die heroische Gemeinschaft aus Sitte, sondern jetzt also die Entscheidung dazu kämpfen zu wollen. Das ist sehr gut herausgearbeitet. Ich will noch einen Punkt machen, versuche mich zu beeilen. Es ist ein bisschen kompliziert, und zwar geht er auf den Militarismus ein, wie der Militarismus nach innen und nach außen wirkt. Also der Militarismus, und damit kann man natürlich auch jetzt die aktuelle Aufrüstung verbinden, ist nicht nur eine, die sich gegen das da außen wendet, Russland, China, was auch immer, sondern auch innerlich in einem Land wird alles militarisiert. Und er sagt, man kommt dann nicht umhin, zu erkennen, dass die Staatskunst selber sich militarisiert, dass der Militarismus eine Art der Vergesellschaftstrungsweise wird, wie man es dann am deutlichsten sieht, wenn es so Debatten gibt um die Dienstpflicht. Und man konnte aber auch nicht umhin und muss über den Kapitalismus reden. Weshalb? Er geht auf die ursprüngliche Akkumulation von Marxeinsack. Ja, da wurde mit Landraub, mit Gewalt, wurde sich da Eigentum angeeignet und dann entsteht die bürgerliche Gesellschaft. Frühe Neuzeit. Dann sagt aber Rosa Luxemburg, ja Moment, ursprüngliche Akkumulation, das gab es, aber die Akkumulation geht weiter, zum Beispiel in Kolonien. Oder kann man auch noch andere Orte sich aneignen, zum Beispiel die digitale Sphäre. Also auch da haben wir weitere Akkumulationen des Kapitals. Und jetzt geht es aber noch weiter, nämlich man muss sagen, die Reproduktion des Kapitals, schreibt er, wiederum hängt vom Verhältnis der Menschen zur Natur sowie von den Verhältnissen der Menschen untereinander ab. Darum besitzt sie neben ihrer ökonomischen Bestimmtheit stets auch rein historisch-gesellschaftliche Momente. Das bedeutet, ohne äußere Bedingungen läuft der innere Wertprozess nicht. Der Kapitalismus hat immer ein Außenverhältnis. Also auch wo quasi der Kapitalismus schon überall ist, ist der Kapitalismus nicht einmal so gesetzt, sondern es gibt weitere Akkumulationsprozesse. Und das bedeutet, so schön also System, Lebenswelt und Zivilgesellschaft erscheinen, so hässlich ist ihre Grundlage. Also zeig dir mal auch den Krieg als Schatten der bürgerlichen Gesellschaft. Um sich reproduzieren zu können, verlangt das Kapitalverhältnis die andauernde Aneignung anderer Verhältnisse. Und sie erfolgt gewaltsam. Das lag am Grund der klassischen imperialistischen Kriege. Das liegt heute am Grund der Weltordnungskriege. Mit ihnen sucht man, die Reproduktionsbedingungen des Kapitals zu ordnen, im Konflikt der Großräume, Staaten oder Rackets. Hier zeigt sich zugleich der blinde Fleck in Luxemburgs Konzept. Denn sie zog den Schluss, dass der Kapitalismus eines Tages sich alle Verhältnisse einverleibt haben werde und dann zusammenbrechen müsse. Aber in Wahrheit eignet er sich sein Außen nicht nur an, er schafft auch selber immer wieder neue Außenverhältnisse. Sehen wir jetzt gerade die Blockbildung, China, USA. Man könnte sagen, es ist doch alles Kapitalismus. Nein, es gibt wieder Außenverhältnisse und zwar von beiden Seiten aus. Ganze Weltgegenden, schreibt er, werden vom globalen Kapitalismus in Wert und außer Wert gesetzt. Also innerhalb und außerhalb der Kapital-Akkumulation verortet. Entsprechend erzeugt die Reproduktion des Kapitals immer wieder Außenverhältnisse höherer Stufe. Ein Zusammenbruch aus eigener Kraft ist darum, von der bürgerlichen Gesellschaft nicht zu erwarten. Und wie die Reproduktion des Kapitals so bleiben, auch deren Kriege erhalten. Das ist eine sehr, sehr clevere, kluge, materialistische Argumentation, weil er hier nicht sagt, ja und da sind die Rüstungskonzerne und die verdienen und deswegen macht die Politik das. Der militärische-industrielle Komplex, der ist ja, wie wir wissen, im Westen doch relativ klein verglichen mit dem, was mal vor 100 Jahren war. Nein, es sind andere Verhältnisse, aber es hängt schon auch mit dem Kapitalismus zusammen. Und er bezieht sich dann auch noch mal schlussendlich auf Ahrend, um zu sagen, Handeln ist natürlich, wenn wir handeln, etwas, das wir in Pluralität tun und es bedeutet auch ein Gegenhandeln. Aber zugleich setzt auch Handeln reflektierende Urteilskraft voraus. Reflektierende Urteilskraft macht nämlich, dass aus unserem Handeln ein Handeln im Sinne eines Gemeinsinns wird. Aber beim Krieg gibt es genau das nicht. Er sagt, der Krieg zerlegt das Miteinanderhandeln, den Gegenhandeln und so verfehlt er geradewegs die Voraussetzung allen Handelns, nämlich den Gemeinsinn. Dieser Satz von Klausowitz, dass der Krieg nur die Fortsetzung der Politik mit anderen Mitteln ist, ist falsch. Sondern der Krieg ist eigentlich ein Nichthandeln. Es ist nur noch ein instrumentelles Ton. Und damit verlieren wir den Gemeinsinn. Und deswegen ist jede Philosophie über den Krieg eine, die antimilitaristisch ist. Und ich finde, dass Gunda Hintrichs hier einen vorzüglichen Essay vorgelegt hat.
Damit sind wir Brückenschlag direkt in Taiwan. Denn Klaus Badenhagen, unser Hörer, der dort wichtige Arbeit verbringt, nämlich auf Deutsch, aber natürlich nicht nur auf Deutsch, aber auch für uns Deutsche, Taiwan zu erklären, geht genau für uns auf diese Gemengelake ein. Also ja, wir können uns Krieg noch erklären im Sinne von, da hat jemand sein Gebiet abgesteckt, also gehen wir dahin und rauben ihn aus, besetzen, wie auch immer. Nur, wie ist das zu verstehen? Also wenn Taiwan einfach nur ein Gebiet wäre, das liegt nun wirklich so günstig in der See vor China, dass es auf der Hand läge, dass China da sofort einmarschieren würde. Aber es geht nicht, weil sie sich mit der ganzen Welt anlegen und auch sich selbst schädigen. Denn irgendwo kommen die Chips her und da gibt es nichts mehr zu erobern. Das könnte man nur noch zerstören. Aber da ist das Kriegsziel Eroberung, Aneignung, was auch immer, ist da nicht zu erringen. Und diese Aufschlüsselung ist doch für uns besonders von Nöten, denn es betrifft uns alle. Also was in Taiwan passiert, betrifft uns alle. Und er sagt, wenn ich mir ein bisschen Zeit nehme, beginne ich im 17. Jahrhundert. Denn kurze Antworten reichen hier nicht. Also wir haben es mit einer heute friedlichen Gesellschaft, demokratischen Gesellschaft von 23 Millionen Menschen zu tun, die da im Ozean direkt vor China leben. Und die haben Besuch bekommen von Nancy Pelosi. Das haben wir alle noch mitbekommen. Es war kurz vor oder während Corona. Ich weiß gar nicht mehr genau. Er nennt die Jahreszahl auch. Ich habe es mir gar nicht rausgeschrieben.
Nee, es war schon während Corona.
Aber genau, also Pelosi ist Besuch, wird da genannt, als der damals ranghöchste Besuch, also die Mehrheitsführerin, kommt und stattet diesem Land einen Besuch ab mit Delegation. Und spätestens durch den Angriff Russlands auf die Ukraine wissen wir, alles ist möglich. Also in kriegerischen Auseinandersetzungen ist jetzt alles möglich. Diese Gemengelage führt dazu, dass wir heute so eine unklare Lage haben, die also zu besprechen ist. Und er thematisiert die Rolle Taiwans insbesondere aus dem Lichte der UN zum Beispiel. Wir haben Corona, die Weltgesundheitsorganisation kann keine Hilfe bieten, da China, Taiwan sogar den Beobachterstatus bei Konferenzen verweigert, bei Impfstofflieferungen sind sie völlig außen vor. Da allerdings kommen ihr dann vor allem Japan und so zur Hilfe. Man fragt sich, Japan? Also es ist eine ganz interessante Geschichte. Ich fasse sie mal wie Volk zusammen. Taiwan ist Taiwan für sich eine Insel. Und dann kommt aber die chinesische große Zeit vor 500 Jahren, die nicht nur China in Folge dessen Taiwan über 200 Jahre besetzt, sondern wir haben auch so eine Problemlage, dass in dem Moment, wo China gerade durch innenpolitische Streitereien sagt, wir beenden unser Projekt als imperiale Macht auf den Meeren, entsteht dasselbe in Europa. Also die Zeit der Kolonialismus beginnt. Und China stellt fest, so ganz geht dieser Rückzug dann doch nicht. Wir kloppen uns hier jetzt plötzlich mit Frankreich in Stellvertreterkriegen. Irgendwas findet ja noch in Korea statt. Dann gibt es irgendwelche Abmachungen. Wir geben euch Korea, dafür kriegen wir aber Taiwan. Also gibt es große friedliche Übergaben von China an Japan nach 200 Jahren. Also folgen auf 200 Jahren chinesische Besetzung, 50 Jahre japanische Besetzung und so weiter. Also es ist im Grunde ein Land, von dem wir, wenn wir heute über ein unabhängiges, demokratisch organisiertes Gemeinwesens sprechen, sagen, ja das ist für die auch sehr neu und die können das auch genau so einschätzen als für uns sehr neu. Also der Begriff Errungenschaft ist hier wirklich so gemeint. Das ist nicht einfach wie bei uns in Europa so, ja das gab halt so eine wilde Geschichte, keine Ahnung, kann man noch mal reingucken, aber dann ist es passiert. Sondern nein, die letzten diktatorischen Amtsanmaßungen hat man selber dort abgeschüttelt vor 30 Jahren. Also es ist einfach eine lange Zeit der Diktaturen. Jetzt gab es inzwischen dreimal friedliche demokratische Machtwechsel. Was bedeutet, wir haben es hier mit einer stabilen demokratischen Regierung zu tun, nachdem man da Jahrhunderte von den Qing und den Japanern und wie auch immer anders regiert und besetzt wurde, auch wenn man nie so eine 100 Prozent Regentschaft, also es wurde nicht bis unter die Bette geregiert, sondern Taiwan blieb immer Spielball. Und jetzt haben wir diese neue Phase, in der Taiwan nicht nur demokratisch organisiert ist, sondern damals auch ganz gezielt diese Art der Fabrik errichtete, die für andere deren Chips herstellt, weil das Design von Chips und das Herstellen von Chips doch einen großen Unterschied macht und da so eine globale Arbeitsteilung stattfindet, von der wirklich alles abhängt. Also alles einfach. In dieser modernen Zeit hängt alles davon ab, dass es dort Friedrich bleibt. Friedrich bleibt, wir müssen es also auch zu unserem Thema machen. Er schreibt ja, in den 1980ern wurde die Demokratie erstritten und gefestigt und sie ist heute völlig unabhängig von China. Die Details, warum einzelne Journalisten immer noch anders schreiben, warum die UN eine andere Sprachlegung vorgibt, warum das mit der Realität und der Geschichte nichts zu tun hat, kann man nachlesen. Ich will nur mal eine Szene rausnehmen. Der Film Top Gun Maverick ist ja ein Film, der an eine– wie alt ist der erste Film, 40 Jahre oder was? Also der überspannt ein bisschen Zeit. Wir wissen, vor 40 Jahren war es in Taiwan noch anders. Keine Chipfabriken, keine Demokratie. Tom Cruise hatte heute, weil sie erinnern wollen an den Filmen damals, die gleiche Jacke wie im Originalfilm von 86 an. Und er schreibt jetzt aufmerksame Beobachter stellten fest, von einem Aufnäher waren die Flakken der Republic of China und Japans verschwunden im Trailer. Dann dauerte es ein Jahr, der Film kam ins Kino, die beiden Aufnäher waren wieder auf der Jacke. Was bedeutet, dieser Film wurde in China nie gezeigt. Allein durch solche kleinen Sachen. Also hier sieht man an solchen Beispielen, wie hart da gerungen wird. Leider macht Klaus keinen Hinweis darauf, wie wahrscheinlich Angriffsszenarien sind unter der Beobachtung. Es findet gerade viel semantisches Trailer und Theater statt. Was ja für uns auch signalisieren könnte. Ah ja gut, die wissen also, ihre Kampffront ist sozusagen Hollywood und ganze Semantikbetrieb. Aber nicht so sehr, dass sie jetzt wirklich ihre Armee beauftragen. Das marschiert doch mal ein. Aber er beschreibt auch, wo diese ganzen wichtigen Linien verlaufen, also geografisch, die überschritten wurden. Nach dem Nancy-Pelosi-Besuch, wo es vorher undenkbar war, dass Schiffe über die Grenze fahren. Aber jetzt sind die da dauerhaft und machen auch ihre Militärübung. Fliegen da rum, verletzen die Lufträume und so weiter. Also China nähert sich da schon.
Aber die Frage ist ja dann, ob dieser Pelosi-Besuch sinnvoll war. Im Sinne Thais war oder ob es besser dem Land getan hätte, wenn sie es nicht besucht hätte.
Ganz große Paradoxien, weil wir können ja jetzt nicht sagen, die Chinesen bedrohen uns und wir kuschen. Weil dann wäre es nicht sinnvoll gewesen. So irgendwie. Auf der anderen Seite muss man so viel üben im Meer, um dann den Land zu überfallen. Also das könnte man wahrscheinlich auch ohne zehn Jahre vorher der Übung stattgefunden haben. Also ich lese mal im Wortlaut, das Ende finde ich dann in seiner Offenheit doch vielsagend, denn die für uns wichtigen Fragen kriegen wir nicht beantwortet. Am Ende hängt es wohl vor allem von Xi Jinping ab, ob der inzwischen fast allmächtig befiehlt. Was aus der realen Welt überhaupt noch zu ihm durchdringt, das ist eine große Frage. Man kann davon ausgehen, dass er der Volksbefreiungsarmee den Auftrag erteilt hat, sich auf eine Invasion vorzubereiten. Aber wir wollen auch davon ausgehen, dass der Machterhalt der KP die höchste Priorität hat. Ob Xi wirklich für Taiwan alles riskieren würde, dass er für einen Angriff nur einen Versuch hat, dürfte er wissen und sich den Zeitpunkt genau aussuchen. Also auch Klaus mit allen Einsichten, die er davor hat, weiß nicht so recht. Aber ich halte es auch für sehr wichtig, dass wir hier Fokus auf Taiwan legen, unabhängig davon, dass es fast auf der Rückseite des Mondes liegt. Denn die Containerschiffe, die nun alles, was uns wichtig ist, sind nur ein paar Wochen unterwegs. Also die Welt ist da sehr klein und sehr in Gefahr.
Wir blicken nochmal auf den Krieg und zwar in der Ukraine. Simon Zeise, zuständig für Wirtschaft und Geopolitik in der Berliner Zeitung, hat einen Artikel veröffentlicht, der den Titel trägt, Blackrock will sein Geld zurück, ukrainische Oligarchen profitieren von westlicher Hilfe. Und dieser Artikel beginnt wie folgt. In der vergangenen Woche sind erneut Gespräche der ukrainischen Regierung mit internationalen Investoren gescheitert, in denen Kiev um eine Verlängerung der Rückzahlungsfrist und einen teilweise Schuldenerlass gebeten hat. Die Gespräche wurden zwischen dem 3. und dem 14. Juni hinter verschlossenen Türen geführt, wie das ukrainische Finanzministerium diese Woche mitteilte. Die Anleihegläubiger haben seit 2022 keine Zahlung mehr von der Ukraine erhalten. Mit dem Beginn der russischen Invasion hatten sie einem zweijährigen Moratorium zugestimmt. Nun aber wollen BlackRock, aber auch der französische Fonds Amundi die britische Anleger Amia Capital so langsam mal Geld sehen. Die Ukraine hätte aber eigentlich gerne einen Schuldenschnitt, einen sogenannten Herkert, und zwar von 60 Prozent. Damit sind aber BlackRock und die anderen Gläubiger nicht einverstanden. Sie sagen also, 20 Prozent, das sei machbar, aber 60 Prozent nicht. Also wir sehen hier schon, man unterstützt die Ukraine sehr wohl, aber jetzt nicht so bedingungslos. Also man sagt, andere sollen das Leben dafür geben, aber wir selbst, ein Herkert jetzt 60 Prozent, nee, immer lieber nicht. Der IWF hat, heißt es dann hier, mit der ukrainischen Regierung vereinbart, dass das Verhältnis der Staatsverschuldung zum Protoinlandsprodukt bis 2033 auf 60 Prozent sinken soll. Im vergangenen Jahr lag die Schuldenquote bei 82 Prozent. Ende 2024 dürfte die Schätzung zufolge sie mehr als 94 Prozent betragen. Wie kann man also dagegen angehen, was wird da vorgeschlagen? Wir ahnen es, Privatisierung von Staatsunternehmen. Man möchte nämlich die westliche Hilfe an ein drastisches Strukturanpassungsprogramm knüpfen. Das sagt hier der Ökonom Frederic Mousseau vom amerikanischen Oakland Institute. Das heißt also, man neoliberalisiert jetzt während der Ukraine im Krieg, ist schon mal die Ukraine. Du hast ja auch schon gesagt, die jungen Leute müssten ja mal wissen, wofür sie kämpfen. Die kriegen jetzt also das, was wirklich dem Staat gehört, was sie noch verteidigen als Staat. Das löst sich jetzt so gerade auf, weil schon diese Strukturanpassungsprogramme vorgenommen werden.
Das ist wirklich eine ökonomische Invasion in dieses Land. Wir kritisieren, dass Russland sich da einfach was nimmt, was nicht Russland gehört. Wenn jetzt kommt BlackRock und sagt, es gehört ja uns und wir sagen, das gehört nicht euch und keiner widerspricht. Das ist ja grotesk.
Ukraine, Kornkammer Europas. Da gibt es eine Studie dazu. Diese Struktur-Anpassungsprogramme laufen ja schon länger. Da heißt es in einer Studie, mit 33 Millionen Hektar Ackerland verfügt die Ukraine über große Teile des fruchtbarsten Ackerlandes der Welt. Zeise schreibt es, doch fehlgeleitete Privatisierung und korrupte Regierungsführung seit den frühen 1990er-Jahren hätten das Land in den Händen einer neuen oligarchischen Klasse konzentriert. Rund 4,3 Millionen Hektar werden demnach im großen Stil landwirtschaftlich genutzt. Der Großteil aber, nämlich 3 Millionen Hektar, befinden sich in den Händen von nur einem Dutzend großer Agrarunternehmen. So, da kann man sich natürlich denken, wem gehören die? Ukrainische Oligarchen?
Ja.
Und dann gibt es noch ausländische Investoren. Unter anderem diesen Staatsfonds von Saudi-Arabien, dann gibt es Private-Equity-Fonds, alle sind da so mit drin.
Könnte BlackRock nicht einfach Blackwater beauftragen, um da die Felder frei zu schießen?
Von den Oligarchen kommt dem ukrainischen Staat und auch der Bevölkerung wenig zugute. Neun der zehn größten Landlords in der Ukraine sind der Studie zufolge im Ausland registriert. Hauptsächlich in Offshore-Zentren wie Zypern oder Luxemburg.
Ja, aber zum Glück wurden bei den Panama Papers alle freigesprochen, weil unschuldig.
Die Firmen sind zum größten Teil an der Börse notiert. Westliche Banken und Investmentfonds kontrollieren dadurch einen erheblichen Anteil ihrer Aktien. Ja, dann ein norwegischer Staatsfonds spielt auch noch eine Rolle. Weiter. Dann heißt es hier noch vom Auckland-Institut, der sagt, die Kleinbauer werden dazu getränkt, ihr Land an große Eigentümer zu verkaufen. Für ausländische Investoren ist das Engagement sehr rentabel, da die Agrarunternehmen, an denen sie sich beteiligen, über großen Landbesitz verfügen und in der Lage sind, in großem Maßstab zu produzieren und zu exportieren. Dann geht es noch um einen Oligarchen, der hat so ein Geflügel-Imperium, der wird der Hühnchenkönig genannt. Also der allein besitzt 60 Prozent der ukrainischen Geflügelproduktion.
Es ist also sehr gut, dass wir da Krieg führen, dass wir die Ukraine verteidigen gegen die russischen Invasoren.
Ja, also man muss wirklich mal gucken, was ist eigentlich da in der Ukraine los. Mehr können wir gar nicht dazu sagen.
Und ihr dachtet, ihr habt jetzt keine gute Laune mehr. Doch ein bisschen war noch übrig, denn jetzt fege ich sie euch davon. Armut und soziale Probleme lassen sich nicht strafrechtlich lösen. Ein Text von Nils Seibert in ND Aktuell, also Neues Deutschland. Ich bin drauf gekommen, weil Stefan Niggemeier den getwittert hat. Er ist vom April. Er beginnt so. 50 Tagesätze in Höhe von jeweils 15 Euro, also 750 Euro Geldstrafe, für eine Bürgergeldempfängerin, die Salamis im Gesamtwert von 7,58 Euro im Rewe-Supermarkt aus Versehen nicht aufs Band gelegt hat, wie sie vor Gericht sagt, denn wir sind hier vor Gericht. 100 Tagesätze A, 15 Euro, für fahren ohne Führerschein. Vier Monate Haft ohne Bewährung gibt es für eine Mutter von vier Kindern, darunter ein fünf Monate altes Baby, für den Versuch, für 47,57 Euro bei Netto Sachen mitzunehmen, ohne sie zu bezahlen.
Was? Das gibt es doch gar nicht.
70 Tagesätze, 15 Euro, also 2.100 Euro insgesamt, für den gemeinschaftlichen Diebstahls von Kinderkleidung im Verkaufswert von 205 Euro bei Primark. Die Angeklagten werden hier wie am Fließband abgearbeitet. Das ist die Außenstelle des Berliner Amtsgerichts. Das tagt einfach zweimal die Woche so im Einzugsgebiet der Leute, die da Hilfe brauchen, also Hilfe in Anführungszeichen, weil sie soziale Probleme haben. Fast immer geht es um Diebstahl geringwärtiger Sachen oder Fahren ohne Fahrschein. Es werden bis zu 15 Verfahren an einem Vormittag terminiert und abgearbeitet. Von August 2022 bis Februar 2024 besuchte er 180 solcher Termine, über die er dann geschrieben hat. 100 wurden tatsächlich verhandelt, beim Rest waren so Termine und man muss ja dann auch vorstellig sein, wenn da jemand nicht kommt und so wird das dann vertagt und dann wird später aus der Vorladung kommt dann die Polizei hol dich ab. 93% der öffentlichen Verhandlungen endeten mit Verurteilungen zu Geld- oder Haftstrafen. Kein einziges Mal kam es zu einer Einstellung gegen Sozialstunden oder einer Verwarnung mit Strafvorbehalt. Viele der Angeklagten standen zum ersten Mal vor Gericht. Was bedeutet, die haben dann gar keine Ahnung, was da passiert. Diejenigen, die schon häufiger da waren, wissen dann auch nicht, was passiert. Aber das Gericht weiß, was dann passiert. Nämlich, wir setzen noch mal eins drauf. Also es kommt zu immer höheren Strafen, immer höheren Geld- und Haftstrafen. Selbst wenn die Betroffenen seit ihrer Tat eine radikale Lebensveränderung hinter sich haben, beispielsweise ihre Drogenabhängigkeit überwunden, einen Arbeitsplatz gefunden oder einen Umzug in soziales Milieu, also ein soziales Milieu verlassen haben durch Umzug, oder eine Familie gegründet haben, nein, Rückfälligkeit wird immer mit höheren Strafen behandelt. Ich habe den Eindruck, bei ihnen kann man noch etwas retten. Begründet im Frühjahr 2023 die Amtsanwältin ihr Plädoyer für eine zweimonatige Haftstrafe auf Bewährung, gehe wegen versuchten Diebstahls eines Shampoos im Wert von 4,40 Euro. Es gab acht Verurteilungen wegen Fahrens ohne Führerschein. Bei dem einen summierten sich seit 2008 mehrere Geldstrafen auf 11.000 Euro. Das sind dann so Strafen, die können das nicht bezahlen. Die gehen dann dann tageweise ins Gefängnis.
Was den Staat sehr viel Geld kostet.
Was den Staat extrem viel Geld kostet, also mit 300 Euro am Tag oder so, ist man da bestimmt erst dabei. Ich lese mal, was ich mir hier markiert hatte. Sie sind auch aufrichtig, wieder mehrfach wegen Fahrens ohne Fahrschein. Verurteil der AE20, weiß ich wieder, warum ich mich missmarkiert habe. Also ein verurteilter Fliesenleger, der von einer Richterin gefragt wird, wie sind Sie näher gekommen, bei den Öffentlichen? Haben Sie einen Fahrschein? Nein, aber kein Geld. Und ich muss ja hierherkommen. Es ist wirklich haarstreifend. Aber das wird dann da geklärt. Urteil, vier Monate Gefängnis. Die Menschen, die vor Gericht stehen, sagen immer mal wieder Hunger, kein Geld, das ist immer die gleiche Leier eigentlich.
Naja, wer für 2,40 Euro den Shampoo klaut.
Die Staatsanwaltschaften und die Richter sind dessen überdrüssig, also da wird einfach gar nicht mehr, ach ja, pff, ist mir doch egal. Der Autor schreibt dann, die Menschen brauchen ja eigentlich was anderes als ein Gerichtsverfahren. Es ist aber nichts anderes da. Der Staat repräsentiert sich in dem Moment als Anklager und Urteiler. Er beschreibt dann so ein paar Szenen, wie demütig diese Menschen vor diesem Gericht landen. Also der Saal ist über 100 Quadratmeter groß, die kommen dann da so reingeführt und dann wird sofort mündlich eröffnet, die wissen dann gar nicht, wie sie, und dann, darf ich meine Jacke ausziehen? Solche Fragen sind dann, darf ich meine Tasche abstellen? Also es sind sehr verunsicherte Blicke, die dann an die Richter gewandt werden, wenn die Richter so völlig genervt sind von solchen Sachen. Diese Gesprache vor Gericht ist viel zu kompliziert, niemand versteht irgendwas, es wird nur noch in Abkürzungen gesprochen und es sind sowohl Grundwortschatz der Juristen, den wirklich dann niemand hier versteht, vor allem, wenn die selber in so einem Sing-Sang dann drin sind. Und er beschreibt dann hier immer wieder die Szenerie, die Staatsanwaltschaft liest vor, was sie beantragt. Das heißt dann zum Beispiel 120 Tagesätze zu 10 Euro. Und dann ruft der Angeklagte rein, ah, damit bin ich anverstanden. Weil er gar nicht versteht, dass das erst mal nur der Antrag ist und noch nicht das Urteil. Oder eine Beschuldigte hört einfach nur 60 Tagesätze zu 15 Euro. 15 Euro? Einverstanden. Also die verstehen wirklich gar nicht, was hier passiert.
Das ist mal 60, ja.
Kaum einer eigentlich nie kommt mit einem Anwalt, sondern wird immer einer zugeteilt, einen Beigeordneter. Die Anwälte beschreibt dann hier so eine Richterin, die reinkommt, eine junge Richterin unter 30, die dann dem Protokoll folgend einfach vorliest, wer ist denn hier da. Dann kommt die Staatsanwaltschaft und sagt, ich finde es nicht so gut, dass sie hier meinen Namen vor Gerichten nennen. Und dann beobachtet er, wie die Richterin beim nächsten Mal einfach die Namen nicht mehr vorliest. Also hier wird auch einfach recht gebeugt. Wir haben ein Mündlichkeitsprinzip, hier wird protokollmäßig mitgeschrieben und eigentlich soll klar sein, im Urteil steht ja auch drin, wir hatten ja eigentlich verhandelt und so. Aber ja, wir würden einfach so auf eigene Faust das halt so wegformulieren. Also es ist wirklich haarsträubend. Wenn Angeklagte vor Gericht von diesen Schwierigkeiten erzählen wollen, die sie dazu brachten, heißt es einfach nur, das tut nichts zur Sache. Damit ist das raus aus der mündlichen Verhandlung, raus aus dem Protokoll. Er schließt mit dem Satz, die Richterinnen und Richter interessieren diese Menschen einfach nicht. Und er verweist darauf, dass er am 9. April, also es gibt einen zweiten Text zum Thema, wo er dem noch mal weiter nachgeht. Aber das ist wirklich haarsträubend, was man hier liest, weil man sitzt so ein bisschen daneben, also so als Leser und denkt sich, eher kein Wunder. Also das ist einfach völlig klar, dass diese Leute dann drei Monate später wieder vor Gericht landen. Niemand, also die wissen gar nicht, wie ihnen geschieht. Die verlassen dann einfach diesen Saal und müssen dann erst im Brief, also es wurde auch immer wieder auf diesen Brief verwiesen, wenn irgendwer noch Fragen hat, hier ist die Post, da steht alles drin. Das ist wirklich ist haarsträubend, so was zu lesen. Das sind diese Einblicke, die wir heute von Niko Semsrott ins Parlament und hier in diesen Strafvollzug, nicht Strafvollzug, sondern diese Gerichtsbarkeit bekommen haben, sind wirklich nicht gut.
Ja, ich finde, man sollte da jetzt mal ihren Spahn hinsetzen und den mal genauso behandeln und sein mit den Masken. Hier war eben eine Dame, die hat ein Shampoo geklaut. Bei Ihnen gibt es irgendwie ein Problem mit den ganzen Masken.
Das sind ja ungefähr eine Milliarde Shampoos, die sie geklaut haben. Das waren vier Monate Haft. Was kriegen sie? 15.000 Jahre Haft, wir hier in Spanien.
Ich will noch schnell ein Buch empfehlen, und zwar Das Erbe der Menschheit und andere Geschichten von Shi Hui. Sie ist eine chinesische Science-Fiction-Autorin im Maro-Verlag. Erzählungen sind nun erschienen, zum Beispiel von neuen Spezies, die entstanden sind, von neuen Völkern irgendwo in der Welt, dort draußen in der Welt des Weltalls. Dort ist dann zum Beispiel ein Volk, das nie Widerstand leistet. Dann haben wir eine Erzählung, die heißt Der Algorithmus der Artifiziellen. Der spielt in der Zukunft natürlich und es wird unterschieden zwischen den Artifiziellen und den Echten. Von den Echten gibt es aber nur ganz wenige. Dann gibt es eine Geschichte von unserer Erde, die sich auch stark verändert hat, denn sie hat einen weiteren Kontinent hinzubekommen. Auf diesem Kontinent sieht man nur Müll, denn es ist ein Müllkontinent. Aus all dem Müll, der in den Meeren schläft, hat sich ein eigener Kontinent gebildet, der fast so groß ist wie die USA. Eine Forscherexpedition ist da unterwegs und will herausfinden, was da so los ist. Plötzlich geschieht dort etwas Eigenartiges. Das ist der einzige Abschnitt, den ich daraus vorlesen möchte. Das Expeditionsteam beginnt, eigentlich seine Sachen zusammenzupacken. Bai Lan, die ihre eigene Ausrüstung schon verstaut hat, ist gerade dabei, ins Maisfeld zu gehen, um weitere Proben zu nehmen, als sie plötzlich stehen bleibt. Im Schatten eines Müllhaufens brennt eine kleine Flamme. Sie sieht, wie eine Ratte mit ihren Vorderpfoten ein Stück Plastik nimmt und ins Feuer legt, um die Flamme zu füttern. Eine weitere Ratte rollt mit ihrem Schwanz einen Zweig ein und hält ihn in die Flamme. Als dieser zu brennen beginnt, hebt sie die winzige Fackel vorsichtig hoch und verschwindet damit in einem Loch. Bai Lan hält den Atem an. Ihr ganzes Leben lang hat sie Ratten studiert, aber noch nie eine solche Intelligenz bei den Tieren beobachtet. Sie erkennt, dass es sich um das Feuer handelt, das sie in der vergangenen Nacht gesehen hatte, und dass es nicht von Menschenhand entfacht wurde. Sie beißt sich auf die Lippe und geht vorsichtig rückwärts Schritt für Schritt, ohne die Ratten zu stören. Es sind wirklich ganz interessante Geschichten, die hier erzählt werden, weil sie Bekanntes oder schon Gedachtes dann verschieben hin zu etwas, was neuartig ist. Ich habe das mit großem Vergnügen gelesen und kann es auch deshalb empfehlen.
Ein letzter Text. Das ist ja gar nicht so lang.
Nein, es sind kurze Geschichten, so 30 Seiten, immer eine Geschichte lang. Überhaupt, glaube ich, chinesische Science-Fiction-Literatur sollte man ein bisschen mehr rezipieren. Ich kenne mich da aber auch nicht gut genug aus. Das war eher so ein Zufallsfund. Nun noch ein letzter Text von Ariel Dom erschienen in der britischen Vogue-Ausgabe. Es geht ums Dating. Wie datet man heute, wenn man nicht mehr nur sich auf Dating-Apps herumtreiben will? Beim Lauftreff. Die Autorin schreibt, Sport und Sex sind zwei Dinge, die ich noch nie miteinander in Verbindung gebracht habe. Aber im Jahr 2024 habe ich das Gefühl, in der Minderheit zu sein. Ein neuer TikTok-Trend hat die Plattform im Sturm erobert. Schwärme von sonnengebräunten Muskel, bepackten Content-Erstellern, die Videos von ihren dampfenden Gruppenläufen teilen, argumentieren, dass Lauftreffs nicht nur der perfekte Weg sind, um fit zu werden, sondern auch der beste Weg, um mit anderen heißen und verschwitzten Singles ins Bett zu gehen. Dating-Apps, Tinder und Thursday sind sogar auf den Zug aufgesprungen und haben ihre eigenen Laufveranstaltungen gestartet. Singles Weekly und Soulmates. Ja, also Run-Clubs sind jetzt das neue Ding, so heißt es hier zumindest, also im urbanen Raum. Eine, die hier mitläuft und datet, Bess29 sagt beim Reden, würden organische Verbindungen entstehen. Man konzentriert sich nicht nur darauf, ein Gespräch zu führen, man macht auch noch etwas anderes, das nimmt den Druck weg. Denn in der normalen Dating-Situation sitzt man ja oft da und sagt, oh, jetzt ist Dating. Aber hier muss man auch sehen, dass die anderen Dinge funktionieren. Man läuft und was weiß ich, was man da alles beachten muss. Du merkst schon an der Art, wie ich darüber rede. Ich glaube, meine Sache wäre es nicht so. Ich könnte vorschlagen, schon mal mit dem Auto vorzufahren. Denn danach geht man noch in einen Club oder isst noch etwas gemeinsam.
Direkt nach dem Laufen?
Ja, also man geht nicht sofort nach Hause, sondern man muss ja dann noch weiter ins Gespräch kommen. Hier schreibt die Autorin, es macht durchaus Sinn, dass der Hype um den Run-Club im Jahr 2024 stattfindet. Denn hier prallen Dating-App-Müdigkeit und nüchterne Neugier aufeinander. In den letzten Jahren hatten Partnervermittlungs-Apps Mühe, junge Nutzer davon zu überzeugen, für ihre Dienste zu bezahlen. 79% der College-Studenten wenden sich von den Apps ab und treffen sich lieber persönlich. Einer von fünf Gen Z und Millennials hat bei einem ersten Date zusammen trainiert. Keine schlechte Quote, fast ein Drittel ein Fitnessstudio, einem Kneipentreffen vorgezogen. So hat es eine Studie von Bumble ergeben. Sie läuft dann da auch mit im St. James Park. Es ist ein 5-Kilometer-Lauf, das ist ja dann nicht so weit.
Ja, das ist weit. 5 Kilometer ist weit.
Ja, ich will sie jetzt nicht laufen, aber es ist jetzt ja kein Marathon.
Ein Marathon ist so weit, dass das normale Menschen gar nicht schaffen.
Das ist natürlich klar, aber 5 Kilometer scheint mir schaffbar zu sein, wenn man einigermaßen sportlich ist. So. Und eine, Sarah heißt sie, sie ist Kommunikationsberaterin, die sagt, man taucht einfach etwas weniger gefiltert auf, als man es vielleicht tun würde, wenn man jemanden über eine App trifft. Also man gibt ja dann direkt viel Preis und das würde dann eigentlich die Kommunikation ermöglichen. Sie sagt dann, dass sie jetzt das so alles mal da beobachtet hat und schließt damit, vielleicht war es nicht das Challenger-Niveau, das ist dieser Film jetzt mit Zendaya, den Tennis-Film, wo die toll trainierten Körper ausgestellt werden, aber für alle, die auf der Suche nach echten Gesprächen ohne den Schutzschild von Alkohol oder kitschigen App-Aufforderungen sind, könnte ein Laufklub der perfekte Ort sein, um anzufangen.
Yes, ich glaube ja, keiner trifft mehr irgendwer irgendwo, irgendwen und alle sind nur noch enttäuscht, aber...
Stimmt gar nicht. Die Leute machen Sport und treffen sich wohl da.
Ich finde das auf jeden Fall, wie soll man sagen, die Datings, ich würde es mal gar nicht so als, das ist so online und so weiter, sondern dieser Fake-Anteil. Dehende Bilder, keine Ahnung, ist das überhaupt das Kriterium, dass es geht? Also in einer Sekunde jemanden in Bewegung zu sehen, da ist ja die Bandbreite der Informationsübermittlung, die dann auch Gefühle auslässt, sehr viel höher, als da hat jemand fünf Bilder von sich ausgewählt aus dem Urlaub. So, und ich habe letztens auch darüber nachgedacht, der Auswahl, also man braucht ja mal so einen strukturellen Auswahlprozess. Und der Sport eignet sich da besonders gut, weil er auf so einer gewissen Art ehrlich ist. Wer fünf Kilometer laufen kann, kann auch ganz schön viele andere Sachen, die man nicht mehr einfach so voraussetzen kann, weißt du? Weil kleinste, unschärfende, keine Ahnung, du hast dir die Hand verletzt, irgendwas tut weh, keine Ahnung, zu viel Gewicht und schon kannst du nicht mehr laufen. Also du fällst einfach aus diesem Raster raus und von daher finde ich das gar nicht so schlecht. Die Frage ist halt nur, was ist mit den anderen? Wenn du jetzt sagst, fünf Prozent laufen, das ist dann die Dating-Gelegenheit für die sieben Prozent.
Einer von fünf.
Naja, also grundsätzlich.
Aber klar.
Menschen würden jetzt gesagt, geht laufen. Da würde ich sagen, also für 93 Prozent ist das kein Tipp.
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Weil die tauchen nicht da auf und laufen plötzlich fünf Kilometer. So, also es ist da so eine gewisse elitäre Note drin, die aber finde ich ganz interessant ist, denn sportliche Herausforderungen bewältigt man oder nicht. Kannst du nicht plötzlich einfach fünf Kubikmeter mehr Motor kaufen oder sonst irgendwie rumfaken, sondern entweder du kannst es oder nicht.
Sport ist ja etwas, was man nicht über Geld regeln kann. Also man kann natürlich ins teure Fitnessstudio, man kann mit Personal-Teile arbeiten, aber man muss es selbst machen, man kann nicht sagen, ich habe mir jetzt jemand angestellt, der für mich läuft. Ich kann mir jemanden anstellen, der mich fährt oder der für mich das Haus saubert oder kocht.
Es gibt kein Outsourcing bei diesem Entscheidungskriterium, Auswahlkriterium, das hier maßgeblich ist. Das ist schon ganz interessant, dass man heute diesen Weg, und ich würde sagen nicht gegen online irgendwas, sondern gegen Fake, antritt.
Dann hören wir uns Ende des Monats und sind gespannt, was so alles auf uns zukommt.
Ob die Welt noch da ist nach Ampelstreit, englischem Regierungswechsel und Königs-Proklamationen in Amerika.